ARE GOING TO CALL THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET --
SUB SIX AND THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION.
COMMITTEE TO ORDER COULD WE
OUNCE OF THE A GASP IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
PLEASE --
COMPORT.
LET ME JUST START OFF WITH --
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS AND JUST
THINK MY ARM --
A CO CHAIRMAN MISTER FRAZIER WHO
CHAIRS ARE SIMPLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
ALSO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PRESIDENT MISTER PATTERSON WHO.
ARE ALSO HAS RAISED THE ISSUE OF
BOTH LOCALLY AND STATEWIDE.
HARM COULD KILL MY MOST RECENT
EXPERIENCE GOVERNMENT VOEPEL
MOTOR VEHICLES WAS A LITTLE BIT
--
SHOCKING BECAUSE I WENT.
TO LIKE MANY CALIFORNIANS RENEW
MY DRIVER'S LICENSE A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO BY LOCAL SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICE.
AND WAS SURPRISED TO SEE
ALLOWING GOING AROUND THE BLOCK.
AND UNLIKE MOST ROCK CONCERTS
WHICH WE HAVE AN OCCASIONAL LINE
OF PEOPLE WAITING.
TO SEE THEIR FAVORITE SHOW --
I WAS TOLD THAT PEOPLE STE.
SAM THE MORNING. TO TAKE CARE OF
ORDINARY BUSINESS AND THAT THIS
WAS SOMETHING THAT HAD BEEN
HAPPENING QUITE REGULARLY
UNFORTUNATELY --
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO THE RELIEF
[inaudible]
TAKE OUT.
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATIONS WE APPROPRIATED
FOR THE PROMOTED VEHICLES
AFFECTED JULY FIRST --
DE UP BELIEF ABOUT ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED POSITIONS THAT WERE
ALLOCATED IN THE BUDGET --
HOW THOSE POSITIONS HAVE BEEN --
ALLOCATED THAT THE TIMING OF PA
BRINGING THEM ONLINE WHERE THEY
HAVE BEEN --
WHERE THEY'VE BEEN PLACED IN DMB
OFFICES AROUND THE STATE?
AS WELL AS REALLY WHAT THE PLAN
IS TO REDUCE THE WAIT TIMES
WE'VE BEEN HEARING.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT --
RESIT CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO
ARE GOING IN WITHOUT AN
APPOINTMENT HAVE WE TIME TO TALK
TO SIX SEVEN OR EIGHT HOURS
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY.
UNACCEPTABLE.
รณ WE KNOW THAT WITH THE REAL
AYE.
THAT THE REQUIREMENTS ARE VERY
VERY DIFFERENT THAT WE NOW HAVE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
BEFORE WOULD JUST RENEW THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSES BY MAIL NOW.
CARBON DOING THEM HAVE TO RENEW
THEM IN PERSON LIKE MYSELF.
AND SO THAT THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
CAUSING A STRAIN WE ALL WE WANT
TO KNOW ON AGAIN DID WE ESTIMATE
CORRECTLY THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO HAD TO COME FORWARD INTO D.
M. V..
AS WELL AS DO WE ESTIMATE THE
TRANCE THOUGH TRANSACTION TIME.
THAT IT WOULD TAKE TO PROCESS
EACH OF THESE ARE APPLICATIONS I
KNOW MY DISCUSSION WITH THE
DIRECTOR A FEW WEEKS AGO.
THEN THAT TECHNOLOGY WAS BEING
IMPLEMENTED WE WANT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED HASN'T MADE A
DIFFERENCE --
IN MY BRIEF DISCUSSION WITH THE
CLERK.
WHEN I WAS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES THEY ESTIMATED
THAT TOOK ABOUT ROUGHLY TWENTY
MINUTES AND THIS IS OF COURSE
ANECDOTAL TWENTY MINUTES OF TIME
THE DATA ENTRY?
THAT ON I FIGURED COULD BE DONE
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING IN
LINE TO BE DONE AT A KIOSK THAT
COULD BE DEBT BE DONE ONLINE --
BEFORE THEY GOT THERE THEY COULD
BE DONE WITH AN AYE.
TAKING A CORRECTIVE ACTION TO
REALLY --
ADDRESS THAT A PARTICULAR
[inaudible]
SITUATION [inaudible]
ON AND THE LAST THING IS ALSO
THE CONCERN THAT RENEWAL NOTICES
ARE GOING OUT TOO LATE THAT
RENEWAL RENEWAL NOTICES FOR
DRIVER'S LICENSES.
ARE RECEIVED IN THAT PEOPLE
CANNOT GET APPOINTMENTS. FOR THE
EXPIRATION OF THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSES I THINK THAT CAN BE
FIXED I VERY EASILY BY SENDING
OUT RENEWAL NOTICES MUCH FURTHER
AND EVENTS. TO RELIEVE THE
ANXIETY OF CALIFORNIANS AND GIVE
THEM PLENTY OF TIME TO GO OVER
NEW THAT LICENSE.
ARE LET ME JUST START OFF BY
ASKING IF MR FRAZIER HAS ANY
OPENING COMMENTS THEN.
ALLOWS THE REMAINDER OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SEE IF THEY
HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS MISTER
FRAZIER.
I THANK YOU MISTER KING I HAVE
FOR JOIN YOU ON MY COMMITTEE FOR
THIS HEARING TODAY.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES HAS ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO LOCATIONS ACROSS
OUR STATE WITH OVER FOUR
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
IN MANY WAYS THE DMV IS THE FACE
OF CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT.
IT IS THE AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST OFTEN INTERACT
IN SOME WAY.
WHETHER IT IS FOR VEHICLE
REGISTRATION OBTAINING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR RENEWING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
BECAUSE OF THIS IT IS IMPORTANT
THEBUDGET COMMITTEE PRIORITIZE
FUNDING FOR CUSTOMER SERVICE FOR
DIEM THE DMV SERVICES.
AS IT CAN HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT ON
THE WAY ALL CALIFORNIANS VIEW
GOVERNMENT.
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO WAIT HOURS
TO RECEIVE A BASIC GOVERNMENT
SERVICE.
THE RECENT SPIKE IN WAIT TIMES
TO SHOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET HAS NOT PRIORITIZE.
THE DMV ANYWAY TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE CUSTOMER SERVICE.
PART OF THE PROBLEM LIES IN A
FAILURE OF COMMUNICATION AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT CAN BE DONE
IN IN OR OUTSIDE OF A D. M. V.
OFFICE.
WELL ANY CALIFORNIA HAS A CAR
HAS TO INTERACT WITH THE MV ON A
YEARLY BASIS MOST CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD ONLY SEE THE INSIDE OF
THE DMV ONCE EVERY FIFTEEN
YEARS.
TO RENEW THEIR LICENSE IN
PERSON.
THIS IS BECAUSE IN RECENT YEARS
DMV AS AN AUTOMATED MANY OF ITS
SERVICES BY OFFERING THEM.
ONLINE OR OVER IN THE MAIL.
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO COME TO
INTO THE DMV TO RENEW THEIR
VEHICLE REGISTRATION.
AND MOST PEOPLE CAN HANDLE TWO
OR THREE DRIVERS LICENSE
RENEWALS BY MAIL.
DMV HAS ESTABLISHED MOBILE
CENTERS IN RECENT YEARS CALL D.
M. V. NOW.
WHICH ALLOWS CUSTOMERS TO RENEW
THEIR VEHICLE REGISTRATION A
KIOSK IN THEIR LOCAL GROCERY
STORE IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO DO
SO BY MAIL.
IN THE RARE OCCASIONS THAT
SOMEONE DOES HAVE TO VISIT THE
DMV AN APPOINTMENT CAN BE MADE
AHEAD OF TIME TO REDUCE WAIT
TIMES [inaudible]
HOWEVER.
DESPITE ALL OF THIS MANY PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO THE DMV TO HANDLE
THESE TRANSACTIONS THAT COULD
OTHERWISE BE DONE ELSEWHERE.
AND DIEM BE WAIT TIMES HAVE
BECOME INCREASINGLY LONGER MUCH
OF THIS HAS TO DO WITH A CHANGE
IN FEDERAL LIES YOUR KNOWLEDGE
FEDERAL ID.
BUT WE THE LEGISLATURE HAVE ALSO
BEEN ABLE.
A PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH AB
SIXTY AB NINE THIRTY FIVE THESE
ARE ALL SOLUTIONS.
THAT WE'VE PUT IN LEGISLATION
HAS TO CREATE MORE TIME NEEDED
FOR DIEM VIEW EMPLOYEES.
SO AFTER THE HORRORS OF
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ADDED AND CREATED
STRICTER STATE ID LAWS WITH THE
PAST OF THIS RELATE REAL ID ACT.
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
OF FUNDING.
IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
FIFTEEN YEARS AFTER THE FEDERAL
LAWS PASSAGE.
EVERY STATE IS REQUIRED TO
COMPLY WITH REAL IDEA TO
RESIDENTS WHICH TO FLY
DOMESTICALLY.
OR ENTRY FEDERAL FACILITY AS A
RESULT THE REQUIREMENT OF
CALIFORNIANS ONCE EVERY FIFTEEN
YOUR DMV VISIT JUST GOT MOVED
UP.
AND ARE CONSEQUENCES WHAT'S WILL
HAVE TO VISIT THE DMV IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS TO CHANGE OUR
LICENSES TO RELY DE.
THIS IS LEAD TO CONFUSION
AMONGST OUR CONSTITUENTS WHO
SPEND MINUTES LONGER THAN WITH
DIEM VIEW.
EMPLOYEES TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY REALLY NEED --
WITH IT REAL ID COMPLIANCE.
THIS IS RESOLVED IN DELAYING THE
PROCESS FOR EVERYONE LINED THE
DMV.
THIS BECOMES A BIGGER HEADACHE
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE TO GO TO DMV
FOR UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCES
LIKE LOSING THEIR ID'S HOW ARE
HAVING THEIR ID STOLEN.
IN ANTICIPATION AWAY THE PEOPLE
COMING IN TO TRADE IN THEIR ID'S
TO BE REAL IDEA COMPLIANT.
D. DMB IS GRANTED FOUR HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL STAFF WITH ANOTHER
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO BE ADDED BY
AUGUST A SMALL ADDITION FOR THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO OFFICES
STATEWIDE.
BECAUSE A DIEM V. IS SO HIGHLY
UTILIZE IT IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT WE IS THE LEGISLATURE
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE A GOOD
EXPERIENCE.
THE RISK OF FAILING TO DO SO CAN
HAVE NEVER THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES ON EVERYONE'S
OPINIONS ON HOW GOVERNMENT
FUNCTIONS.
THIS IS WHY WE'RE HERE NOW.
I HOPE TODAY WE CAN LEARN THE
DMB NEEDS IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
THIS INFLUX OF CUSTOMERS SO THAT
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE CAN
PRIORITIZE THIS FINAL DEPARTMENT
TO RECEIVE THE RESOURCES IT
NEEDS.
TO KEEP OUR CONSTITUENTS
SATISFIED.
AND WITH THAT MR TING I THANK
YOU FOR CALLING THIS HERE.
I THINK IT'S FRAZIER MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
YOU KNOW WE DEAL WITH A LOT OF
COMPLEXITY HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT OUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE A MUCH SIMPLER VIEW OF THE
WAY THAT STATE GOVERNMENT WORKS
[inaudible]
AND THEIR INTERACTION ON A DAILY
BASIS WITH DIFFERENT APARTMENTS
OF THE STATE IS ACTUALLY VERY
CONSTRAINED AND THE DMV IS
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE PRIMARY
PUBLIC FACING AGENCIES THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
SO OUR CONSTITUENTS CHARACTERIZE
A LOT OF THEIR FEELINGS ABOUT
STATE GOVERNMENT BY THE SERVICE
THAT THEY GET AT THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEY DO
INTERACT WITH.
SO THE FACT THAT WE HAVE.
A PUBLIC FACING ORGANIZATION OF
THE STATE WHERE OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE SPENDING A DAY OF THEIR
LIVES TRYING TO GET SOMETHING
SIMPLE DONE.
IS COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
PART OF THE SOLUTION ON THIS.
BOB BUT I WANT TO MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR THEIR CONSTITUENTS REALLY
DON'T CARE ABOUT.
THE WHY.
AND I KNOW THAT'S WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY WERE TALK
ABOUT REAL IDEA WERE TALK ABOUT
A BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS WERE TO
TALK ABOUT A MAYBE
TECHNOLOGICAL.
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN BE MADE
AND THESE ARE ALL APPROPRIATE
THINGS FOR US BUT OUR
CONSTITUENTS CARE ABOUT THE WHAT
THEY CARE ABOUT HOW LONG IT'S
GOING TO TAKE ME TO GET MY
VEHICLE LICENSE --
RENEWED HOW LONG IT'S GONNA TAKE
ME TO GET THAT APPOINTMENT TO
GET MY DRIVER'S LICENSE RENEWED
AND THAT'S WHAT I REALLY REALLY
HOPE THAT WERE ABLE TO SOLVE
TODAY SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD --
TO BEING PART OF SOLUTION MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN COMMITTING THE
HEARING.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER PATTERSON.
THE BIGGEST CHAIRMAN AGAIN UP --
THAT MISTER THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS A BUDGET HEARING
IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT AT THIS
IS A GOOD PLACE TO MAKE A START
ASKING SOME OF THE KIND OF TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
FRANK YOU THAT DOUBT WE NEED TO
BE ASKING YOU GETTING SOME
ANSWERS.
TO WHEN MANY CUSTOMERS ARE
WAITING AS LONG AS EIGHT HOURS
AT THE DMV.
OUR ALARM BELL SHOULD BE GOING
OFF SHOULD BEEN GOING OFF A LONG
TIME AGO.
WE HEAR A LOT OF EXCUSE MAKING
THAT THIS IS THE REAL ID IT IS
THERE.
A THIS IS THE REASON THAT THAT
WE HAVE ALL OF THESE DELAYS.
BUT DOWN THIS NOT THE ONLY CAUSE
OF THESE.
LONG WAIT TIMES.
AND QUITE FRANKLY AT THE AUDIT
HEARING TOMORROW WE WILL NO
DOUBT CONTINUE TO TO DEBT
TODAY'S INQUIRY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO DELVE DEEPER
INTO THE DELAYS CAUSED BY REAL
ID WHICH IS A PROBLEM.
BUT AS AS WELL AS HORRIBLY
OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY [inaudible]
AND FAILURES OF NEW SYSTEMS AND
IMPACTS ON CUSTOMERS AND
EMPLOYEES [inaudible]
JUST YESTERDAY.
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM OF THE DMB
COLLAPSED.
IF THAT DOESN'T TELL US.
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A HUGE
TECHNOLOGICAL.
PROBLEMS WITH THE DMV NOTHING
[inaudible]
ELSE WILL.
AS IT'S BEEN STATED EARLIER THE
DMB TOUCHES THE LIVES OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS EVERY
YEAR.
MANY HAVE MADE APPOINTMENTS.
BUT FOR OTHERS MAKING
APPOINTMENTS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY NOT AN OPTION.
APPOINTMENT TIMES CAN BE WEEKS
OR MONTHS OUT WITH A LICENSE
EXPIRING IN JUST A FEW DAYS.
WE'VE HEARD THIS FROM OTHER
MEMBERS THE DMV EXISTS TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
IT SHOULD NOT BE THE TASK WITH
THE CHALLENGE OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO SET UP THEIR
LIVES.
AROUND THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES.
UP DECISIONS WITH RESPECT TO
WHAT WHEN WHERE HOW AND FOR HOW
LONG THESE INDIVIDUALS MUST
APPEAR [inaudible]
BEFORE THEM.
I THINK WE ALSO HAVE TO BE UP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF.
OF DMB EMPLOYEES SCHOOL ARE JUST
AS MUCH IMPACTED.
AS THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
MANY ARE WORKING TWELVE HOUR
DAYS SIX DAYS A WEEK AND THEY
ARE SAYING AND YOU WILL HEAR
SOME OF THAT TESTIMONY TOMORROW.
WHERE ARE THE EMPLOYEES TO HELP
US WE HAVE BEEN PROMISED OVER
AND OVER AGAIN?
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
TALKING TO THESE EMPLOYEES.
THESE ARE DEDICATED DMB
EMPLOYEES.
THEY HAVE FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
LOVE TO THEIR JOBS.
MANY OF THEM THOUGH ARE ASKING.
IS IT HOPELESS.
WHERE ARE THE NEW RECRUITS?
IS THIS THE NEW NORMAL.
SO WE FOUND OURSELVES TODAY A
SITUATION THAT REQUIRES ACTION
YES BUDGETARY ACTION MAY VERY
WELL BE NEEDED.
BUT I AM A BIT RESISTANT TO THE
IDEA THAT THE SOLUTION HERE IS
JUST THROW MORE MONEY AT THE
DMV.
WE HAVE DONE THAT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
WE DID IT OVER A YEAR AGO.
AND WE HAVE THE SAME PROBLEMS
THAT WERE PROMISED TO BE FIXED
AT THAT TIME.
AND NOW I SUPPOSE WE'RE GOING TO
BE OUT [inaudible]
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
APPARENTLY TO DO THE VERY SAME
THING YOU WERE GIVEN MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. TO DO.
OVER A YEAR AGO.
OUT THERE ARE HIRING ISSUES
THERE ARE MAJOR TECHNOLOGY
ISSUES THERE ARE MANAGEMENT
ISSUES THAT GO FAR BEYOND REAL
REAL ID.
AND UP YOU WILL BE HEARING FROM.
THE INDIVIDUALS WITH THAT KIND
OF A SERIES OF ISSUES.
IN FACT FROM INSIDE THE DMV.
THERE ARE PROBLEMS WITH REAL ID
WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THERE ARE SO MUCH THERE'S SO
MUCH MORE AT STAKE HERE.
THAN JUST RELY DE.
AND FACT TOMORROW WE ARE GOING
TO DISCOVER THAT THE ESTIMATES.
OF HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD SHOW UP
FOR REAL ID.
OUR WAS WOEFULLY OVER PREDICTED.
AND IN FACT FEWER SHOWED UP THAN
YOU THOUGHT WOULD SHOW UP.
NOW WE WE NEED TO FIND OUT WHY
THE PLANNING WAS SO FAR OFF THE
MARK.
AND WHAT WE GOING TO DO ABOUT IT
GOING FORWARD.
WE MAY NOT GET TO DISCUSS ALL OF
THESE ISSUES HERE TODAY.
BUT WE WILL TALK ABOUT THEM IN
SOME DETAIL ABOUT THEM TOMORROW
AT THE AUDIT HEARING.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST HIGH END UP.
THAT THE DMB BE PREPARED TO
DELVE INTO THESE A ISSUES IN
MUCH MORE DETAIL PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF THE TESTIMONY YOU WILL
HEAR TOMORROW.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
--
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO IN JUNE I
HAD A NEW FIELD REPRESENTATIVE
IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE AND SHE
TOOK OVER TRANSPORTATION ISSUES
OFFER MY CONSTITUENTS.
AND THE OTHER DAY I ASKED HER
HOUSING GOING AND SHE SAID SHE
FEELS LIKE SHE'S GOT MY PHD IN
D. M. V. --
AND AND THAT THIS IS.
IN THEN IT PREDOMINANTLY WHAT
SHE'S BEEN DEALING WITH --
AND IN HER FIRST FEW MONTHS ARE
ON THE JOB IS FRUSTRATED
CONSTITUENTS --
WHO ARE WHO ARE FRUSTRATED WITH
THE INTERACTIONS THEY'VE HAD --
AS WE'VE HEARD AS WELL HIM HEAR
MORE ABOUT A CONSTITUENT WHO TAG
ME IN A SERIES OF TWEETS OVER A
FRUSTRATINGLY LONG DAY --
AT THE DMV --
AND WAS JUST GETTING MORE AND
MORE EXASPERATED WITH YA HOW CAN
THIS HAPPEN OWE YOU KNOW WHAT'S
GONE WRONG AND WHAT ARE WE GONNA
DO ABOUT AS STATE AS AS THE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND THIS ISN'T A CONSTITUENT
WHO'S PREDISPOSED TO BASHING
GOVERNMENT HE WORKED FOR THE
FEDERAL EDUCATION DEPARTMENT FOR
EIGHT YEARS UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION --
SO EVERYBODY IS FRUSTRATED WITH
THE EXPERIENCES THAT THEY'VE
BEEN HAVING --
YEAH AND AND CLEARLY IT'S GOTTEN
MUCH WORSE --
THIS YEAR --
I DON'T I DON'T WANNA REPEAT A
LOT OF THE THINGS ON MY
COLLEAGUES SAID BUT CLEARLY THEM
THE DMV IS THE NUMBER ONE IN OUR
ACTIONS THAT ARE CONSTITUENTS
HAVE WITH STATE GOVERNMENT IN
THEIR LIVES.
AYE WHICH MAKES A REALLY
IMPORTANT AND MAKE --
AND THINGS HAVE GOTTEN OFF TRACK
--
AND IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE IDENTIFY YOU KNOW BOTH
WHAT WHAT WENT WRONG BUT ALSO
WHAT CAN WE DO TO FIX IT --
AND I THINK THAT'S GONNA BE
CARROTS AND STICKS IS NOT GOING
TO BE JUST.
ON THE RESOURCES BUT IT'S ALSO
GOING TO BE MAKING CHANGES.
ON TO HOW WE DO THINGS AND I'LL
BE THE FIRST IS THAT I REPRESENT
SILICON VALLEY --
AND WHEN A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY TO
ME รณ YOU KNOW GOVERNMENT
SHOULD OPERATE LIKE A BUSINESS
--
AND I SAY TO THEM WELL YOU KNOW
YOU RUN A BUSINESS HOW MUCH OF
YOUR MONEY IS RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT HOW MUCH OF YOUR
MONEY GOES TOWARDS PROJECTS.
WHERE THERE IS A POSSIBILITY OF
FAILURE?
AND THEN WHAT'S YOUR TOLERANCE
FOR FAILURE WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
TRIES SOMETHING AND IT DOESN'T
WORK SO IS SO I UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGE YOU KNOW.
THAT THERE ISN'T A LOT OF
TOLERANCE FOR RISK AND THEREFORE
IT'S HARD FOR YOU TO UPDATE YOUR
SYSTEMS --
AND THERE IS A LACK OF INCENTIVE
TO DO SO BECAUSE YOU'RE WORRIED
ABOUT FAILURE BUT WE'VE HIT
FAILURE --
AND AND WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING WRONG --
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO FIX IT
FAST SOME LOOKING FORWARD TO TO
LEARNING ABOUT --
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN WHAT WE CAN
DO TO HELP YOU GET THERE.
THANK GOODNESS.
FOR I THINK IT IS CHAIRMAN I
WANNA I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING ON I THINK
THAT --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FREIGHT OF
FRAZIER FIRS LEADERSHIP ON THE
TRANSMISSION COMMITTEE AND I
THINK I JIM FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
--
AS WELL BRING THIS ISSUE TO
LIGHT -- WE
ARE MADE MAY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
LAST YEAR YOU TESTIFIED AT THE
IN BE JUSTIFIED --
ASKING FOR TWO HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT SIX YEARS
ADD TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE SEEN
THAT.
THE WAIT TIMES HAVE GOTTEN
WORSE.
AND ON TOP OF THAT REAL ID THAT
THE ACT WAS ENACTED IN MAY OF
TWO THOUSAND FIVE SO. THIRTEEN
YEARS AS PASSED. TO GET READY
FOR THIS AND SO WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THAT IN THOSE
THIRTEEN YEARS AND SO
CALIFORNIANS.
ARE RIGHTFULLY UPSET AND WE ARE
ASKING WHO SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IN THIS SITUATION
AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO FIX
THIS SITUATION IMMEDIATELY.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS
THAT I HAVE AND HOPE TO HEAR
FROM UP HERE LOS ANSWERS AS WELL
AS SOON THANK YOU BUT I THINK
MISTER BRO.
THANK YOU CHECK TING AND CHAIR
FRAZIER FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
--
LOOK FORTY HEARING FROM OF THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DMV ABOUT THIS
ISSUE I'VE.
I CAN TELL YOU IN MY DISTRICT
OFFICES THE NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT
I TOURED THE LAGUNA HILLS
FACILITY --
NOT VERY EASILY WE ASKED SEVERAL
TIMES AND THEY WERE LIKE
RELUCTANT TO HAVE ME COME IN.
AND BUT WE FINALLY GOT IN THERE
AND TALK TO A COUPLE THE
MANAGERS AND THEY EXPLAINED THE
SITUATION THERE ARE CHALLENGES.
AND I LEARNED A LOT FROM IT AND
DUFF FROM THAT.
WELL I THOUGHT ABOUT THE ISSUE
AND RATHER THAN ASKING FOR MORE
MONEY AND MORE STAFF WHICH
GOVERNMENT TENDS TO DO --
I LOOKED AROUND AND YOU HAVE
SOME PARTNERS ALREADY AUTO
CLUB'S.
IF CAR DEALERS SO THERE ARE
PRIVATE ENTITIES THAT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO.
CERTAIN LIMITED DMV SERVICES AND
YOU AUDIT THERE SO THERE ARE
TRANSACTIONS AT THE END OF THE
YEAR SO MY FIRST YEAR I HAD A
BILL TO EXPAND IT ANYBODY WHO
WANT TO COME IN OF YET UPS STORE
FED EX KINKO'S.
BUT IF YOU WANTED TO TEAM UP
WITH THE DMV TO HELP YOU OUT --
LOW LET'S --
GET AN AMMO YOU'RE A CONTRACT
GOING WITH YOU GUYS OUT SELA
HOPEFULLY WE CAN LOOK AT SOME.
PRIVATE SECTOR --
SOLUTIONS AND NOT JUST THE
SIMPLE YOU KNOW ALL WE NEED MORE
GOVERNMENT OF STAFF AND MORE
GOVERNMENT DOLLARS TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM SO BUT FORTY HEARING
TESTIMONY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER.
I DON'T THINK BOTH CHEERFULNESS
HEARING I'M HERE FROM SACRAMENTO
ON MY NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT MY
FIELD OFFICES IN ELK GROVE IS
WITH DMB I'M A FULL TIME PERSON
AT ITS WORST ON CONSTITUENT
COMPLAINTS.
THIS REGARDING DMB DAY IN AND
DAY OUT IN THE FORCED TO CALL
YOUR OFFICE AND TRY ADDRESSED IN
THESE PROBLEMS.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL MONEY IS THE
ISSUE TO FIX THIS IS
ACCOUNTABILITY --
THEIR MAJOR PROBLEMS ACT TOWARD
THE OFFICE YOU BEFORE REAL ID
CAME ONLINE NO LINES ARE THERE
AND THINK ABOUT IT FOR SOMEONE
TO COME AND WAIT.
UP TO EIGHT HOURS UNACCEPTABLE
YOU INTO FOR DENTIST OR DOCTOR
ANYWHERE ELSE.
THE FOR A DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
REGISTRATION I MEAN.
IT'S IT'S MIND BOGGLING IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE GOT THIS POINT SO
I'M OPEN HERE.
I'M FINANCES I GOT SOME VERY
POINTED QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON BUT IT COMES ON
ACCOUNTABILITY SOME POINT.
THE BUCK HAS TO STOP SOMEWHERE
SOMEONE HAS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE THIS IS THIS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
I MEAN EIGHT HOURS FOR ANYTHING
THAT'S A PERSON'S DAY PEOPLE
TAKE TIME OFF WORK THEY'RE USING
VACATION.
SICK LEAVE TO COME IN AND GET A
DRIVER'S LICENSE WE'VE GOT TO
FIX THIS AND THE PUBLIC HAS A
RIGHT TO BE UPSET.
SO I WAS LOOKING FOR TO HEARING
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES THAT TO SAY
NOVELS FROM DMB WOULD HAVE TO
SAY.
THANK YOU MISS BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ALSO --
CHAIR FRAZIER TRANSPORTATION FOR
DOING THIS I COULD NOT POSSIBLY
COME SOON ENOUGH --
I AM VERY GRATEFUL TO HAVE A
HEARING TODAY AS WELL AS IN THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE.
I'M WE'VE ALL HAD OUR
CONSTITUENTS CONTACT US AYE I'VE
ACTUALLY COMPILED.
THIS IS A SAMPLE PILE OF THE
LIST OF CONSTITUENT TESTIMONIALS
TO WHAT THEIR EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN WITH THE DMV.
IT IS NOT JUST IT JUST ABOUT
REAL ID.
IT'S ABOUT MY CONSTITUENTS IN
LINE FAINTING.
SENIOR CITIZENS WITH ZERO EIGHTY
A OR ACCESS THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
TO BE ABLE TO WAIT IN THAT LINE.
THE LINES BEING OUTSIDE IN
SCORCHING HEAT AND IS NOT FOR
REAL ID IT'S TO PICK UP PLATES.
TO TO DO A SIMPLE RENEWAL IT'S
TO DO THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO EFFICIENTLY.
I'M I'M GONNA MAKE SURE THAT OUR
DMB REPRESENTED TODAY GET A COPY
OF EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
COMPLAINTS BECAUSE I REALLY
THINK YOU NEED TO SEE THEM TODAY
WILL BE THE DATA READ EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
POSITIVE COMMENTS SOME
SYMPATHETIC CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE
LIKE YOU KNOW THERE'S DMV
EMPLOYEES HERE.
WHO ARE WORKING VERY HARD IN
TRYING BUT THEY'RE RARE?
AND THEY'RE NOT JUST ABOUT REAL
ID MY HOPE IS TODAY NOT A SINGLE
EXCUSE WILL BE PROVIDED.
THAT IT WILL BE AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF WHAT IS THE
PROBLEM WITHOUT EXCUSES
[inaudible]
AND COMPLETELY.
WILLING WILLING NO WILLINGNESS
TO HEAR EVERY POSSIBLE SOLUTION
WHETHER IT INCLUDES PRIVATE.
UP PARTNERSHIPS THAT ALLOW US TO
GET MORE DONE WHETHER IT
INCLUDES COMPLETELY
RESTRUCTURING AND REINVENTING
THE DMV OR OTHERWISE NO EXCUSES
AND A WILLINGNESS TO CONSIDER
ANY OPTION THAT WILL GET THE JOB
DONE THAT'S WHAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS DO WITH THEIR LIVES
WHEN THEY ARE FACED WITH THE
PROBLEM.
AND I I THINK THAT'S WHAT ALL OF
US WANT TO SEE TODAY SO AGAIN
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIRS BOTH
COMMITTEES.
AND I ALSO TO THE REPRESENTS FOR
COMING TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO A
HEARING THAT IS ABOUT SOLUTIONS
AND NOT A SINGLE EXCUSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S BAKER SONGS AGAIN
JUST TERM --
HIT THAT POINT WELL BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR IS.
HOME AGAIN HOW THE BUDGET
IMPLEMENTATION IS GOING.
ON HOW HOW IT'S GOING TO
REDUCING THE WAIT TIMES. FOR HOW
LONG IT WILL TAKE AND WHAT IT
WILL TAKE TO REDUCE THESE --
WAIT TIMES AND THEN IN
PARTICULAR --
WHAT FUTURE PLANNED OUTSIDE OF
WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET
--
REALLY NEEDS TO HAPPEN WHETHER
IT IS.
WHETHER IT IS ON UPDATING SOME
OF THE NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS I
EXTENT I THINK EVERYBODY HERE IS
LOOKING. TO FIGURE OUT A
SOLUTION TO IMMEDIATELY PRODUCE
THESE WAIT TIMES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE SO WITH THAT LET ME.
COME START IN ALLOW --
DIRECTOR SHIA MOTO --
THE FLOOR AND JUST LET HER START
IN A FAR HOW HOWEVER YOU WANT TO
DIRECT YOUR TESTIMONY.
TO A THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
REMAINDER OF YOUR STUFF IS --
UP TO YOU AS A WITHOUT A HUNDRED
IRISH HIMOTO.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR IS A
MEMBERS I'M JEANNE SHIMMER THE
DIRECTOR OF THAT PART MOTOR
VEHICLES WITH ME IS ROBBIE
COCKETT THAT BE DIRECT
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES VISION.
AND A FORMER BUDGET OFFICER FOR
THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEES ON DEAN
HE'S WAIT TIMES AS A DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT.
ELIJAH APOLOGIZE FOR CUSTOMERS
THE WAIT TIMES YOU'RE
EXPERIENCING ARE NOT WHAT WE
EVER WANT OUR CUSTOMERS TO GO
THROUGH.
WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUES FOR OFFICES
STATEWIDE.
WE START EXPERIENCING HEART WAIT
TIMES IN LATE APRIL EARLY MAY
AND OF PROCEEDING FOR MONTHS THE
DVD WE DID EMPLOYMENT THREE
CERTIFICATE I. T. EFFORTS WHEN
WAS THE FEDERAL REAL ID ACT.
THE FACE IMPLEMENTATION OF A NEW
QUEUING SYSTEM AND FACE
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW ELECTRONIC
DRIVER'S LICENSE APPLICATION.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN YEARS
THAT DEPARTMENTS IMPLEMENT THIS
NUMBER BECAUSE MY FACE
INITIATIVES.
THE SAME TIME.
IMPLEMENTATIONS DID OVERLAP
BETWEEN YOU AND ADDITIONAL
WORKUP FOR STAFF AND YOU AN
ADDITIONAL PROCESSES FOR
CUSTOMERS.
LAWYER PROJECTED DISTANT TIME
WOULD BE NEEDED TO PROCESS A
REAL ID APPLICATION WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT IS TAKING A PROXY
ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES ON AVERAGE
TO EDUCATE EVERY DRIVER'S
LICENSE IDENTIFICATION CARD.
CUSTOMER ABOUT THEIR OPTION TO
OBTAIN A REAL ID COMPLAINT CAR
AND WHAT DOCUMENTS ARE REQUIRED
TO COMPLETE A REAL LIKE THE
TRANSACTION.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A CHOICE AND
DECIDE WHICH CARD THEY WANT AS
THIS IS A FEDERAL MANDATE.
HOWEVER THE WAIT TIMES THAT
CONSUMERS ARE EXPERIENCING ARE
NOT ACCEPTABLE TO ME AS WE HAVE
HEARD AND THE PUBLIC.
DEFINITELY DESERVES BETTER.
WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN SEVERAL
RESOURCES AND PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS TO REDUCE WAIT
TIMES WE ARE ALMOST RELEASED
CAPITA BUDGET CHAIN PROPOSAL
THAT AUTHORIZES FIVE AND FIFTY
NEW EMPLOYEES. FIVE HUNDRED OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES HAVE ALREADY
START WORKING AT A FIELD OFFICES
WITH REMAINING THIRTY ONE YOU
EMPLOYEES BE IN PLACE BY THE END
OF THE MONTH.
ON JULY TWENTY SEVENTH THE
DEPART FINANCE SUBMITTED A
BUDGET AUGMENTATION REQUEST FROM
THE DEPARTMENT FOR AN ADDITIONAL
TWO ENGINE THIRTY EMPLOYEES TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
THE DEAL HIRES ARE GOING OF
GOING TO FILL LAWS THAT NEED THE
MOST HELP.
FURTHER WE HAVE INCREASED STAFF
OR TIME BY ABOUT SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND HOURS MONTHLY.
JUST THIS WEEK TO IT IN FORTY
EMPLOYEES TWENTY ME HEADQUARTERS
AND STAFF OTHER STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS WERE DEPLOYED TO
HIGHS NEED OFFICES AROUND THE
STATE.
STEPHAN EDT.
THE CHP CALPERS AND THE PART OF
JAIL SEARCHES ARE TEMPORARY
ASSISTING US WITH OUR EFFORTS IN
OUR FIELD OFFICES.
I WANT TO THANK THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS INDIAN BE STAFF IN
THE FIELD HEADQUARTERS WERE
STEPPING UP AND WORKING MORE
HOURS AND WILLING TO TRAVEL. TO
ASSIST WERE NEEDED.
ALL YOU AGAIN OFFERING LIMITS
EVERY SERVICE IN JUNE LAST
SATURDAY WE OPEN SIXTY OFFICES
OF FROM EIGHT AM. TO FIVE PM.
THESE OFFICES WILL BE OPEN EVERY
SANITY WE OPEN FOURTEEN OFFICES
ONE HOUR EARLIER TO GET
CUSTOMERS IN EARLIER.
AND WE ARE FRONT LOADING
SCHEDULES TO HAVE ALL AVAILABLE
STAFF AT WORK BY EIGHT PM.
THIS PROVIDES OUR CUSTOMERS MORE
OPTIONS FOR THEIR SCHEDULE AND
MORE APPOINTMENT AVAILABILITY.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
IMPROVING THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE WE HAVE DIRECT WE
DIRECTED FIELD OFFICE STAFF.
TRIAGE THE WEIGHT LIGHTS VERIFY
CUSTOMERS HAVE THE CORRECT
DOCUMENTS AND IN THOSE CASES
WHERE THEY DO NOT WE'RE OFFERING
THEM APPOINTMENTS COME BACK WITH
THE CORRECT DOCUMENTS WHICH
COULD BE THE SAME DAY.
OR A DAY THAT IS CONVENIENT FOR
THEM. FOR CUSTOMERS AT THE
OFFICE BEFORE IT OPENS WHERE
BRING IN SOME IN EARLY TO
COMPLETE THAT LOOK TIME DRIVERS
LICENSE APPLICATION SO THE ABLE
TO GET THEIR TRANSACTIONS DONE
SOONER.
WE REMOVE THE FOUR PM STOP TIME
FOR TAKING NOT STATES THAT
CUSTOMERS DO NOT HAVE TO RETURN
TO TAKE THE TEST AFTER.
FOUR THIRTY THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROCESSES PARTISAN CREWS HERE WE
HAVE MADE TO FURTHER REDUCE WAIT
TIMES ON JULY SIXTEENTH
ELECTRONIC DRIVER'S LICENSE
APPLICATION WHEN ONLINE.
GAME CUSTOMERS THE OPTION TO
COMPLETE THEIR APPLICATION
BEFORE ARRIVING TO AN OFFICE
WHILE WAITING IN LINE.
ON JULY TWENTY FIFTH ARGUING
SYSTEM AUTOMATICALLY GENERATED
Q. TICKET FOR THE NUMBER FOR THE
CUSTOMER.
IN TWO WEEKS WOULD BE UNCLEAN
ITS STATE Y. PROGRAM FOR TEXT
NOTIFICATIONS.
THIS ALLOWS THE CUSTOMER THE
FLEXIBILITY TO LEAVE THE OFFICE
AND IF THEY WANT TO GO GRAB A
BITE TO EAT OR GET COFFEE AND
GET A TEST.
TEXT NOTIFICATION SHORTLY BEFORE
THE TRANS FIRST CALL.
WE ALSO PARTYING SELF SERVICE
SOUTH CHECK IN KIOSKS WERE
APPOINTMENT CUSTOMERS INTO
OFFICES.
THAT ALLOWS CUSTOMERS TO BYPASS
THE STORY WINDOW AND IT'S ONLY
RECEIVE THE SERVICE NUMBER.
ON AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH AS CHAIR
TING YOU HAD YOU HAD INQUIRED
WILL BEGIN THE PROCESS TO MAIL
OUT RENEWAL NOTICES FOR DRIVER'S
LICENSE IDENTIFICATION CARDS.
THIS IS GOING FROM SIXTY TO
NINETY DAYS TO NINETY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS IN ADVANCE
OF THE CARD EXPIRATION SO WHEN
THE CUSTOMERS GET THE RENEWAL
NOTICE.
THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT AS A MAKING
APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE NINETY
DAYS IN ADVANCE.
WE ARE ABOUT NINETY DAYS OUT WE
ARE EXPANDING OUR SELF SERVICE
TERMINALS ARE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION.
AT FOUR TO TEN ADDITIONAL DB
FILLED OFFICES OF FIVE EVER
READY BEEN STALLED ONE IS BEING
INSTALLED TODAY BUT THE
REMAINING FOUR BEFORE THE END OF
THE MONTH AND AN ADDITIONAL.
FIFTY SELF SERVICE TERMINALS IN
RETAIL LOCATIONS LATER THIS YEAR
WOULD BRING THE STATE MY TOTAL
TO HEAD TO SIXTY SIX SELF
SERVICE TERMINALS.
IN MID SEPTEMBER THE NEXT PHASE
OVERLOOKED ON KATE AND PROJECT
WILL BE ACTIVE WILL SAFETY INTO
TIME BY TECHNICIANS.
THIS IS DONE DIEM HAS DONE AND
CONTINUES TO DO SIGNIFICANT
OUTREACH EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION THE PUBLIC ON REAL
ID.
THESE INCLUDE A SPECIFIC RELATED
WEBSITE WE A PARTNER WITH SIX
CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS TO ADD
MESSAGING ABOUT REAL ID
INCLUDING VISION VIDEO MESSAGE
BOARDS.
THAT PAID EARNED MEDIA ABOUT
TRADITIONAL SERVICE HOURS AND
ONLINE INFORMATION THERE INSERTS
ABOUT CHANGE ABOUT THE CHANGE IN
THE UC REGISTRATION WHEN ALL'S
AND DRIVER'S LICENSE
IDENTIFICATION CURRENT ALLS.
AND WE DO CONTINUES SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTINGS.
WE STARTED TO SEE THE BENEFITS
FROM THE ACTIONS WE TAKE IN THE
PAST FEW MONTHS AS DB COMPLETED
17% MORE FIELD OFFICE
TRANSACTIONS IN JULY.
THAN IN JUNE WHICH IS ABOUT ONE
POINT THREE MILLION UP FIELD
OFFICE TRANSACTIONS ALIVE VERSES
NINE TO SIXTY NINE THOUSAND
TRANSACTIONS IN JUNE.
WHAT THE SAME TIME?
SEEN THE WAIT TIMES DROPPED BY
FEW MINUTES WE ARE SEEING MORE
CUSTOMERS AND STILL WORKING TO
REDUCE THE WAIT TIMES.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT THE MAJOR
ACTIONS TAKEN THIS PAST WEEK AND
THOSE TO BE EMPLOYMENT IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND THE MONTHS.
NEXT FEW MONTHS WILL PRODUCE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
CUSTOMER WAIT TIMES.
BUT WE WANT TO DO BETTER AND WE
WILL DO BETTER OUR CUSTOMERS
DESERVE IT WE CONTINUE TO LOOK
FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE OUR
PROCESSES.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THIS
CHALLENGE AND WHAT WE'RE DOING
TO OUR OVERCOME IT.
AND NOT OPEN TO ANY SUGGESTIONS
REGARDING HOW I KNOW THAT SOME
OF YOU HAVE MENTIONED THEY GET
SOME SUGGESTIONS I WANTED THINGS
IS THAT IN TERMS OF A
PARTNERSHIP WITH AUTO CLUBS AND
WE HAVE PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
AUTO CLUB'S A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SENATE CALIFORNIA.
A WITH THEY ARE SO THE
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPANDED THEIR US
SERVICE HOURS AND THEY HAVE
HARDWARE PEOPLE.
A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH.
SELF SERVICE TERMINALS IN THEIR
ON A CLIP OFFICES THE APART WITH
THE VENDOR TO DO THAT SUIT
DEFTLY ARE LEVERAGING THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR OTHER
OTHER OF ENTITIES.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO EXPLORE
ANY OTHER ONES IF YOU HAVE ANY
SUGGESTIONS ON THAT.
IN TERMS FOR REAL ID AND WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING AT IT WHAT IF
THINGS IS THAT --
TO GET READY FOR ID THE
REGULATIONS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAD TO PAS LAWS
REGULATIONS UNTIL THOSE
REGULATIONS ARE PASSED.
A A STATE CANNOT DETERMINE WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO UNTIL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS A
REGULATIONS IN PLACE.
AND WHILE DOING THAT WE WORK TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A VERY SECURE
CARD CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
MOST SECURE A DRIVERS LICENSE ID
CARDS IN ADDITION.
A WE HAVE WE ISSUE OUR DRIVER
LICENSE FOR SUCH A LOCATION THAT
IS A REQUIREMENT.
OF INDIGENT THAT A WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
ONE THING IS THAT --
WE WERE ASKED TO SEE IF THEY
COULD RELAX SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AND IN TALKING WITH
THE TIME HOLDEN SECURITY.
A WE DO LET TIME VERIFICATION
WITH SO SCARY ADMINISTRATION AND
WE MARK OUR RECORD WITH THAT
THEY STILL REQUIRE YOU TO BRING
IN YOUR SOUL SECURITY CARTER
DOCUMENT THE FULL SO SCARY NEVER
SUCH AS A W..
TO AND THEY WOULD NOT RELAX THAT
REQUIREMENT THEY SAID THAT
REQUIRED.
I WOULD NOT HAVE BEING IN THAT
ADDITIONAL DOCUMENT.
AND TERMS OF THE OTHER FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT FOR RELY DE IS YOU
HAVE TO BRING INTO RESIDENCY
DOCUMENTS TALKING WITH HOMELAND
SECURITY.
WAS ABLE TO GET THEM TO REQUIRE
ONLY ONE DOCUMENT THAT BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO BRING IN AS WHEN WE
SING YOU ARE --
DRIVER'S LICENSE IT DOES YOUR
HOME ADDRESS AND IF YOU'RE NOT
THERE REMOVE THAT IS RETURNED
BACK TO THE POST US BACK TO US.
SO ABLE TO GET THEM TO ALLOW
ONLY ONE DOCUMENT AND REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF DOCUMENTS BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO BRING AND AGAIN REDUCE
WHAT WE HAVE TO REQUIRE.
SO WE HAVE BEEN INTO THE TALK
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF CALIFORNIA
OTHER STATES HAVE ASKED THEM TO
YOU IF THEY LEAD UP MAKE IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE EASIER FOR THE
STATES TO IMPLEMENT IT BUT THAT
THEY ARE NOT.
OPEN TO CHANGING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS.
THE KEY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
MISTER CHIP.
THANK YOU AND AND SHARES A
QUESTION ASSIDUOUS SHARE ANY
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT TO US UP
VERY.
UPGRADE YOUR HARDWARE SYSTEM IN
OUR LIVES THEIR SOFTWARE SYSTEM.
IN TALKING ABOUT IDENTIFICATION
TO YOU ASAP [inaudible]
THE EMAIL.
THE BOOK COPY OFF TO YOU GOOD
BOOM PASSPORT AS AN IDEAL ARE
YOU HAVE TO SEE THE PHYSICAL AT
ALL REQUIREMENTS TO WE HAVE TO
SEE THE DOCUMENTS OF REACH ALL
DOCUMENTS AND A PERSON HAS TO WE
HAVE TO BE CREDENTIALED THE
PERSON IN PERSON SO.
WE CANNOT ACCEPT IT TO SENDING
IT TO LAST WEEK AND WE HAVE TO
SEE THE ORIGINAL FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT YES THEY IN TURN OFF
YOUR YOUR THE EQUIPMENT.
YOUR YOUR YOU AREN'T.
HARDWARE THAT AT A SOFTWARE.
IS THAT ANY NEW ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT SO YOU CAN.
BETTER SERVE OUR COMMUNITY.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
MODERNIZING IT SYSTEMS WE'VE HAD
A REQUEST THAT WE DID RECEIVE
FUNDING WE ARE IN THE PROCESS.
A WE HAVE DID MODERNIZE ON THE
FINE IN THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
SYSTEM ON THE FINE AND WE ARE
GOING TO FINISH MODERNIZING.
AND THE FRONT AND ON THE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION AND ALL THE BACK
AND SO WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
MODERNIZING OUR SYSTEMS THERE
FROM WHAT WOULD THAT CAUSE FOOD
PACKED HER DO YOU HAVE ANY
ESTIMATE. FOR MODERN I THINK
YEAH SO SO THE PROPOSAL WE PUT
FORWARD I'M WITH THE BUDGET THIS
AND PAST FISCAL YEAR WAS RIGHT
AROUND NINETY MILLION DOLLARS TO
DO THE FRONT END OF THE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION.
AND ALSO THE CONTROL CASHIERING
PIECE [inaudible]
WHEN HER?
BY PROVIDING CARE.
MISS COOPER MISSED DOING
REGARDER COMMENTS ABOUT OUTSIDE
AGENCIES USING THOSE THAT WAS
JUST IMPLEMENTED YESTERDAY
CORRECT.
WHEN WHAT YOU THINK USING
OUTSIDE AGENCIES TO A SISTER
EMPLOYEES?
YES DID YES WE HAD I GOT THESE
LOAN EMPLOYEES THEY WERE
DEPLOYED YESTERDAY SOME FROM
HACKERS WERE DEPLOYED LAST WEEK.
OF THEY WILL STAY OUT THERE --
AS WE ARE ABLE TO FILL BEHIND
FOR THE OF POSITIONS THAT WE'VE
ASKED FOR SO HERE'S MY QUESTION
IS DMV IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
CHP NEED DIESEL BY BRINGING
THOSE OUTSIDE AGENCIES INTO YOUR
OFFICE IS.
IT'S DIFFERENT SYSTEMS FOR
COMPUTERS HOW ARE THEY GOING TO
BE EFFECTIVE AND WHAT IS THAT
LEARNING CURVE SO THEY ARE DOING
ITS SO THEY ARE DOING NON
PRODUCTION WORK SO THEY ARE WHAT
WE HAD DONE IS TAKEN TAINT
TRAINED TECHNICIANS. TO BUILD A
TRIAGE LINE OUTSIDE HELP
CUSTOMERS TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT DOCUMENTS SO THE LOAN
EMPLOYEES WILL BE --
MAKING SURE THE DOC CUSTOMERS
HAVE THE RIGHT DOCUMENTS DE FOR
RELY DE FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE
A PASSPORT YOU HAVE
APPRECIATIVELY GET YOUR W. TWO
IF YOU'RE SO SCREEN NUMBER.
RESIDENTS A DOCUMENT SO THAT WE
WANT CUSTOMERS WAY LYING IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT DOCUMENTS
SO THEY CAN GO HOME AND GET THE
RIGHT DOCUMENTS.
AND WE ALSO WITH --
OR ELECTRONIC DOLLARS LICENSE
FORM THEY'RE ASSISTING CUSTOMERS
AND HOW TO WORK THEIR WAY
THROUGH THE SCREENS SO THEY'RE
NOT DOING TECHNICAL WORK SO YOU
COULD TRAVEL AND PER DIEM FOR
THESE EMPLOYEES WHAT WHAT NUMBER
WHAT'S THE UNIVERSE EMPLOYEES
THERE.
BEING SHIPPED OUT ARE BEING USED
BY DMB.
AT FOUR I JUST FOR THE DMV
UPLAND OUTSIDE EMPLOYEES WILL
TOTAL TOTAL NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
DEVIANT PLAYS BEING SENT OUT.
THAN OUTSIDE AGENCY EMPLOYEES
BEING USED SO OUTSIDE EMPLOYEES
THEY ARE --
IN THE LOCATION THAT WE HAVE A
FIELD OFFICES SO THEY ARE AT
THEIR HOME BASE A TO AN OFFICE
CLOSE.
TO OUT WHERE THEY LIVE SO THERE
IS JUST TRAVEL TO THE FIELD
OFFICE LOCATION.
ARE YOU PAY FOR THEIR SALARIES.
BUT WE WILL WORK OUT IN HE
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT WITH THOSE
AGENCIES ARE YOU HAVING ANY
EMPLOYEES FROM DMV OFFICE UP AND
TOLD THAT SOME THE POLICEMEN OFF
THE FLYING TO OTHER LOCATIONS
YES THEY ARE WE ARE SAYING THEM
OUT BECAUSE OF OFFICES NEED
ADDICTIVE.
ASSISTANCE SO WE ARE FLYING THEM
OUT FACILITIES THE ESTIMATED
COST AND WHERE WOULD THAT
FUNDING COME FROM TO PAY FOR
THESE COSTS INCURRED.
THOSE ARE COMING FROM ICE PACK
PERSONAL SERVICES COSTS WE WOULD
HAVE TO GET UP AND AN ESTIMATE
OF WHAT THAT IS AND GET BACK TO
ON THAT IS A SUFFICIENT MONIES
TO PAY FOR THOSE COST.
OF ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
REIMBURSEMENT.
CURRENT CURLY OUR CURRENT BUDGET
WE WE CAN FIND THAT. FOR HOW
THEY GET THOSE EMPLOYEES ARE
GONNA BE THERE UNTIL WE AYE WE
HAD PUT THE ASK BOARD FOR
ADDITIONAL TO IT AND THIRTY P.
WEISSMAN SIXTEEN MILLION --
ASKED OF FOR THE AUGMENTATION
THAN THOSE I ONCE WE GET THOSE
EMPLOYEES HIRED AND TRAINED AT A
HIGHER THEY WERE DEPLOYED TO THE
FIELD OFFICES WERE ALONE IN
PLACE AROUND RIGHT NOW SO I
GUESS BILLS EMPLOYERS ARE HIRING
THAT HAVE ALSO BEEN TOLD THAT.
NGUYEN SEVERE OFFICES ASKED FOR
JUST.
A YEAR AGO.
PREVIOUS YEAR ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS WHEN ASKED FOR THOSE
EMPLOYEES THERE TOLD NO YOU
CAN'T HIRE THOSE EMPLOYEES WE'VE
I'VE HEARD THAT FROM NUMBER OF
IT.
INDIVIDUALS INDIAN BE.
THAT OF CULT LAYOFFS IS A
REPORTED THAT THAT.
WHEN THE SUPERVISORS ASKED FOR
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS ARE TOLD
WILL HOLD ON YOU CAN HURDLES
EMPLOYEES RIGHT AWAY?
AND WILL HAVE TO GO BACK AND
TALK TO THOSE OFFICES SO WE HAVE
HIRING TEAMS IN PLACE WE HAVE
EIGHT REGIONS WE PUT TOGETHER
HIRING TEAMS WE CAN EXPEDITE.
THAT THE REVIEW THE APPLICATION
AND INTERVIEW SO WE ARE WORKING
TO GET EMPLOYEES OUT TO THOSE
OFFICE.
IF THAT IS A WE WERE DEATHLY
FALL IF YOU KNOW LET ME KNOW
WHAT THOSE OFFICES I WILL FOUGHT
WITH THOSE MARRIAGES BECAUSE
THAT SHOULD NOT BE HAPPENING SO
I GUESS WHEN US FEELS POSITIONS
LAST YEAR.
HOW MIDDLE SOLUTIONS HAVE BEEN
FILL?
AND THE THOSE POSITIONS HAVE
BEEN FILLED ALL OF THEM.
CRACKED SO IT WAS THE LAST
YEAR'S A BLAST FROM.
FISCAL YEAR WE HAD TWO INTERNET
WE AUTHORIZED TO UNDER NINETEEN
POSITIONS WE ACTUALLY FILLED
MORE THAN THE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN AND THIS CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR THAT WERE IN.
POWER BUT YOU DIDN'T AUTHORIZE
FOR FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THAT
THE CONTINUATION OF THE TWO
EIGHTEEN WE HAD OVER FILLED THAT
THE TWO EIGHTEEN AND HAVE
ROUGHLY ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY POSITIONS.
AND SO THOSE CARRY FOR TO THIS
YEAR.
IS WHAT WE'RE HIRING NOW WITH
THE DIRECTOR JUST MENTIONED AND
WHAT PLANNING TO HAVE THAT ALL
WRAPPED UP BY THE END OF AUGUST.
WITH AYE THERE'S ABOUT FIFTEEN
POSITIONS LEFT.
SO AS FAR AS A REAL LADIES GO
THAT'S THE CRUX THE PROBLEM WITH
THEIR AN UNDERESTIMATION OF
FAMILY PHOTO COME FORWARD SINCE
THAT'S BUGGING YOU DOWN THE AND
WOOD WAS WHO WHO PLANNED FOR IT
WAS A PLANNING INCORRECT.
NOW SO THAT SO THE CHALLENGE WAS
NEVER NECESSARY IN THIS KIND OF
GOES BACK --
TO PATTERSON'S COMMENT AS IT
RELATES TO THE TIME FRAME FOR
THE TRANSACTION THROUGH THE
EDUCATIONOF THE CUSTOMER WHAT
WE'RE SEEING.
IS THAT THE TIME VALUE FOR THE
TRANSACTION ITSELF IT AND
CHANGING IT THAT ADDITIONAL FIVE
MINUTE CONVERSATION IT'S THAT
THE THE TALK TIME THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE WITH EVERY SINGLE
EMPLOYEE.
ARE EVERYTHING A CUSTOMER THAT
COMES AND AS IT RELATES TO
WHETHER THEY'RE GIVING RELATING
OR NON RELATED HAVING TO EXPLAIN
THE DIFFERENCES AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND.
I'M WHETHER THEY CHOOSE TO GET A
REAL ID ARE NOT LIKE THE AND
THEN THE DOCUMENTATION
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SO WHAT IS
THE AVERAGE WAIT TIME WITHOUT AN
APPOINTMENT.
SO SO RIGHT NOW THAT THIS
STATEWIDE AVERAGES ABOUT ON OUR
HAVE WE AND WE KNOW WE'VE HEARD
THAT YEAH EMPLOYEE CUSTOMERS ARE
WAITING.
LONGTIME EIGHT HOURS SIX HOURS
AND I THAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE IN
THERE IN DIFFERENT OFFICES WHERE
WE HAVE OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
WAITING LONGER.
AND SO WE ARE WORKING ON THAT SO
WHAT WE ALSO DID EMPLOYMENT IS A
COMMAND CENTER ANNIE IQ MARCHING
TEAM SO WE ARE MARCHING THE WAIT
TIMES IN REAL TIME.
SO THAT WE ARE WATCHING EVERY
OFFICE OF HOW LONG THE WAIT
TIMES ARE AND WE ALSO ASKING
EVERY OFFICE.
CALLING INTO THE REGION OFFICE
IN THERE WE'RE FINDING OUT IF WE
HAVE --
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE NOT THAT
CALLING IN SICK FOR THEY HAVE
AND WE DEFINITELY HAVE SCHEDULED
A TIME OFF WE'RE MOVING
EMPLOYEES AROUND TO LEVEL OFF
THAT THE WORKLOAD SO THAT WE
HAVE.
EMPLOYEES AT ALL THE OFFICES.
AND THEN AS A THE WAIT TIMES ARE
MY HIM OF IT TODAY.
EVERY DAY IS THAT IF WE SEE
WHERE --
CUSTOMERS ARE WAITING A LONG
TIME WE ARE ADJUSTING WHETHER
IT'S AN APPOINTMENT VERSUS NON
APPOINTMENT CUSTOMER.
AND THAT IF THERE AND WE SEE
THAT AND OFFICES GET BUSY AND WE
KNOW OUR OFFICES ARE WE'VE BEEN
VERY BUSY AND I THERE IS A
PERSON THIS MUST BE MARK THAT IS
MARTINE ARE QUEUING SYSTEM.
MARCHING WHAT CUSTOMERS WAITING
HOW LONG THEY'RE WAITING AND WE
DON'T WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE CUSTOMERS.
NO ONE SHOULD WAIT LONG AND
MAKING SURE THOSE CUSTOMERS GET
SERVED BUT THE TINIEST TOLD ME
IS AN ACCURATE AND THAT THAT'S
LIKE IT'S THAT'S CREEK THE ISSUE
BECAUSE I WE HAVE DOCTORS FROM
BEING V. TALKING ABOUT WAIT
TIMES. FOR PLUMAS NOT
APPOINTMENTS THAT ARE REFLECTIVE
OF WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING SO.
THAT THAT'S THE DISCONNECT RIGHT
THERE COMING FROM YOU.
YOU'RE TELLING ME IT'S A OUR
WHATEVER LEFT DOES NOT HAPPEN
THAT'S NOT THE FACT THAT WE ARE
MONITORING EVERY OFFICE --
ALL THE OFFICES AND WHAT CAN
WAIT TIMES ARE I'M GONNA REPORT
BUT THE WAIT TIMES ARE.
AND WE ARE.
OUT WITH THE ADDITION THAT'S
COMING ON BOARD WILL HAVE.
TO BE ABLE.
TO HELP OUR CUSTOMERS AND GET TO
WORK TO WORK REDUCE THAT WAIT
TIMES AND DEFTLY WE KNOW THAT
CUSTOMERS ARE WAITING A LONG
TIME VERTICALLY GOING TO WORK TO
HIRE MORE EMPLOYEES. TO REDUCE
THAT WAIT TIME.
BUT BUT LIMITS FELT MISTER
COOPER'S PART SO IF YOU'RE DOING
REAL TIME MONITORING WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE LONGER WAIT TIMES AT
SOME OF THE MORE CROWDED
OFFICES.
GIVE US SOME EXAMPLES --
WE ARE SEEN IT COULD BE IT'S AND
WE'RE JUST CHECKING TODAY US
SOME OFFICES RIGHT FOR OUR SOME
OFFICERS SIX HOURS AND THAT IS
WHERE.
I TODAY WE GET WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE
WILL GET THE PERMISSION TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL PLACE THAT WILL MAKE
A DIFFERENCE.
AND TERMS OF PROCESSING AND THEN
ALL THE OTHER UP THINGS THAT I
TALKED ABOUT TERMS OF IMPROVE
EFFICIENCIES --
WE WILL --
WITH IT OF BEING ABLE TO DO THE
ELECTRONIC GRAYSON AND THEN
SEPTEMBER WE ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PULL IF YOU COMPLETE
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE ONLINE UP
GET ONLINE.
THOUGH TO PUT THAT INFORMATION
INTO A DRIVERS LICENSE SYSTEM
OUR TECHNICIANS WILL NO LONGER
HAVE TO KEEP THAT INFORMATION WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THAT FOR
EFFICIENCY PURPOSES.
AND THAT WILL SAVE AT LEAST FIVE
MINUTES OF KEEN TIME WHERE THE
CUSTOMER WE DON'T AYE
TECHNICIANS AND I HAVE TO KEEP
THAT INFORMATION THAT'LL MAKE IT
MORE EFFICIENT PROCESS BOTH. FOR
THE CUSTOMER AND FOR THE
EMPLOYEE IN TERMS OF PROCESSING
AND GETTING FOR CUSTOMERS DONE
--
SERVE FASTER QUICKER AND WE CAN.
PLEASE DISCUSS YOUR YOU JUST
REFERENCED IT NOW THE JULY
TWENTY SEVENTH.
LETTER YOU SENT TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE ARE ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC FINANCE I BELIEVE.
AFFORDED TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
REGARDING TO REQUEST.
YES WE SUBMITTED THAT REQUEST AS
DEPARTMENT VICE ESTIMATED THAT'S
FOR SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT WOULD --
ALSO THAT EQUATE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY MORE POSITIONS WE ARE.
IN ANTICIPATION OF GETTING THAT
APPROVAL WHICH WOULD OF THE
PLACE INTO THE HIGH OFFICES AT
THE HIGHS WAIT TIMES.
WE'VE ALREADY POT STARTED THE
PROCESS TO ADVERTISE THE
POSITIONS HASN'T AS WE GET
APPLICATIONS WE ARE GOING TO
START THE PROCESS TO INTERVIEW
BUT I ASK IS FOR CLINTON THIRTY
POSITIONS AND THEY WILL BE
PLACED.
IN OFFICES WITH THE HIGHEST WAIT
TIME GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THAT HAVING THIS
HEARING --
FOR MANY ISSUES REGARDING THE
STATE -- IT.
THE COMPLAINTS ARE CONSISTENT
BUT THIS IS ONE AREA WHERE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CONSISTENT ARE
THE COMPLAINT OF INDEED SPIKED
--
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY THIS YEAR UP
ONE OF THOSE COMPLAINTS I'M
HEARING A LOT ABOUT AYE IS ABOUT
THE THE SYSTEM JUST SHUTTING
DOWN AND THAT'S A BIG PART POINT
OF FRUSTRATION THAT PEOPLE HAVE
IS THAT.
ACCUSE NOT MOVING AT ALL BECAUSE
THE SOFTWARE SYSTEMS ARE
OPERATING OUT WERE THE COMPUTER
SYSTEMS ARE OPERATING BUT DO WE
HAVE ENOUGH --
TO COVER THAT TRANSITION OR IS
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE PROBLEM
HERE WITH THIS IT AMOUNT OF THE
SOFTWARE PROBLEMS.
SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AN INCH AT
WORK WITH THEM THAT IF THERE%
ISN'T ANY ME ANY AYE AYE AYE T.
SYSTEM CHANGER UPGRADE.
THAT IS BEING DONE OFF HOURS ON
THE WEEKENDS AND THEN WHEN THAT
IS BEING DONE ADEQUATE TESTED SO
THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE NOT GOING
DOWN.
WHEN IT'S WHEN IT DOES GO IT'S
ALL HANDS ON DECK BECAUSE CREDIT
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY WORK WITH
THEM IN TERMS OF PUBLISHING WHAT
THAT PROBLEM IS?
THAT WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT THAT
DOES NOT AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
ANY CHANGE OR UPGRADE IS GOING
TO BE AT BE.
APPROVED AT THE HIGHER LEVELS --
AND DEFTLY BY THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AND
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR BEFORE
ANY CHANGES AND SAME WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DMV.
WITH FOR US IT'S ARE ADAPTING
[inaudible]
MAYOR UPGRADE [inaudible]
YES HYSLOP.
SO WE CAN MINIMIZE THE SYSTEM
GOING DOWN. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
I GET A LOT FROM CONSTITUENTS
AYE IS ABOUT THE AB SIXTY
DRIVERS LICENSE THE NON CITIZEN
DRIVER'S LICENSES AND HOW MUCH.
I IS THAT CONTRIBUTING TO WASTE
--
WAIT TIMES UP OR DO WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE AYE THOSE ADDITIONAL
DRIVER'S LICENSES.
ADD THOSE A LOT OF APPLICANTS
FOR THOSE HAVE LEVELED OFF
REDOING PROBABLY ABOUT. NINE TO
TEN THOUSAND A MONTH ONLINE THAT
TWO THOUSAND A WEEK SO THAT THAT
HAS LEVELED OFF.
HOW IS NOT AFFECTING --
IN TERMS OF ANYWAY WANTING.
TO GET A REAL ID SO THAT IS
PRETTY PRIMITIVE LEVELED OFF.
THANK COMMISSIONER.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS CHAIRMAN
ALONG THANK --
YOU AND MR A FRAZIER FOR PUTTING
THE SONGS I THINK IT'S VERY
TIMELY --
SPEAKING OF MISTER HARPER ASKED
MY QUITE.
YOU.
LET ME JUST KIND OF FINESSE IT
--
YOUR TECHNOLOGY WHAT ARE YOU
DOING IN TERMS OF TRYING TO PUT
A INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN PLACE THAT WILL ADDRESS WHAT
MR HARPER TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS
OF COMPUTER GLITCHES --
A FRAMEWORK BECAUSE I'M HEARING
THAT YOU KNOW THAT --
IN FACT THAT YOU GUYS GO TRY TO
RESPOND TO COMPUTER GLITCHES BUT
IS THERE A MECHANISM OR PLAN. TO
ANTICIPATE THESE KIND OF
GLITCHES MOVING.
FOR I HAVE WELL AND IF IT IF IT
LETS DOES OCCUR I'VE YOU KNOW WE
WHAT WE DO IS WE PLAN.
FOR AYE WHEN WE DO ANY UPGRADES
OR ANY CHANGES IN THOSE ARE --
TESTED AND MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS LOAD BALANCING THINGS
LIKE THAT AND SO THAT THE INTENT
IS THAT THERE WOULD NOT BE A
COMPUTER GLITCH IN SO HE SAID.
IF YOU WANT TO ANTICIPATE --
WE NEED YOU ARE JOB ENSURING
THAT IT IS ADEQUATELY TESTED
PLAN FOR THAT IS DONE OFF HOURS
AND NOT WHERE IT WOULD EFFECT.
OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
OKAY MY NEXT QUESTION IS --
SECURITY --
I KNOW THAT I THINK HAVE PRIVATE
AND SO --
AND I REPRESENT ONE THE DIEM
THESE IN MY DISTRICT AND
SECURITY IS AN ISSUE --
AS RACE OF THIS PARTICULAR DMV
AND GIVE EXAMPLE MY WIFE WAS
ADDED GMB --
WE WAIT IN LINE TO AND SHE THERE
WAS A SITUATION THAT TRANSPIRED
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY GRABBED HER
AND PULLED HER OVER THE COUNTER
ALONG WITH.
OTHER INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE SECURE
IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA IS IS IS
EXTREMELY BAD I DON'T KNOW
THAT'S CONSISTENT --
IN OTHER AREAS BUT SECURITY IS
CERTAINLY AN ISSUE --
AT THE DMV IN WHICH I REPRESENTS
A CAN YOU SPEAK TO SECURITY.
SO THAT IS THROUGH A A PRIVATE
CONTRACTOR THAT'S A AND SO --
OF I I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT WHAT OFFICES AND WHAT
THEIR ISSUES ARE WITH THE
SECURITY SO WE CAN GO BACK AND
DIRECTLY ADDRESS IT WITH THAT
SECURITY IN TERMS OF THE OFFICE
--
NOBODY SHOULD BE GRABBED AND SO
THAT I'M GRATEFUL THEY DID
BECAUSE IT WAS A A BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO THAT WAS IT AN INFANT
IN AND SEND IT YEAH O. THESE
INCIDENTS HAPPEN.
YEAH BUT AND SO I YES THERE ARE
INCIDENTS AND THAT'S WHY WE DO
HAVE SECURITY TO ENSURE THAT IF
THERE IS ANY --
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE --
NOT BEHAVING VERY WELL THAT DAY
THAT THEY HAVE WORKED TO CALM
DOWN THE SITUATION AND IN TERMS
OF MAKING SURE THAT --
THERE IS OF KNOWING THAT THINGS
THAT'LL GET A HAND WE ALSO WILL
CALL THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL.
BUT THEY DO COME ASSIST OFFICES
BROUGHT HER HER PURSE OR USED TO
BE THERE --
AND IMITATE THE REASON WHAT.
BECAUSE OF THE WAIT TIME.
I'M IS ALMOST OF HAVING --
SOME LEVEL USE THAT EXAMPLE.
IT THE WAIT TIME IS SO LONG.
THAT PEOPLE ARE IRRITATED --
WITH YOU BOB SOMEONE.
THERE AND ON A HOT DAY THAT SETS
OFF SITUATIONS THAT TRANSPIRED
THERE THAT'S BEYOND THAT THE
PERSONNEL CONTROL --
AGAIN IS THAT WHEN YOU GO TO THE
DMV ELISE IN MY EXPERIENCE I'M
GOING TO BE SPENT AN HOUR TO TWO
HOURS THERE TO DMB JEST GOING
FROM ONE PLACE --
INCOME IN FACT TO THE OTHER AND
SO THOSE KINDS OF SITUATIONS ARE
EXPLOSIVE --
AT THE DMV DISTANT WITH OTHER
DMV'S BUT THE WAIT TIME IS
CERTAINLY AN ISSUE.
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT AND WHAT
WE'RE ALSO WORKING TO DO WITH
OUR A STAR HERE WINDOW --
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE --
EMPLOYEES TRIAGE IN THE LINE
THAT IF CUSTOMERS DON'T NEED TO
BE THERE IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT DOCTORS THAT CAN GIVE IT
BACK LEISURE TIME SO THAT WE
COULD DO THAT WAIT TIME.
WE ALSO ARE OUT WORKING TO GET
THE CUSTOMERS IN SOONER BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND THAT WITH THE
WEATHER IT IS HOT AND PEOPLE
CAN'T STAND OUT THERE IN.
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME SO WE ARE
WORKING TO EXPEDITE TO GET
CUSTOMERS IN THE OFFICE SOONER
IN SO WE HAVE A SIMPLIFIED THAT
IF YOU JUST ARE A VEHICLE
REGISTRATION DRIVERS LICENSE --
OR A COMBINATION OF THE TWO OR
DISABLED THAT YOU'RE JUST GOING
TO GET THAT TYPE THE TICKET AND
NOT A GET WE HAD --
TWELVE CARRIERS OF THE TICKETS
WE JUST SIMPLIFIED IT TO SEVEN
CATEGORIES SO THAT YOU'RE JUST
GIVEN THE TICKET AND YOU CAN
COME INSIDE AND SIT DOWN.
AND THEN OUT WORK TO GET THE
TECHNICIANS TO CALL YET SO WE
ARE WORKING VERY HARD TO GET THE
CUSTOMERS IN THE OFFICE SOONER
AND THEY CAN --
SIT DOWN OR WITH OUR SOON
TEXTILES VACATION WE'LL GET THAT
NOTIFICATION SO WE I UNDERSTAND
THAT DEFTLY WE DO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CUSTOMERS ARE SAFE
OUTSIDE.
WE'RE WORKING TO GET THEM INSIDE
AND THEN WORKING WITH ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS IN THE PROCESS
APPROVALS EFFICIENCIES TO GET
THE CUSTOMER SURVEY AFTER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON AND
THAT ALSO WENT CAN I ADD JUST
ONE MORE THING THAT WE ALSO DID
ADD AN EXPEDITE WINDOW SO HEARD
CONCERNS FROM SOME OF THE
MEMBERS --
THAT IF YOU HAVE A SIMPLE
TRANSACTION YOU'RE PICKING UP
IT'S STABLE PLACARD THE PICKING
UP YOUR PLAY TO JUST GETTING A
VEHICLE RECORD OR YOU NEED TO
COME BACK AND BECAUSE YOU HAVE.
PUT YOUR SMOG WE HAVE AT IT
CREATED WHEN WE KNOW THAT IT'S
EXPEDITE YOU DON'T EVEN NEED TO
GET A TICKET AT STAR HERE
THROUGH THE TRIAGE PROCESS
YOU'LL BE DIRECTED STRAIGHT
INSIDE AND BE PROCESS.
BUT THE COULD YOU HAVE HEARD%
COMPLAINTS I WAITED FIVE OR SIX
HOURS AND I HAD A SIMPLE FIVE
MINUTE TRANSACTION SO WE HAVE
CREATED THOSE EXPECT WINDOWS YOU
CAN GO STRAIGHT TO THAT WINDOW.
AND NOT EVEN GET A TICKET.
THEY COULD MISS SPENT A FEW
[inaudible]
UP.
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD THE TERM --
COMPLETE COMPUTER GLITCHES
[inaudible]
ARE.
YOU'RE HAVING SUBSTANTIAL AND
RECURRING.
OUTAGES.
IT'S NOT JUST GLITCHES.
HOW MANY OUTAGES HAVE YOU HAD?
RECENTLY.
HOW LONG DO THEY LAST?
AND DO YOU HAVE ABSOLUTE
CONFIDENCE IN YOUR TECHNOLOGY.
TO BE ABLE TO DO THE KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL ASSISTING.
BUT YOU HAVE SUGGESTED THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO IMPLEMENT LIKE
TEXTING AND OTHER THINGS GOING.
SO THE TEXAS SOME OF THAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'RE IMPLEMENTS
US OF TAXING IS DONE TO THE
VENDOR FOR ACUMEN SYSTEM SO THEY
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
IN TERMS OF OUR SYSTEMS A WE DID
EVAN I DID YESTERDAY --
WE WERE RECOVERED BY ABOUT THAT
I THINK ABOUT A TEN O'CLOCK NINE
THIRTY TEN O'CLOCK --
SYSTEMS REQUIRE BUT NOT ALL THE
SYSTEMS WERE DOWN ALL OVER WITH
WORKSTATIONS WERE DOWN --
ABOUT THREE QUARTERS OF
WORKSTATIONS ARE DOWN THE REST
WERE COMING BACK THAT AND SO WE
WORK WITH OUR DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY TROUBLE SHOULD WHAT
THE PROBLEM WAS.
AND OF WORK WITH THEM IN TERMS.
OF ALL AND I THE EXACT NUMBER I
DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME TODAY
WILL GET BACK WITH YOU FOR THAT.
NOW WE ARE MARCHING AND DEFTLY
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNER THE
PART OF TECHNOLOGY AND
ADDRESSING WHERE WE WILL WORK TO
DO ANY UPGRADES AFTER HOURS AND
ON THE WEEKENDS AND THEN TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO ADEQUATE
TESTING SO THAT THESE GLITCHES
IN THE SYSTEMS DO NOT GO DOWN.
DO YOU HAVE A A SENSE OF I CAN.
YOU'RE THE DIRECTOR.
CAN'T YOU GIVE US AN IDEA OF THE
SCOPE OF HOW MANY OUTAGES.
CAN'T I'M BUT MAYBE NOT A NUMBER
BUT REGULARLY [inaudible]
BODY.
EVERY NOW AND THEN.
NOT VERY OFTEN.
HOW SERIOUS ARE YOUR OUTAGES?
SO ANYMORE AND SO.
I THERE MAY BE WHO IN GOT
YESTERDAY WAS FOR A COUPLE HOURS
--
DEFTLY WE WORK QUICKLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY OTHER MAY
BE INSTANCES WHERE I IT COULD BE
A A HALF A DAY BUT DIDN'T AND WE
HAVE TO FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED
WHAT.
IN TROUBLE SHOOT AND FIND THE
ROOT CAUSE AND WE WILL WE WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
WORK WITH AND THE VENDORS THAT
SUPPORT OUR SYSTEMS.
IN TERMS OF FINDING WHAT THE
ROOT CAUSE IS AND SO WE HAVE
WORKED QUICKLY DETERMINE WHAT
THAT ROOT CAUSES AND THEN WORK
TO FIGURE WHAT TECHNOLOGY DO WE
NEED TO DO WE NEED TO REPLACE A
PART.
WAS THERE ANY A FAILURE OF OF
THE HARDWARE --
THEN WE HAVE TO WORK WILL GET TO
FIGHT TO THE VENDORS THAT WE
HAVE ON ON SITE THAT WE PARTNER
WITH TO GET EQUIPMENT AND AS
QUICKLY AS THEY CAN.
I'M ASKING FOR A DESCRIPTIVE
[inaudible]
TERMINOLOGY THAT WAS NOT AN
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION HOW
OFTEN.
BUT A LOT A LITTLE.
EVERY NOW AND THEN I MEAN YOU
YOU YOU MUST HAVE SOME IDEA OF
THE DESCRIPTION OF HOW OFTEN.
YOUR TECHNOLOGY FAILS.
CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME KIND OF A
DESCRIPTION.
FROM THE DIRECTOR OF THIS
DEPARTMENT.
SO -- AS WE
DIDN'T THERE WAS AN UPGRADE THAT
WAS DONE OVER THE WEEKEND --
WE DID HAVE A FAILURE OF A WORD
NOT ALL THE WORK STATION WERE
OPENED YESTERDAY THAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY.
OF WE HAVE I WOULD HAVE TO GO
BACK TO GET THE DEFINITE NUMBERS
OF WHERE WE HAVE A OUTAGES I
DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME TODAY
ADEPTLY GET YOU THAT TOMORROW.
TERM.
A QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO THE
WAIT TIMES AND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE REALITY OF THE WAIT
TIMES AND WHAT YOU REPORT.
ARE WILL HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS
TOMORROW.
A BUT THERE ARE INCREASINGLY
INDICATIONS.
THAT --
YOU'RE NOT REALLY TELLING.
THE STRAIGHT STORY ABOUT THE
WAIT TIME SO YOU'RE POSTING.
ON THE INTERNET A WAIT TIME OF
WHAT AN HOUR OR SO.
IS THAT NOT CALCULATED FROM THE
TIME THAT THE INDIVIDUAL GETS A
TICKET.
AND THE TIME THAT THEY GET TO A
WINDOW WHAT I'M HEARING IS THERE
ARE.
SUBSTANTIAL WAIT TIMES AHEAD OF
ALL OF THAT.
AND YOUR REPORTING ESSENTIALLY
TICKET TO WINDOW WAIT TIME
INSTEAD OF A COMPLETE.
IN THE LINE THROUGH THE DOOR.
THROUGH THE WAY.
AT THROUGH THE QUEUING TO THE
TICKET TO THE WINDOW CAN YOU
EXPLAIN [inaudible]
THAT.
SO I'VE YES OF THE WAIT TIME IS
WHEN YOU GET A TICKET TO WIN
YOUR SERVE BY THAT BY A
TECHNICIAN THAT AS THE WAIT TIME
THAT WAS REPORT ON OUR WEBSITE.
AYE WE ARE WORKING WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED WHERE WE ARE --
TRACKING THE TIME IT CUSTOMERS
WAIT OUTSIDE SO IT IS A MANUAL
PROCESS WE ARE GIVEN A CUSTOMER
CARD AND THIS IS THAT THE TIME
THAT THEY SAY THEY ARE THE LAST
PERSON IN LINE READING THAT ON
THE OUR WORK COLLECTING THAT.
THE TURN THAT INTO THE START
HERE WINDOW WHERE COMPLAIN ALL
THAT INFORMATION SO THAT WE HAVE
IT WE KNOW HOW LONG CHRISTMAS
ARE WAITING --
ON THE HOUR EVERY HOUR OF WE ARE
WORKING TO POST THAT ON OUR
WEBSITE THAT IS NOT PART OF BY
QUEUING SYSTEM WHERE WE CAN
POST.
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO MANUALLY
IMPORT WERE TALKED.
SIGH POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE SO
CUSTOMERS.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE WAIT
WOULD BE WAITING OUTSIDE AND
THEN WAITING TO GET PROCESS AND
WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THE
PRESIDENT [inaudible]
METHODOLOGY.
FROM FROM TICKET TO WINDOW.
ARM.
IS INCOMPLETE INFORMATION AND
ESSENTIALLY REPORTS A FALLACY
[inaudible]
IT'S NOT [inaudible]
REAL.
IT IS TICKET TO WINDOW.
AND WHEN YOU POST SOMETHING ON
THEIR WEB THAT SAYS ONE THING
AND THEN THE EXPERIENCE BY.
PEOPLE WHO COME MAN AT IT'S TWO
THREE FOUR HOURS IN LINE THEN
YOU GET A TICKET IT'S ANOTHER
COUPLE HOURS TO THE TO THE
WINDOW WOULD YOU.
AGREE THAT THAT IS NOT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCURACY AND%
THAT YOU SHOULD BE DOING A
BETTER JOB.
SO WE ARE WORKING WE ARE
MEASURING WHERE WE ARE --
CLICK IN THE INFORMATION ON HOW
LONG IT TAKES FOR THE WAIT TIME
OUTSIDE WE ARE CLICK THAT
INFORMATION LIKE SAID.
OREGON THE VENDOR TO GET THAT
INFORMATION POSTED SO WE CAN BE
TRANSPARENT AND COMMUNICATE THAT
TO THE CUSTOMER SO THAT THEY
WILL KNOW WHAT THE WAIT TIME IS
OUTSIDE APPROXIMATELY AND THE
WEIGHT DOT TIME TO GET SERVED.
AYE WHEN THEY GET A TICKET
ANSWER BY A TECHNICIAN SO YES --
OUR WEBSITE DOES INDICATE WHAT
THE TIME IS TO GET SERVED A WHEN
YOU GET THERE WE ARE WORKING TO
UP A POST THE TIME THAT IT TAKES
THAT OUTSIDE THE LINE OUTSIDE.
A WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO THAT YET WE'RE TALKING ARE
GOING TO SEE IF WE CAN GETTHAT
POSTED SO THAT.
THE CUSTOMERS TRULY KNOW WHAT
THE EXPERIENCE IS A MAYBE.
TRACK I WOULD I WOULD THINK THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND TRYING TO BE
ACCURATE.
BUT YOU CERTAINLY COULD HAVE
DONE SOME.
ROUGH SKETCH ESTIMATES BASICALLY
AND REPORTING THAT WHICH
BASICALLY SAYS DUE TO THE VOLUME
DUE TO SOME OF THESE WEIGHT
ISSUES.
THERE MAY BE TWO THREE FOUR HOUR
WAITS BEFORE YOU GET A TICKET.
I MEAN PEOPLE HAVE OR THAT OF
RIGHT TO KNOW PRECISELY WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING AND YOU'RE
ASKING THEM TO GO TO THE
TECHNOLOGY TO UTILIZE IT.
AND YET THE TECHNOLOGY IS FAULTY
IT IS FAILING AND EVEN WHEN YOU
USE THE TECHNOLOGY.
YOU'RE NOT CLEAR YOU'RE NOT
ACCURATE WITH IT I WANNA ASK ONE
FINAL QUESTION HERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF MODERNIZING --
WHEN IS THAT GOING TO BE DONE
WHEN WILL YOU BE ABLE TO REPORT
TO US WE HAVE A MODERN? TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY TECHNOLOGICAL
HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE THAT WE
HAVE FULL CONFIDENCE IN.
THAT IT WILL DO ALL OF THE
TRANSACTIONS WE WANTED
[inaudible] TO DO.
OUT WE WILL NOT HAVE DOWN TIMES
AND THAT THE ACCURACY OF THE
INFORMATION IS TRUSTWORTHY WHEN
DO WE GET. TO THAT KIND OF
REPRESENTATION TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE SO WE WE THANK
THE LEGISLATURE FOR APPROVING
OUR PRIOR FUNDING REQUEST WE
HAVE BEGUN THE PROJECT WE HAVE
THE PROJECT TEAM ON SITE.
OF WE ARE A WORKING IN TERMS OF
THE MODERNIZATION ON THE FRONT
OF THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION SITE
THAT PROJECT HAS BEGUN.
A WE ARE WORKING ON THAT AND WE
ARE WORKING ON THE BUSINESS OF
CARDS FOR THEM FUND AND
MODERNIZATION AND NOW WE ADDED
THAT FUNDING REQUEST THIS IS
THIS PAST BUDGET YEAR TO ASK FOR
THAT FUNDING SO WEAK.
THAT PROJECT IS UNDER WAY I
BELIEVE IT WILL BE DONE IN THREE
YEARS.
AB THAT THEM WITH A MULTI DAY
THAT REMEMBER THE MULTI PHASED
APPROACH WE'RE GONNA NAM GO WITH
THE HAM PBA'S THEM TRIPLE A. M.
THEM.
DANDY SO WAS A PHASED APPROACH
OF REMEMBER WARNED OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION.
AND I BELIEVE I'M A IT WAS
PROBABLY.
I THINK WITH A FOUR FIVE YEAR
I'M TIMEFRAME.
SO ONE OF THINGS THAT WE WANT TO
DO NOT FACE APPROACH WAS LESSEN
THE IMPACT --
TURNED TERMS OF A CUSTOMER SO
OUR BUSINESS PARTNERS THEY DO A
SUBSET OF TRANSACTIONS WE'RE
GOING TO MODERNIZE THOSE FIRST
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH
OUR NEXT PARTNERS AS WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT.
AUTO CLUBS THEY DO ANOTHER
SUBSET OF TRANSACTIONS AND THEN
WHEN WE DO ALL THE FULL SINCE WE
OF TRANSACTIONS ARE FILLED
OFFICES DO.
A WE WILL BE ABLE TO QUICKLY ONE
THE FIELD OFFICES AT IF WE DID
ALL THE TRANSACTIONS ON THE
FIELD OFFICES ADD UP FRONT AT
THE SAME TIME.
WOULD TAKE LONGER TO TO IT WOULD
IMPACT THE FIELD OFFICES UP
GREATLY IF WE STARTED WITH THEM
SO WHERE TALK TARGETING WITH THE
FIRST SUBSET OF TRANSACTIONS FOR
VEHICLE REGISTRATION THE NOT SO
UPSET.
WERE OUR AUTO CLUBPARTNERS DO
DO MORE SO THIS IS A FACED
APPROACH SO WEEKEND I MODERNIZE
OUR SYSTEM.
THOUGH IT YOU'RE GONNA HEAR SOME
TESTIMONY TOMORROW --
THAT DOG FROM FROM A PEOPLE TO
WORK WITH US TECHNOLOGY FOR A
LONGER TIME YOU GOT HERE.
PHRASES LIKE OUT WE HAVE THE
FORTY YEAR OLD DINOSAUR OF A
TECHNOLOGICAL OPERATION IS THAT
ACCURATE.
YES IT IS.
S. IT IS OUR TECHNOLOGY IS OLD
AND WE ARE TOLD THAT WE ARE
WORKING TO MODERNIZE IT WE DID
ON THE DRIVER'S LICENSES AND
THAT IS MODERNIZE BUT WE DEFTLY.
WE STILL HAVE TO MODERNIZE THE
FIN AND YES IT IS OLD.
M. AND THAT THE A YOUR PARTNERS.
OTHER TRIP WAYS IN THOSE.
THOSE OUTSIDE PARTNERS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY ARE
SLAVES TO YOUR COMPUTERS AND
THAT WHEN YOU GO DOWN.
THEY GO DOWN IS THAT TRUE.
YES THEY ARE TIED TO ISIS AS WE
HAVE OF STAFF THERE THEY THEY
WORK ON STAY OPEN AS LONG AS
THEY ARE THEY'RE OPEN ON
WEEKENDS ARE OPEN ON HOLIDAYS TO
SUPPORT THEM IN TERMS OF THEIR
SYSTEMS.
TO APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR
BEING HERE I REALLY DO OUT WERE
REALLY TRYING TO FIND OUT WHAT
HOW DEEP AND WIDE THE PROBLEM
IS.
AND I I AM GRATEFUL THAT YOU ARE
HERE AND OUT.
TAKING A QUESTIONS FROM SOMEBODY
WHO.
I HAD I DON'T MEAN TO BE GRUMPY
--
BUT I HAVE WE ALL.
I JUST AFTER A THAT I HAVE I
HAVE A I HAVE ON MY DESK --
FRIEND OF MINE THE ARAB WHO GAVE
ME A FRONT WENT TO THE HARRY
TRUMAN.
LIBRARY AND IT HAS --
ON MY DESK THE BUCK STOPS HERE.
I THINK I MAY WANT TO BEQUEATH
THAT TO YOU I THINK THAT'S A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT YOU FACE.
THAT IS MY DEPARTMENT CORRECT
BETTER AND YES THE BUCK STOPS
WITH BUT YOU.
THANK YOU I'M GLAD WE CAN ALL BE
--
FORTHRIGHT TODAY THAT'S
WONDERFUL MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU --
JEAN THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND AGAIN --
AG.
AGREEING THAT YEAH THE BUCK DOES
STOP WITH YOU --
ONE OF THE THINGS IS IS THERE
NOT A PROTOCOL IN PLACE THAT
WHEN.
WHEN YOU HAVE A ON OFFICES
COMPLETELY IMPACTED WITH
CUSTOMERS WERE YOU CAN HAVE A
MOBILE RESPONSE THAT TO COME IN
AND ACTUALLY?
TAKE CARE OF THE PEOPLE OF AND
AND ALLEVIATE THE SIX AND EIGHT
HOUR WAITS WE'RE HEARING ABOUT
--
IT IS I MEAN.
DO YOU NEED TO DO THAT BUT YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO BE MORE
MOBILE.
SO THAT IF THERE IS AN IMPACT ON
A CERTAIN DAY THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY JUST.
AND IT ACCOMMODATE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO TO
GET SERVICE.
YET SO WE HAVE EIGHT REGIONS WE
HAVE REGIONAL OFFICES AND SO AS
THE OFFICE REPORTING IF THERE IS
A STAFF SHORTAGE THEY HAVE.
SO THEY'RE MOVING EMPLOYEES
AROUND AND SO WE HAVE A RELIEF
TEAMS WE HAVE LIVE RELIEF
MANAGERS AND EMPLOYEES THAT GO
OUT TO THESE OFFICES.
AND SO WE ARE JUST STACKING UP
THROUGHOUT THE MORNING WE MOVE
STAFF AROUND AYE IN THESE
LOCATIONS --
AND SOME DO TRAVEL A BIT OF A
DISTANCE BECAUSE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE OFFICES WITH
GREAT DISTANCES.
WE DO I STAND STEP OUT IT JUST
AND WE HAVE EIGHT REGIONS BUT HE
SAID WE HAVE NO REGIONAL LINES
FIVE OFFICERS ARE CLOSE BY.
AND THEY CAN LOAN IF YOU STEP
OVER TO ANOTHER OFFICE THOSE
EMPLOYEES MOVE OVER.
THANK YOU --
THIS QUESTIONS TO KINDA FINANCE
--
DO YOU BELIEVE THE DMV HAS THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE.
PARTMINER PART OF FINANCE --
OKAY TO IT OFF WITH THAT TO HIM
SURVEYS --
DID THEY NOT PLAN WELL OR IS THE
ADMINISTRATION OF PLANNING FOR
THESE ISSUE ALSO --
SO THE FIRST VIRTUAL THE TWO
HUNDRED AND THE NEW TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY POSITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
REQUESTED ARM WILL CERTAINLY
HELP -- AT
WHEN WHEN WHEN THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL WAS PUT TOGETHER
WE WENT THROUGH A LOT OF THE YOU
KNOW ALL OF THE METRICS HOW MANY
--
HOW MANY RENEWALS HOW MANY
IDENTIFICATIONS HOW MANY --
FIRST TIME AND AND THE I THINK
TO THEIR CREDIT OPPOSED ANY IT
ISSUES THAT DEPARTMENT VEHICLES
TRACKS THESE THINGS YOU KNOW
VERY WELL.
ARM AND SO I'M IN SOME CASES THE
OTHER LEFT TO ESTIMATING.
HOW MANY PEOPLE WILL COME IN AND
WANT A I'M A REAL ID THE FIRST
TIME?
AND SO ARE.
YOU KNOW THEY DID SOME RESEARCH
AND CAME UP THE NUMBER AND IT
TURNS OUT THAT THE NUMBER THAT
OF BUT OF CUSTOMERS ARE
INTERESTED IN THAT.
IS IS LOWER THAN WHAT WAS
ANTICIPATED WASN'T ANTICIPATED.
WAS THAT --
AS CUSTOMERS COME UP TO THE
DESK.
THEY DECIDE THAT THEY'VE YOU
KNOW THE EIGHT BIT.
THE CUSTOMER SERVICE PERSON AT
THE DESK WANTS TO OFFER A REALLY
DEEP.
AND THEN THERE ARE OTHER FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS AND IN PART OF THE
REQUESTED PART OF DMV'S
IMPLANTATION --
THEY DID MEDIA BLASTS THEIR
WEBSITE HAS PROVIDED INFORMATION
THEY'VE PUT OUT MAILERS SO A AND
MEN FEEL TO THEIR OFFICE AND
FEAR YOU KNOW THEREFORE IN ANY
AMOUNT OF TIME TO SEE.
A POSTERS EXPLAINING WHAT REAL
IDEAS AND WHAT YOU NEED TO DO SO
--
THESE OTHER STEPS WERE ALSO PART
OF THEIR PROCESS.
IN A IN PUTTING TOGETHER HOW WE
GOING -- TO
GET THIS OUT TO THE CUSTOMERS.
AND SO ARM WITH THEY DIDN'T
ANTICIPATE WAS IN OF THE FACT
THAT I WAS STAYING ALL OF THOSE
OTHER.
YOU KNOW OUTLETS THERE WOULD
STILL BE OTHER QUESTIONS ON
ANAHIT THAT REALLY COMES OUT OF
THAT THE MATHIS.
NOT NOT THAT COMPLICATED --
AND THAT'S THE ONE THING I THINK
THAT WELL UNDERESTIMATED.
OKAY SO WHAT I'M SAGE.
JERRY WHEN I SEE A BUDGET
REQUEST OR ANY KIND OF BILL
ANALYSIS WHEN DEAL IF HE GETS IT
ENGAGED THEY ALSO PUT THEIR
THEIR STAMP OF EITHER APPROVAL
OR DISAPPROVAL.
AND IT --
APPARENTLY.
YOU GUYS WERE IN LINE WITH THE
DMV THIS YEAR WITH.
AND LEISURE WHAT'S CALLED THE OF
THE REQUESTS WERE UNIT NOISE IN
MY BEING MORE --
FATE YOU JUST FELL IN LINE WITH
THE DMV AND JUST SAID OKAY THIS
IS WHAT YOU GET --
BECAUSE AGAIN.
OF WHEN I SEE THE DEAL WORTH
MAKING ANALYSIS IS SOMETIMES
VERY CONTRARY TO AN AGENCY OR A
BILL REQUEST OF OUR BUDGET
REQUEST SO --
I'M SEEING.
THAT -- THEY
NEED HELP [inaudible]
OBVIOUSLY.
AND AND WE'RE HERE BECAUSE OF
THERE WAS IT THERE WAS A
DISASTER GOING ON IN THE PUBLIC
BASICALLY SAYING.
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO CUSTOMER
SERVICE RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
AND LACK OF MANPOWER --
THAT WHAT WAS A AN ESTIMATE.
LOVE IT TOOK.
IT OVER CONSTITUENT CALLS TO
COME IN AND TELL US.
AND THEN.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO HAVE TO STAND ON OF
A LINE AROUND THE CORNER FROM
THE DMV OFFICE TO TO TO TRY TO
GET A RENEWAL --
YOU KNOW IT.
WITH THESE AGENCIES BUTTON.
I AM I'M AND I'M LOST FOR WORDS
WHEN YOU KNOW THAT ALL THE
SUDDEN.
THERE IT HERE AFTER THE FACT
AFTER THE BUDGET'S PASSED.
AND YOU KNOW THAT WAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT.
I THINK WAS COOL OR WHAT THE
REQUEST WAS COOL SO.
I CAN EXPLAIN.
PINNACLE BUT THE DEAL HAVE PUT
RESPONSIBLE ALSO.
MINNESOTA AND MANY THINK OF WE
UNDERSTAND THAT --
WE WHEN WE GET THESE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS WE WORK THROUGH
IT WITH DEPARTMENTS WE YOU KNOW
WE QUESTION THEIR ASSUMPTIONS
NAM.
AND WHICH ARE TO MAKE SURE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S REASONABLE AND
TO FOR EXAMPLE IF IF AN
APARTMENT WOULD COME IN AND SAY
WELL WE'RE GONNA.
BRING ASSUME THAT'S GONNA TAKE
TEMAS TO DISCUSS THIS AND AND
THEY DID HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OUTREACH RIGHT THERE MIGHT BE
SOMETHING THAT WE MIGHT ADDRESS
AND US ARE TALKING ABOUT AN
HOUR.
IN OUR EVALUATION SO --
MID TERMS OF WETTON PARTNER OR
VEHICLES CAME FORWARD WITH IN
THE REQUEST WE DID TALK THROUGH
ITS ALL PART OF OUR ANALYSIS AND
DATA -- AND
IN IT IT SEEMED REASONABLE AND I
THINK OF YOU KNOW.
BOTH APARTMENTS WE JUST MESSED
THIS -- THIS
ONE OTHER YOU KNOW MAJOR
COMPONENT AND UP BUT WE YOU
KNOW.
WE DID UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WAS
YOU KNOW.
WILSHIRE MAKE MAKE ROOM FOR SOME
RISK THAT YOU KNOW THERE MIGHT
BE A STICKER SO WE PUT THIS
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE AND TO TO
ALLOW US TO A DOWNTURN AND THE
JUST -- IF
FOR IF WE ARE WRONG ANYTHING.
APPRECIATE THAT SO JEAN.
HOW CAN WE HELP YOU?
SO AND YOUR RIGHT NOW.
RIVER IT'S A ROAD HOW CAN WE
HELP YOU.
SO WE WE DO APPRECIATE PREVIOUS
LEGISLATORS APPROVALS TO AUGMENT
OUR A BUDGETARY TO HIRE MORE
STAFF -- WE
DID NOT AND IT IS FATE AS THE
PART FINANCES THEM OUT ITS CASE
YOU NEED TO EXPLAIN A REAL ID TO
OUR CUSTOMERS --
WE WOULD ASK THAT TO GET
ADDITIONAL BUDGET AUTHORITY UP
UP TO UP TO TWENTY SIX MILLION
TO ALLOW US TO HIRE MORE STAFF.
WHICH INSURANCE SHOULD HELP
FURTHER ALLEVIATE THE WAIT TIMES
AND WE WOULD PROVIDE A MONTHLY
REPORTS LEGISLATIVE REPORTS TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
ABOUT WHATEVER STEAMY HAS
UNDERTAKEN AND HOW OF THESE ARE
REDUCING WAIT TIMES.
SO WE WOULD APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT [inaudible]
BUT I THINK YOU JUST SIX COUPLE
QUICK QUESTIONS.
MY AYE MIKE.
I BROUGHT A CONCERN AS THERE'S
THERE'S SOME OF THIS DISCONNECT
HIS A ONE THE ONE HAND YOU
MONITOR REAL TIME.
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS IN EACH
OF THE FIELD OFFICES.
AND THE OTHER HAND THERE'S SOME
DELAY IN ACTING.
AND NOW WE'RE SEND NOW WE'RE
SEEING THE WAIT TIMES NOW BEING
SO BAD THAT YOU'RE NOW SENDING
PEOPLE TO THESE FIELD OFFICES.
WHY WASN'T THIS DONE EARLIER IN
THE PROCESS IF YOU'RE TRACKING
EVERYTHING REAL TIME AND YOU
KNOW EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON
THE FIELD OFFICES WHY AREN'T YOU
SENDING STAFF WHEN THEY NEED IT?
SO WE ARE SAY THE STAFF AND WE
WERE SLOW TO RESPOND TO THAT I
AGREE I AGREE TO THAT.
OF BY SENDING THE STAFF THEY'RE
DOING NON PRODUCTION WORK UP TO
THESE FIELD OFFICE WERE PUTTING
THE TRAINED TECHNICIANS UP GORE
TREES ONLINE HELPING THE
CUSTOMERS.
DON'T SEE ME BACK ON WORKING ON
THE WINDOWS WE CAN PROCESS MORE
TRANSACTIONS AND SEE CUSTOMERS
AND SO I THE DIGITAL.
AUTHORITY WILL HELP US GET MORE
TRAIN OUR EMPLOYEES ON ON BOARD
SO THAT WE CAN HELP THE
CUSTOMERS AND SO --
YEAH WE WERE SLOW TO RESPOND TO
GET HEADQUARTERS TO DO THE NON
PRODUCTION WORK --
TO HELP OUR CUSTOMERS AND WE ARE
OUT WORKING FAST TO GET THE
EMPLOYEES THAT --
WE HAVE OUT THERE IS ANOTHER --
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX WE HAVE THAT
ALMOST ALL THOSE HIRED WE HOPE
TO HAVE THE REST OF THIRTY WHEN
THEY'RE HIRED AND THEN WITH
ADDITIONAL LAST RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE.
IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE OF
SIXTY MILLION THAT'S ANOTHER TWO
TO THIRTY AND SO WE ARE WORKING
ACTIVELY.
AND TO GET THOSE EMPLOYEES HARD
AS FAST AS WE CAN.
BECAUSE I AND I THINK YOU THE
I'M ASSUMING THOUGH AS THE
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY REAL ID
DEADLINE AS THAT PROCHES THIS.
I KNOW WE AUDIO IS NOT THE SOLE
CONCERT PURPOSE OF EVERYTHING
OTHER PROBLEMS AT THE DMV BUT
THIS CHALLENGE IT WILL ONLY
INTENSIFIES THAT CORRECT.
AND MORE CUSTOMERS ARE COMING IN
AND SO THIS IS WHERE IN TERMS OF
THE REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR MORE PEOPLE LIES WE
WANT.
TO AYE WE ARE MARCHING THE WAIT
TIMES MARGIN LINES OUTSIDE WE
NEED TO RAMP UP AND SO WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO BE ABLE TO HIRE MORE PEOPLE
EYES AS WE SEEK QUESTIONS COMING
AND AND BE ABLE TO RAMP UP. FOR
THAT.
AND ALSO JUST TO ADD TO THAT AT
IN REGARDS TO THE RELATED
PROPOSAL WEEKS SUMMIT IN FRONT
OF LEGISLATURE THERE'S ONLY
THOSE FIRST TWO YEARS OF FUNDING
WAS PROVIDED.
AND SO WE WILL BE COMING BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THAT WITH
ANOTHER PROPOSAL FOR THE
ADDITIONAL YEARS SO DO YOU HAVE
A PLAN IN TERMS OF HOW.
YOU'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THIS TO
ME DO YOU HAVE A PLAN.
THAT JUST THE IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA IMPLEMENT REAL ID OVER THE
NEXT --
HERE'S NOT STAFF NOT JUST NEAR
MONEY BUT WHAT ARE PROCESS HE'S
ARE GOING TO BE.
SO WE ARE LOOKING INTEREST
BUDGET WE ARE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
GET CUSTOMERS OUR FIELD OFFICES
OF WEAKENED --
OFFER OTHER OPTIONS ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES.
ALSO LOOKING AT WHERE WE LOOK AT
SOME OTHER SOLUTIONS WHERE THE
CUSTOM HAVE TO COME TO THE DMV.
AND SO THAT WE DO NOT HAVE TO WE
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SEE MORE
CUSTOMERS WERE LOOKING AT SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE ARE --
FLESHING OUT RIGHT NOW AND WHERE
WE COULD DO THAT AND SO WE HAVE
SOME THINGS THAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING WHAT SOME --
DISCUSSING INTERNALLY AND THEN
UP WITH WE NEED TO WE MADE DO
YOU NEED TO REST AT REQUEST AN
EXPEDITED.
PROCESS IN TERMS OF THE PROCESS
TO GET A PROJECT STARTED A WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME THINGS IN TERMS
OF WHERE WE COULD GET KEY --
CUSTOMERS WHO UP DO NOT NEED TO
COME TO THE DMV I CAN'T TALK
ABOUT WHAT THESE ARE AS YET
BECAUSE IF I HAVE TO PUT A
PROPOSAL OUT.
I DON'T WANT TO GET AHEAD OF THE
GAME BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT THOSE
SOLUTIONS IN TERMS OF IN GETTING
READY AS WE ARE GOING TO SEE
MORE ID CUSTOMERS.
ARE THERE WAYS THAT WE CAN GET
CUSTOMERS THAT DON'T NEED TO
COME TO DEEMED READ TO DO MORE
ONLINE SERVICES OR NOT HAVE TO
COME TO THE OFFICE.
BUT YOU'LL RELEASE THAT PLAN OR
RELEASE WILL DISCUSS IT PUBLICLY
CORRECTIVE WE KNOW THIS IS
COMING YEAH OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTIES COMING.
AND SO WILL WE GET AT LEAST SAID
AND THE DETAILS OF A PLAN OF
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO AND WE
SHOULD PROBABLY HAVE ONE ALREADY
BUT YET SO YOU KNOW WE ARE
OUTLOOK EXPLORING SOME OF THESE
THINGS -- WE
ARE --
TALKING TO SOME VENDORS ABOUT --
WHAT THEY OFFER IN SO WE?
THEN HOW IT WOULD IMPLEMENT THAT
AND THEN WE WOULD --
GO FORWARD WITH THAT IT COULD BE
A A PILOT COULD BE APPROVED THE
CONCEPT TO SEE IF WE CAN DO THAT
BUT THEN WE DO HAVE A PLAN.
IS TO REDUCE THE CUSTOMER IS NOT
HAVING TO COME TO THE DMV AND WE
CAN HAVE THIS A MORE SERVICES A
DONE OUTSIDE WITH OUR PARTNERS
WE ARE WORKING WITH THAT TOO CAN
WIN RELEASED BE ABLE TO SEE A
PLAN OR AN ALLY ARE WORKING ON
THAT RIGHT NOW --
SO WE WOULD COME BACK TO YOU
ONCE WE HAVE THAT THAT DONE BUT
WE'RE ART I DON'T UNDER
DISCUSSION RIGHT NOW OKAY I
WOULD JUST SAY TO THE CHAIR OF
MY MY CONCERN IS BEFORE WE START
GIVING MORE MONEY I THINK WE
SHOULD.
BEGIN TO SEE A PLAN FIRST AND
WHAT THAT WOULD WOULD ENTAIL BUT
I JUST LAST QUESTION WOULD YOU
BE WOULD YOU BE OPEN ARE WELCOME
REVIEW BY.
SOME OUTSIDE ENTITY TO REVIEW
THE PROCESS HE'S AND HOW THINGS
OPERATE IN EUROPE AND YOUR
OPERATION.
SO -- YOU
KNOW WE ARE OPEN TO SUGGESTIONS
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE CAN DO
BETTER SO --
WE ARE YOU WE ALL THINK ANYBODY
AT GIVING US A SUGGESTIONS.
BUT JUDGING AUDITOR REVIEW IF
YOU PROCESS IF YOU HAVE THAT AND
I DON'T WOULD REQUIRE US TO
REDIRECT THE RESOURCES REQUIRED
TO HAVE DEDICATED TO REDUCING
THE WAIT TIMES AND SO THEN AND
IF ANY AUDIT YOU HAVE TO PULL
OUT A DOCUMENT YOU HAVE.
TO A DIFFERENT AS PEOPLE ARE
WORKING ON DIFFERENT PROJECTS
WOULD BE REDIRECTED TO AT
RESPONDING TO AN AUDIT AND THAT
WOULD PULL OUR RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE WORKING.
AYE AND THE TEAM THAT WE HAVE
TOGETHER RIGHT NOW WORKING TO
REDUCE THE WAIT TIME WE WOULD --
HAVE TO REDIRECT THOSE RESOURCES
IF WE HAD TO RESPOND TO NOT AND
THAT WOULD MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE
WORKING ON THE SOLUTIONS THAT WE
HAVE TO REDUCE THE WAIT TIME.
AYE AYE AMENABLE WEARS YOU OUT
BUT A YEAR VERY HESITANT TO NOT
IT.
I IT WOULD WE DIRECTED WE WOULD
IT STRAIN OUR RESOURCES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GEN I WILL FOLLOW THAT UP.
I HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT UP.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN EXECUTIVE
STAFF FROM YOU.
AN ENTIRE EXECUTIVE STAFF.
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE YOUR
HANDS ON AND ALL THE
INFORMATION.
AT YOUR DISPOSAL.
YOU SHOULD BE HAVING THAT
INFORMATION IN FRONT OF YOU
RIGHT NOW.
AN AUDIT IS MERELY GOING TO ASK
YOU TO DIVULGE AND DISCLOSE AND
REPORT.
SO TO SUGGEST THAT AN AUDIT IN
ORDER TO DIG DEEP DOWN INTO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING BY A COMPETENT
AUDITOR WHO HAS.
LOTS OF HISTORY IN FINDING AREAS
OF PROBLEMS AND HELPING US SOLVE
THEM.
IS IN YOUR JUDGMENT.
A PROBLEM BECAUSE YOU CAN
DELIVERED THE BASIC INFORMATION
THAT A DEPARTMENT.
DIRECTOR OUGHT TO IMMEDIATELY
HAVE AT YOUR DISPOSAL.
YOU MUST EXPLAIN I I DID NOT SAY
WAS A PROBLEM LIKE TO SAID IT
WOULD BE REDIRECTION RESOURCE IS
WE WOULD PROVIDE ANY INFORMATION
THAT WE WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE.
THE OTHER WELL EXCUSE ME BUT THE
IMPLICATION WAS THAT THAT THAT
THE REDIRECTION OF RESOURCES
WOULD BE AT THE COUNTER.
IT WOULD BE WITH THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO WORK OUT A THE THE
THE THE SITUATION.
ON THE GROUND AND IN THE FIELD
OFFICES AND I'M SUGGESTING TO
YOU THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE THAT
INFORMATION IT SHOULD BE READILY
AVAILABLE AND HOW.
COMPLYING WITH REPORTS UPON HOW
YOU DO WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU DO
IT HOW MUCH IT COST WHAT IF THE
IMPEDIMENTS.
WHAT CAN WE DO?
AT A BETTER.
YOU SHOULD HAVE THAT AT YOUR
FINGERTIPS THIS MOMENT SO IS IT
I DID NOT SEE A VIEW
REDIRECTION.
WE WOULD NEVER REDIRECT THE THAT
OUR FRIEND BUT SERVING THE
EYEBROW SLIP WILK IT IS A
REDIRECTION OF RESOURCES
INTERNALLY AT HEADQUARTERS ARE
WORKING ON TO STILL BE BASICALLY
TALKING ABOUT YOUR YOUR
EXECUTIVES GOING HAVE DOUBLE THE
MORE WORK TO DO.
THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING NON NOT
SAYING THAT WE THEY ALL WORK
HARD IS JUST REDIRECTION THOSE
RESOURCES WERE WORKING ON THIS
AND THEN GO WORKING WITH ANY
MONEY THAT IS LOOKING.
AND AS AN AUDITOR [inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
MASON [inaudible]
POLITICAL.
YOU KNOW I I WILL SAY THIS ON ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT --
HAVING RUN A CITY DEPARTMENT
WHERE I WAS AUDITED --
FOUR YEARS IN A ROW BY FOUR
DIFFERENT AGENCIES --
WHERE INFORMATION IS REQUESTED
--
AUDITS TO TAKE TIME THEY'RE NOT
YOU HAVE --
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE FULLY
UNDERSTAND AND WHAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH AND I DO AGREE WITH
MR FONG THAT WE DO NEED. TO HAVE
A A A PLAN OUR WAY DOWN THE HALL
AND NOT WAIT TO GET TO MY
QUESTION A MINUTE LET NOT MISS
BAKER GO FIRST BUT ALL OF YOUR
HOUSE BUT IT WOULD ACHIEVING
MORE TIME AND I I PROMISE OUT
[inaudible]
AWARENESS.
IT IT IF YOU DO NOT HAVE WHAT
AMOUNTS [inaudible] TO BEFORE
YOU.
WHAT AMOUNTS?
TO YOUR OWN AUDIT [inaudible]
I THEN WHAT ARE YOUR EXECUTIVES.
RESPONSIBLE FOR IN OTHER WORDS
THIS SHOULD BE READILY OF THE
AND YOU SHOULD BE AUDITING.
YOURSELF AT AS A STANDARD
PROCEDURE.
ARE NOT ROOM SIX LARGEST CITY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
EIGHT YEARS RIGHT WE HAD
INTERNAL AUDITORS WE KNEW WHAT
WE WERE DOING BUT WHEN SOMEBODY
SAID SHOW US YOUR PAPERWORK.
WE HAD IT BECAUSE WE HAD
INTERNAL AUDITING.
DO YOU DO ANY INTERNAL AUDITING
AT ALL YES WE DO WE HAVE
INTERNAL AUDITORS THAT WE DO AYE
ON IT OUR PROCESSES BOTH --
HUMAN RESOURCES ACCOUNTING WE DO
ALL THAT THE REGISTRATION
POSSIBLY DO AUDIT THAT AND THEN
WHY IS THAT NOT REGULARLY
AVAILABLE REGULARLY UPDATED AND
CAN BE IMMEDIATELY TRANSFERRED
TO AN AUDITOR UPON REQUEST AT
THAT IS AVAILABLE UPON REQUEST
THANK YOU.
MISS BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM.
I MAY BE GOING BACK IN A FEW
POINTS TODAY I DIDN'T HAVE A
HAVE HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY YET TO
VISIT YOU THAT TWO TIMES FIRST
THING I WANT TO ASK IS.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU WERE
IN ONE OF THE MOST YOU
PERSONALLY WERE IN ONE OF THE
MOST IMPACTED OFFICES?
SO I'VE BEEN OUT OF VISITING A
BEEN TO REGION ONE WHICH IS THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OFFICES --
AND I'VE BEEN OUT TO REGION'S
SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT THOSE A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I WAS IN THE
MONTEBELLO OFFICE I WAS --
DEAF I WAS IN THE SAN MARCOS
OFFICE SO I HAD BEEN AT THOSE
OFFICES ARE DEBBIE DIRECTOR OF
THE OF FIELD OPERATIONS SHE HAS
BEEN OUT IN VISITING THOSE
OFFICE I HAVE A LIST OF THOSE
OFFICES.
OUT WE HAVE BEEN OUT VISITING
THOSE OFFICES AND WE HAVE BEEN
OUT TALKING TO OFFICE MANAGERS
GETTING THEIR FEEDBACK WHAT WE
DO -- THINGS
THAT --
JOINT WHAT THEY'RE HEARING SO
WHAT CAN WE DO TO IMPROVE THE
PROCESSES YES I HAVE BEEN OUT OF
OFFICE AS THE CAP THANK YOU THAT
IRAN WAS HUNKERED I WANNA CREEK.
I HAVE BEEN OUT TO THOSE OFFICES
THANK YOU A AYE AYE WAS INVALID
IT MORE IT WHEN.
WHEN WERE YOU LAST AT THOSE
OFFICES AND I HAVE TO GO BACK I
WAS THAT --
MONTEBELLO PROBABLY.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO --
BONTA CREEK --
WALNUT CREEK WAS LAST MONTH AND
CONCORD I WAS OUT THERE --
DEFTLY I WAS AT SAN MARCO'S
PALLID MONTH BEFORE I WAS AT
EUREKA WEAVERVILLE AND CRESCENT
CITY A LAST WEEK.
VISITING THOSE OFFICES WHEN OF
YOUR AT ONE AND WE ARE ALSO AT
THE END.
THANK YOU SORRY I'M SORRY WHEN
YOU WERE AT WALNUT CREEK FOR
EXAMPLE CAN YOU DESCRIBE TO US
WHAT YOU SAW HOW LONG YOU WERE
THERE WHAT YOU OBSERVED WHAT YOU
SAW WHAT YOU DID THERE.
A I DID OBSERVE --
OF CUSTOMERS WAITING OUTSIDE WE
DID WALK IN OF WE TALKED OF
OFFICE MANAGER.
AND AND SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT WE ASK ALL
OFFICES DEFAULT WE'RE NOT BEING
FOLLOWED.
AND THEY WERE NOT TOO YOUNG
LYING IN SO DEFINITELY WE FOLLOW
UP WE BRING EXTRACTING BACK OUT
TO TALK TO THEM AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR FOLLY BEST PRACTICES
AND YES I WAS DISAPPOINTED --
THAT -- AT
BEST BUY.
WHAT WERE THE BEST?
WE'RE NOT BEING FOLLOWED I HAVE
BEEN A PERSON OUTSIDE TRIAGE IN
LINE MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
AND I DID HAVE ALL THE RIGHT POT
PAPERWORK IF NOT.
GETTING THE CUSTOMERS IN AS FAST
AS THEY CAN OUT WE DID SEE THAT
CUSTOMER THERE WERE --
EMPTY CHAIRS IN THE LOBBY AND
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN GETTING
THOSE CUSTOMERS AND INSIDE THE
OFFICE AS QUICKLY AS THEY CAN
YET I DID OBSERVE THAT WE TALK
TO THE DEAD TO THE MANAGER IN
THAT THESE ARE THINGS I NEED TO
DO -- IS NOT
ACCEPTED FOR BECAUSE MISTER WAIT
OUTSIDE OUT IF THERE ARE YOU
KNOW THEY NEED TO GET THE
CUSTOMER ISN'T AS FAST AS THEY
CAN.
AND THE STRIKE TEAM YOU DEPLOY
IT SOUNDS VERY GOOD TO HAVE A
STRIKE TEAM BUT THAT WAS
STRAIGHT WHO WHO ARE THEY AND
WINNER THEY GOING TO BE DEPLOYED
TO GO CHECK F. THE FOLLOW UP IS
HAPPENED.
SO WE HAVE UP PET WHERE STAFF IN
FIELD OPERATIONS --
THEY HAVE ARE FORMALLY WORK IN A
FIELD OFFICE THEY I UNDERSTAND
AND KNOW HOW FEEL OFF ON OFFICE
OPERATES.
OF THEY WILL GET DEPLOYED AS
ANGLETON OFFICE OF A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AT LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
STRIKE TEAMS IN PLACE IN CENTRAL
VALLEY AND IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA THAT ARE COMING
OUT OF OUR REGIONAL OFFICES --
WHEN WE SEE THAT IN OFFICE IS
HAVING SOME PROBLEMS WE WILL
DEPLOY THEM --
AS SOON AS WE GET RID OF THAT.
I THINK U. S. REFERRAL BUT MORE
TO THE ONE THE CREEK OFFICE WHEN
HIS THAT STRIKE TEAM.
SET UP TO GO TO AN OFFICE LIKE
THAT WHERE YOU SAW BEST
PRACTICES NOT BEING FOLLOWED --
I ACTUALLY I WAS THAT WE WERE
THERE ARE MAKING PHONE CALLS AND
SAYING THAT --
A WE OBSERVING THIS BECAUSE AND
IMMEDIATELY YOU NEED TO BRING
SOMEBODY DOWN HERE TO TAKE A
LOOK AND AND REINFORCE --
THE BEST PRACTICES SO WE'RE ON
THE PHONE TALKING SAYING WE NEED
TO GET SOMEBODY OUT HERE
IMMEDIATELY AND I'VE BEEN OUT --
WHEN I HEARD COMPLAINTS
REGARDING AND ANOTHER OFFICE
CALL THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND
SAID YOU NEED TO GO OUT THERE
TOMORROW AND SHE WAS OUT THERE
OKAY?
I'M JUST I UNDERSTAND YOU CALLED
RIGHT AWAY DO YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE EXPECTED THE STRIKE TEAM
IS GOING TO GO AYE I GET THE
CALLS ACTED TO GO OUT THE NEXT
THE NEXT DAY OKAY --
I I WILL BE VERY HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU TO FIND OUT IF THE
STRIKE TEAM.
HAS GONE BACK TO ON THE CREEK UP
AS ONE OF THOSE LOCATIONS AND
THE REASON I'M ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS AND A FEW OTHERS THAT
I HAVE IS THAT YOUR DESCRIPTION
OF THE Q..
AND THE WAIT TIMES BEARS
[inaudible] ZERO RIP.
RELATION AT ALL TO REALITY BOTH
IN WALNUT CREEK AND EVERY OTHER
OFFICE.
IT WAS MENTIONED IN THAT THE
STOCK THAT YOU'RE GONNA GET FROM
ME IS GOING TO BE FOLKS WHO
WAITED FOR HOURS OUTSIDE.
BEFORE THEY GOT IN THE DOOR.
I'VE GOT SO MANY WHO WAITED
THREE HOURS TO GET A TICKET.
JUST TO GET A TICKET.
AND THEN THEY WAITED FIVE HOURS
AFTER THAT FOR THEIR TICKET TO
BE CALLED [inaudible]
AND THAT DOESN'T BEAR ANY
RELATION AT ALL TO THE FIVE
MINUTES TO CHECK I THINK HEARD
FIVE MINUTES TO CHECK IF
SOMEONE'S GOT THE REAL ID
PAPERS.
THAT ZERO RELATION.
SO IT IS I'M VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THE RESPONSES YOU GAVE TO MISTER
PATTERSON THE OTHER MEMBERS
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE Q. TIME IN
THE QUEUE SYSTEM IN THE
TECHNOLOGY FOR THAT.
HOT THAT YOU WE ARE LOOKING INTO
AUDIT VERY CAREFULLY AT HOW THAT
BEARS NO RELATION AT ALL TO WHAT
CONSTITUENTS ARE EXPERIENCING A
WHAT'S ON THE GROUND THERE'S NO
FIVE MINUTE WAIT TO HAVE YOUR
DOCUMENTS CHECKED.
NOW ALIVE IT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
HERE IS A ABOUT THE REAL ID.
SO LIVE IN YOUR INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS ABOUT AND THIS IS A BIG
PART OF THE ISSUE.
I'M THAT I WOULD LIKE YOU.
TO EXPLAIN FOR US PLEASE WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS
WHERE YOU THINK --
IT'S NOT REAL IDEA THERE'S OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT IT HAPPENED.
BECAUSE THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT
REAL IDEA I'D LIKE YOU TO ANSWER
TO SAY WHAT ELSE YOU THINK IS
CAUSING --
INSUFFICIENT AND ADEQUATE
SERVICE AT THE DMV.
SO WE ARE.
IN THE PROCESS WE HAVE WE WANT
TO CREATE EFFICIENCIES SO
ENTERED DURING THAT LED TRUCK
DRIVERS LICENSE APPLICATION FOR
LOUIS INTEGRATE THAT INTO A
DRIVERS LICENSE SYSTEM IN
SEPTEMBER.
THAT WILL CREATE EFFICIENCIES
WERE OUR TECHNICIAN DOES NOT
HAVE TAKE KEYED INFORMATION BY
NOW THEY KEY ON THAT END THAT
AGREED AND EFFICIENCY WILL MAKE
IT BETTER.
SO WE ARE OUT WORKING ON THAT.
WE HAVE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
--
ALSO I SAID THAT --
FOR THEY QUEUING SYSTEM WE ARE
GOING SO THAT YOU ALL KNOW THAT
WHEN YOU'RE COMING UP FOR YOUR
Q. TICKET THAT YOU CAN EITHER GO
AND IF YOU'RE CLOSE BY YOU CAN
GO GET.
SOMETHING TO DRINK OR COME BACK
THAT YOU'LL BE NOTIFIED SO THAT
YOU.
CAN GO OUT AND NOT AND THEN COME
BACK WHEN YOU NEED TO SO THAT
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON WE'RE DEATHLY WORKING
ON ADDITIONAL AND THE TRAINING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
WEDNESDAY MORNING TRAIN EVERY
EVERY WEEK.
HOW WE DO REFRESHER TRAINING IN
TERMS OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF FOR
THE REAL ID REFRESHER TRAINING
ON JUST PROCESS AND PROCEDURES
AND SO -- AS
WE GET AND YOU EMPLOYEES THEY
HAVE TO LEARN THE SYSTEM THAT
CAN YOU LEARN WHAT OUR PROCESSES
ARE -- AS
THEY GET MORE TIME ON THE JOB
THEY WILL GET PROFICIENT WERE
PROFICIENT AND WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROCESS MORE CUSTOMERS SO.
I THAT'S WHERE THERE ISN'T A
LEARNING CURVE GET OF SPEED
DEPOSITS ARE TRANSACTIONS BUT
WITH THE NEW EMPLOYEES AND
GETTING THEM --
TRAIN AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN AND
THEY GET MORE PROFICIENT AT THE
PROCESS THEY'RE GOING TO GET
MORE I'VE BE ABLE TO PROCESS
CUSTOMERS FASTER.
I WOULD AND I WOULD EXPECT THOSE
WELL ADJUSTED IT THERE ARE OTHER
AREAS WHERE --
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE REAL ID AND I
GUESS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AND
THAT IS THE CUP THE COMPLAINTS
THAT WE HEAR FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS AREN'T JUST ABOUT
WAITING IN THE SCORCHING HEAT
WAITING TO GET LINES IT'S THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE THEY RECEIVE
WHEN THEY ARRIVE.
AND IT'S THE WAY IN WHICH THEY
ARE TREATED --
IT IS SOMETIMES THE MOST COMMON
SENSE POINTS ABOUT YOU GOT A
ROOM FULL OF CHAIRS AND AIR
CONDITIONING AND YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PEOPLE
STANDING OUTSIDE.
YEAH AND SO WE ARE WORKING WITH
OUR OUR EMPLOYEES WE WANT TO GET
ALL THE CUSTOMERS WAIT OUTSIDE
AS I OBSERVE WHEN I WAS AT WANT
TO CREATE INSIDE THE OFFICE.
AND BE ABLE TO SIT DOWN IN AIR
CONDITIONED OFFICE GREATLY I
RECOGNIZE THAT AND WE ARE
WORKING TO GET THOSE CUSTOMERS
INSIDE AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
THANK YOU SOME OF THE OTHER
AREAS FOR THEIR COMPLAINTS
YOU'LL READ HERE AND I REALLY
STRONGLY RECOMMENDS THAT IF IT'S
A LOT.
OF READING AND THAT'S JUST PART
THAT YOU READ THESE TONIGHT
BEFORE THE HEARING TOMORROW CHEN
LACK.
A AND E'S BECAUSE YOU'LL SEE
THAT IT'S NOT TIME AT THE DMV
FOR MY REAL ID --
SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES THAT
ARE HAPPENING IS ERRORS THAT ARE
CAUSED BY THE DMV.
THAT CAUSES SOMEONE TO COME IN
MULTIPLE TIMES YOU'LL FIND
EXAMPLES IN AT LIKE YOU TO
ADDRESS THAT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
TO IDENTIFY THOSE --
AT WHERE PEOPLE ARE COMING IN
BECAUSE THEY WIN THEY WENT
THROUGH THE LONG PROCESS AND THE
VETERAN STICKER THAT THEIR
REQUEST IT WASN'T PUT ON THERE
OR THE DONOR STICKER WASN'T PUT
ON THERE.
OR THEY WERE NEVER SENT.
OF THEIR LICENSE SO THEY HAD TO
GO BACK.
AND START THE PROCESS ALL OVER
AGAIN AND THE EMPLOYEE SAID TO
THEM WILL THAT HAPPEN SOMETIME.
THE PLOT IN PLEASANTON
CALIFORNIA THAT HAPPENED
SOMETIME --
SO IT'S THE LEVEL OF SERVICE
THAT CONSTITUENTS RECEIVING NOT
JUST HOW LONG THEY ARE WAITING
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO GET A REAL
IMPRESSION OF THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE PROBLEMS AND FIXING
THAT.
THAT ISN'T HAS TO DO WITH THE
CUE SYSTEM OR OTHERWISE.
SO WE ARE IN NIGHT I AM MEETING
WITH OFFICE MANAGERS --
TO LEARN FROM THEM WHAT THEIR
CHALLENGES ARE AND WHAT DO WE
NEED TO DO TO IMPROVE THAT AND
AGAIN THE COMMENTS THAT YOU HAVE
YOUR A LOOK THROUGH THOSE AND
COME UP WITH SOME SUGGESTIONS
HOW WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THEM
BUT I WOULD IF WE WILL LOOK AT
THEM.
TONIGHT AND BE READY TO RESPOND
TO THOSE THANK YOU AT ANOTHER
AREA IS AND I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT FOLKS WHO THEY'RE STILL
GONNA BE LONG LINES THAT WE HEAR
--
I'VE REPEATED.
STORIES OF ELDERLY.
WHO ARE REQUIRED AFTER AGE
SEVENTY TO GO INTO THE DMV WHO
ARE STANDING IN LINE? FOR HOURS
ONE OF THEM IS FROM A WOMAN WHO
FELT SHE FAINTED WHILE SHE WAS
WAITING IN LINE.
AND SHE WAS TOLD BY THE STAFF
THAT IF SHE WERE TO LEAVE
EMERGENCY CREWS CAME.
IF SHE WERE TO LEAVE TO BE
TREATED SHOULD HAVE TO COME BACK
TO THE DMV ANOTHER DAY.
AND SO SHE INSISTED THAT THE
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL TREAT HER
THERE SO SHE COULD STAND LINE --
MULTIPLE A OF ADDITIONAL STORIES
OF A A FAMILY WHO SAW GENTLEMAN
ELDERLY JOHN IN THE CORNER
LOOKING CONFUSED AND ON THE
VERGE OF TEARS AND HE SAID I'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR HOURS THEY TOLD
ME TO JUST WAIT RIGHT HERE THEY
WOULD COME GET ME.
AND NO ONE IS HELPING HIM GET
INTO A LINE NO ONE IS TRYING TO
HELP THEM SO AND THERE ARE NO
CHAIRS FOR PEOPLE SO IN THE MOST
IMMEDIATE TERM I'M ACTUALLY
CONCERNED AS MISTER GIPSON WAS
IN A DIFFERENT ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIANS WERE SITTING AND
WAITING.
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS FOR
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE WHICH YOU
SAW CLEARLY ALL THAT CREEK? TOO
BIG AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR THEM WHAT CAN
WE DO TO HELP YOU ADDRESS THAT
AS WELL.
SO WE ARE FOCUSING ON MANY
FRONTS AND ONE IS DEATHLY GET
THE THE CUSTOMERS INSIDE AND SO
WHEN YOU I DID SEE AND WANT TO
CREATE THE LINE.
OUT WE ARE GETTING REPORTS EVERY
HOUR ON THE HOUR HOW MANY COOPER
WAY IN LINE AND OR FOR SEEN YOU
NEED TO GET YOU NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PERSON CHALLENGING
IS ADDRESSING THAT.
AND THEY ARE --
WE ARE SAYING THERE AT RIGHT
QUICKLY BECAUSE AGAIN WE
UNDERSTAND THEY CANNOT STAND
OUTSIDE VERY LONG IN THE HEAT.
SO CANADIAN WORKERS ARC OF WITH
OUR EMPLOYEES TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE BEST PRACTICES ARE AND THESE
ARE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
NEED TO DO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT TRAINING.
AND UNDERSTAND IF LIKE I SAID IF
I NEED TO GET A STRIKE TEAM OUT
THERE TOO OUT WORK THAT OFFICE
TO ADDRESS THOSE THINGS WE WILL
DO THAT THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THAT --
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OTHER ENTITIES LIKE AYE AUTO
CLUB'S.
I'M ONE OF THEIR CONCERNS A
CONSTITUENT HAS IS THEY WERE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH AN ISSUE BY
JUST PAIN FIFTY BUCKS TO JOIN AN
AUTO CLUB WHAT ABOUT THE
CONSTITUENTS WHO DON'T HAVE
THAT.
IT ARE YOU SITTING UP
RELATIONSHIPS AND LOOKING AT I
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS THAT DON'T
REQUIRE BECOMING A MEMBER OF AN
AUTO CLUB.
BUT REQUIRED AT ALLOW THE
ABILITY OF YOU TO GET SERVICE
SOMEWHERE ELSE SIMILAR TO HOW I
GO TO A POSTAL ANNEX AND SHIP MY
PACKAGE THERE INSTEAD OF WAITING
IN LINE AT THE POST OFFICE.
SO WE HAVE OUR SELF SERVICE
TERMINALS THOSE A WE DON'T KNOW
IT AT WORK BECAUSE WE CAN GO IF
YOU HAVE A SIMPLE VIC REDUNDANT
VEHICLE REGISTRATION WE KNOW ALL
YOU CAN DO THAT.
THERE AND I'VE IT LOCATED AND
SIXTY OUR FIELD OFFICES UP
CURRENTLY IN FORTY RETAIL
LOCATIONS WERE GRINNING BURKE
STANDING THAT.
AND THAT'S IN TERMS OF WHERE --
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY THAT WE
HAVE SOARED THAT COST RIGHT NOW
AND SO WE ARE LOOKING TO EXPAND
THAT PROGRAM.
AND WE WOULD HAVE TO LOOK AND
SEE IF THERE'S OTHER PARTNERS
THAT WE COULD LOOK TO IN TERMS
OF WHERE WE CAN OFFER SUMMIT AT
NINE AND I IT WE WOULD WELCOME
ANY SUGGESTIONS THAT IF YOU KNOW
OF ANYBODY.
THAT COULD OFFER THAT SERVICE
I'M OR COUPLE A AN ABOUT TURN
FINALLY TO THE AREA WHERE YOU DO
IT.
VERY HONESTLY WELCOME
SUGGESTIONS SO I APPRECIATE
THAT.
I HEARD MY THINGS YOU MENTION IN
YOUR TESTIMONY IS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE LIKE A RELY DE
AREA AND THEN.
MAYBE OF A DIFFERENT LINE OR A
DIFFERENT Q. FOR THINGS THAT CAN
BE MUCH FASTER TO GET WHETHER
IT'S A DISABLED PLACARD OR AT
TEMPORARY DISABLED PLACARD OR
AGAIN VETERAN STICKER SOME OF
THE OTHER POINTS THAT HAPPENED.
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE FOR MAKING
THIS DISTINCTION HAVE QUICK?
EASY I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT
SEVEN HOURS IN LINE FOR TWO
MINUTES OF SERVICE --
THAT IS HAPPENING NOW THAT THAT
THAT INSTRUCTIONS ALREADY WENT
OUT AND THAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING
IN REAL TIME TODAY.
WHERE CUSTOMERS TO HAVE A QUICK
TRANSACTION ARE PULLED OUT AND
SET TO THAT EXPEDITE WIND UP CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THE MORE HAVE HOW
THAT'S WHEN YOU SAY IT'S
HAPPENING TODAY?
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A DMV PERSON
GO TO A PERSON AND WHAT IS YOUR
THE DMV IS THAT ARE.
YOU ARE JUST HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE
GETTING A GROUP TOGETHER SEVERAL
PLACARD I DO YOU NEED TO YOUR
PICKING UP YOUR YOUR SPECIALTY
LICENSE PLATE --
YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE YOU NEED TO
GET YOUR VEHICLE RECORD OR
IDENTIFYING THE TYPE OF SERVICE
THAT THEY NEED AND WE CAN
IDENTIFY ONES ARE A QUICK EASY
TRANSACTION THEY'RE BEING SENT
TO THE EXPEDITE WINDOW.
DOT PART THAT TRIAGE PROCESS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER YES
--
MIGHT MY HOPE IS THAT WHAT YOUR
DESCRIPTION IS OF IT WILL BEAR
MUCH MORE --
THAT IS ARE IN RELATION TO THE
WENT REALLY ENDS UP HAPPENING ON
THE GROUND THAT YOU ONLY FIND
OUT IF YOU'RE OUT IN ABOUT A
POTENTIALLY.
WITH THE AUDIT --
BECAUSE THAT IS NOT WHAT PEOPLE
ARE EXPERIENCING.
I WHAT WHAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE FIVE MINUTE
YOU KNOW CHECK TO SEE IF YOU
HAVE THE REAL IDEA THERE'S
TESTIMONY AS WE HEAR FROM FOLKS
WHO WERE ASKED SEVEN TIMES.
SEVEN DIFFERENT DMV EMPLOYEES
WENT TO CHECK IF THE HAVE ALL
THE REAL ID DOCUMENTS THEY
NEEDED.
I'M SO ON THE SUGGESTIONS LIST
IS TO MAKE SURE IF SOMEONE'S
DOING THAT YOU'RE BEING
EFFICIENT ABOUT IT IT'S ONE
PERSON IS CHECKING YOUR DOING IT
EARLY IN THE LINE.
YOU'RE GETTING IT RESOLVED AND
NOT MULTIPLE.
CHECKS AND MULTIPLE EFFORTS TO
DO THIS BECAUSE THE DUPLICATION
OF EFFORT ON THAT IS IS AN ISSUE
CYPRESS SHAPE THE TRIAGE AND THE
DESCRIPTION OF IS VERY GOOD BUT
WHAT.
WE'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND IS
SEVEN PEOPLE ASKING THE SAME
QUESTION OF SOMEONE AS ARE GOING
THROUGH THEIR SEVEN HOUR WAIT.
IDEALLY I DID HEAR THAT FOR AND
SO WHAT WE DID IS THAT THEY ARE
GIVING A A A CARD THAT SAYS YOU
HAVE BEEN CHECKED YOU HAVE YOUR
REQUIRED DOCUMENTS YOU KNOW YOU
NEED TO DO IS GO STRAIGHT THOUGH
WHEN YOU GET TO THE START YUBA
YOU'LL BE ISSUE.
YOUR SERVICE TICKET SO WE DID
HEAR THAT RIGHT AND THAT'S WHERE
PEOPLE ARE BEING CHECKED
MULTIPLE TIMES AND THEY HAVE THE
SAME DOCUMENTS A SO THE SPEED UP
THE PROCESS IS.
YOU BEEN LOOKED AT YOU HAVE THE
CARD IT'S IDENTIFIED YOU HAVE
ALL YOUR DOCUMENTS AND THEN JUST
ISSUED A TICKET TO SPEED THINGS
UP.
AND AND THE AYE ON THE
SUGGESTION LESS AND I'D LIKE TO
KNOW IF YOU'VE TRIED THIS
ALREADY AND AND IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULDN'T TAKE
VERY MUCH DOLLARS FROM.
A BUDGET TO DO.
I WE TALKED ABOUT HOW THE Q.
TIMES AT THAT WERE SEEN ON THE
GROUND ARE TOTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT YOU'RE REPORTING ON
YOUR WEBSITE YOU READ THE
TESTIMONIALS OF FOLKS WHO ARE IN
LINE FOR THEIR FIFTH HOUR.
AND IT SAYS USE ONLY ONE HOUR
WAIT HERE AND PLEASANT OFFICE.
ONE OF THE AREAS IS ALSO HOW
LONG ONCE THEY GET IN LINE AT
DISNEYLAND FIGURE THIS OUT A
LONG TIME AGO.
AT THIS POINT IN THE LINE YOU'RE
GOING TO WAIT THIS LONG.
JUST LIKE YOU GOING TO AN APPLE
STORE RIGHT NOW AND THEY ARE
TRIAGE IN PEOPLE AND THEY ARE
DOING THE TAXED AND CALLING YOU
SEE THAT YOU CAN GO BACK TO WORK
INTO WHATEVER IT IS.
WHAT ARE YOU?
I'VE YOU ALREADY LOOKED AT THOSE
EFFORTS ANY MENTION THE TEXT ONE
BUT THAT HERE'S HOW LONG IT IS
GOING TO TAKE YOU TO BE IN LINE
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN.
A ASSESS WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
SO AS A AS I MENTIONED BEFORE WE
ARE WE ARE --
EVERY HOUR ON THE HOUR I
IDENTIFYING HOW LONG PEOPLE ARE
WAITING --
IT SO THAT WE ARE GIVE VERY
GIVING A A DOCUMENT WHICH THEY
WILL YOU PLEASE MARK WHAT TIME
THEY'RE AT AND THEN WHEN THEY
GET TO THE STAR HE WINDOW THAT
IS OF REPORTED TIME HOW LONG THE
WAIT IS OUTSIDE.
OF WE'RE WORKING TO TRY TO
DETERMINE HOW WE CAN POST THAT
OUR WEBSITE SO GIVES AS A SEVERE
PATTERSON MENTIONED WE ONLY
REPORT WHAT HOW LONG IT TAKES TO
PROCESS THE TRUTH.
GET TO THE SERVICE WINDOW WE DO
WANT TO REPORT HOW LONG IT TAKES
FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO GET TO THE
STAR HERE WINDOW AND HOW LONG
THAT THAT WAIT TIME ISN'T MINE.
DEADLY DEADLY AT DISNEYLAND HAS
TO DO THAT THEY GIVE YOU.
CHAIRMAN HALL ON YOUR WEIGHT IS
AND US SO WE ARE WORKING ON
THAT.
OKAY AND FINALLY ON THE COMPUTER
OUTAGES BECAUSE THIS IS DATA
THAT I AGREE WITH --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON THESE
ARE ACTUALLY ANSWERS THAT
SOMEONE AT THE TABLE SHOULD HAVE
ANSWERS.
TO AB ONE OF THE TESTIMONIALS
YOU HAVEN'T HERE'S HOW SOMEONE
FOR TWO DAYS TRIED TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT ONLINE.
BUT THEY COULDN'T BECAUSE FOR
TWO DAYS.
THERE WAS AN OUTAGE SO THEY
CALLED THE DMV AND AFTER WAITING
ON THE PHONE FOR ONE POINT FIVE
HOURS THEY GOT A LIVE PERSON HE
SAID TO COME INTO THIS LOCATION
HERE'S ANY MAJOR APPOINTMENT.
THE STORY WILL CONTINUE HOW IT
TOOK THEM THREE HOURS TO GET.
A TICKET FIVE HOURS ONCE THEY
GOT A TICKET AND SO ON BUT THE
OUTAGES OUR EXTENSIVE FROM WHAT.
AYE AM HEARING FROM CONSTITUENTS
AND WE WOULD EXPECT YOU AS WHERE
THE BUCK STOPS TO KNOW.
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH THOSE?
AS WELL AS WHAT IS THE REAL TIME
CUE AYE WEIGHTS AND HOW THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING.
BECAUSE WHAT WHAT THIS WILL TELL
YOU IS IT'S THEIR SUBSTANTIAL
OUTAGES OUTAGES AND THEY'RE
HAPPENING FREQUENTLY AND IT'S
COMPLETELY SHUTTING DOWN THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO SELF HELP.
A MUCH MORE.
THANK YOU I LOOK FOR DISNEY WITH
YOU TOMORROW.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
YES THIS IS MEANT QUITE AN
INTERESTING --
DISCUSSION IN CONVERSATION HERE
--
AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES OF YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE INTERESTING
THINGS I FACES AS I LISTEN TO
EVERYONE I GUESS I'M I'M
PROBABLY ELATED.
THAT MY OTHER COLLEAGUES ARE
HAVING SUCH POOR SERVICE.
UP BECAUSE THE MOST POOR
COMMUNITIES AWAITS HAVE BEEN
FOUR AND FIVE HOURS AT THE DMV.
UP I'VE SELDOM GOING TO THE DMV
BUT THE LAST TIME I WAS IN WHICH
IS ABOUT FIVE SIX OUT YEARS AGO
US FOR FIVE SIX HOURS IT TOOK
ME.
ABOUT FIVE HOURS TO GET
SOMETHING SIMPLE DONE SO IT
IMPORT COMMUNITIES WITHOUT AND
KNOW THAT AND IN FACT --
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT MOST OF
US SELDOM GO TO OUR DMV AND I GO
TO THE ONE IN OF LET MYSELF OR
HER SOMEWHERE IN POWER WAY.
WHERE I KNOW THAT THE SERVICE IS
BETTER AND THE CUSTOMER SERVICE
IS BETTER AND FASTER SO THE FACT
THAT WE'RE ALL NOW EXPERIENCING
THE PAIN IS GOOD BECAUSE THEN
WILL GET SOMETHING DONE?
ABOUT DMV BECAUSE BEEN ONE OF
THE AGENCY OF NIGHTMARE AND MOST
COMMUNITIES THAT POOR.
OF EITHER BECAUSE OF THE LONG
NOT ONLY THE LONG LINES BUT
OFTENTIMES WHAT APPEARS TO BE
THE POOR SERVICE.
IN TERMS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK
THERE AND I THINK THAT HAS TO BE
SOME WORK DONE ON THAT IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE'S PERSPECTIVE AN
ATTITUDE.
OF OFTENTIMES PEOPLE WHO COME
INFILL LIKE BR BOTHER TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK THERE AND
IN FACT THE LAST TIME I WAS IN
SOMEONE SAID --
I THINK YOU CALLED THE FOURTH
THAT TIME FOUR THIRTY FIVE
O'CLOCK THEY SIT WAITED THIRTY
MINUTES BEFORE AND YOU'LL SEE
WILL ASK THAT WILL NEVER GET OUT
OF HERE BECAUSE HE DIED WHEN IN
AT NOON AND IT WAS ALMOST FIVE
INNOCENT WILL NEVER GET OUT
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH.
TIME TO WAIT ON ALL OF US AND
THEY SAID WATCH AND SEE THIRTY
MINUTES BEFORE THE TIME WAS OVER
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE APPEARED
FROM SOMEWHERE OUT OF THE OTHER
ROOMS WHO WOULD DOING WHATEVER.
AND THEY ALL CAME IN AND SURE
ENOUGH WE ALL GOT OUT IN TIME
FOR BY THE GET OFF WORK ON TIME.
SO I BEFRUGAL AS THE IF WE
PROBABLY COULD HAVE BEEN OUT
EARLIER YEAR UP HOURS EARLIER IF
EVERYONE HAD BEEN BASICALLY ARE
MOST OF THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
CUSTOMER SERVICE.
SO I THINK THAT THE ISSUE IS IS
AS MOST FOLKS ARE FEELING THE
FRUSTRATION BECAUSE THIS IS THE
ONE AGENCY THAT PROBABLY EVERY
CALIFORNIAN TOUCHES.
THE ONE AGENCY ALL OF US DON'T
NECESSARILY DEAL WITH WEB
WELFARE AND OTHER SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES BUT WE OUGHT NOT HAVE
TO HAVE SOME FORM OF ID.
AND THAT COMES FROM THE ENVY
WHATEVER IT IS WE ALL HAVE TO GO
THERE SO I I NOT ELATED THE
TROLL IN PAIN WITH ME BUT
OBVIOUSLY IT IT GIVES ME GREAT
COMFORT TO KNOW THAT.
AS A RESULT OF ALL THE COMMUNITY
SCREAMING THAT SOMETHING WILL
HAPPEN ALSO IN SOME POOR
COMMUNITIES TO IMPROVE SERVICE
AND TO GET THOSE INDIVIDUALS OUT
FASTER BECAUSE THE ATTITUDE WAS
ALMOST AS IF.
WHAT YOU FOLKS HAVE NOWHERE TO
GO ANYWAY BECAUSE YOU'RE ALL
POOR SO YOU YOU CAN AFFORD TO
SIT AROUND DMB FOR FIVE AND SIX
HOURS TO GET AN ID CARD OR
WHATEVER IT MAY BE?
WHAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW FROM YOU
THOUGH IS THAT?
UP HOW LONG IS IT GOING TO TAKE
FOR US TO GET SOME SEE SOME
PROGRESS BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN
LOVE MEANT ALL DAY LONG AS WE
SIT HERE AND ASK YOU QUESTIONS
AND AND YOU'RE AWARE OF IT AND
IT'S A HUGE AGENCY.
CALLED THAT HAS LOTS OF
EMPLOYEES WE HAVE GIVEN YOU MORE
RESPOND ABILITIES AS WE GIVEN AT
AND NOW YOU'VE GOT OTHER THINGS
IN A BIT AT AT THE REGISTRATION
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO VOTE IN YOU.
SO WE WEWE PUT A LOT OF THINGS
ON THE MP I RECOGNIZE THAT AND
AND I THINK SOMETIMES WE DO THAT
WITHOUT THINKING THAT THAT
REALLY TAKES AWAY FROM.
THE OTHER TAX WHICH IS USED TO
BE JUST GIVING OUT A DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND THEN WITH THE ID'S
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO BUDGET
VOTER REGISTRATION AND NOW WE
DEAL WITH TELL.
THOSE WHO ARE NOT CITIZENS
GETTING LICENSES SO THAT THE
AGENCY AS WELL OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE A TIMELINE WHEN WE
CAN SAY WHO THIS IS GOING TO BE
OKAY.
THE DO YOU KNOW WHEN OF FOLKS
WILL PROBABLY BE FEELING THAT IT
IS REASONABLE AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT REASONABLE IS IS REASONABLE
AN HOUR DMB.
IT I'M IS THAT A REASONABLE TIME
FRAME TO PEOPLE TO SAY WHAT I'M
GOING TO SPEND OUR GOOD ON THE
DMV GET MY LICENSE RENEW TO GET
WHATEVER DONE.
AND TEND TO MY BUSINESS THAT I
HAVE THAT'S NOT COMPLICATED
BUSINESS BUT JUST BASIC
BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHEN WE WILL
SEE THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT
BECOMES IMPORTANT FOR US TO TALK
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH YOU SAY WHAT WE WANT
MORE.
COMPUTERS ALL WE WANT MORE THIS
WOMAN WHAT WAS THAT THAT'S FINE
AND AND AND AND WE MAY BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT FOR YOU PROBABLY
WILL MORE THAN LIKELY IF THIS
STUFF IS FORTY YEARS OLD WE WILL
PROBABLY HAVE TO DO THAT.
BUT FOR THE AVERAGE CITIZEN WAS
WALKING UP AND DOWN THE STREET
THEY WON'T BE DANCING IN THE
STREET BECAUSE YOU GOT NEW
COMPUTERS.
THEY WILL BE DANCING IN THE
STREETS BECAUSE THEY SPEND OUR
INDIAN MOVIE THIS.
IS JUST THAT SIMPLE HOWEVER WE
DID IT THERE WILL BE DANCE IN
THE STREETS FOR THAT REASON.
SO THE QUESTION BECOMES WHAT THE
TIMELINE.
ALL DAY LONG BUT WHAT IS THE
TIMELINE WHEN WE WHEN DO YOU
THINK IS GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE
YOU HAVE SOME GREAT IDEAS THE
FACT THAT YOU CAN TEXT ME AND
TELL ME I'LL BE.
THAT MY NUMBER WILL PROBABLY
COME UP IN THIRTY MINUTES IS
GREAT BECAUSE THEN I CAN COME
BACK TO THE NBA AND DO THAT.
BUT WHEN IS THIS STUFF GOING TO
BE IN PLACE OF THE WE CAN BEGIN
TO SEE SOME REDUCTION IN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THE POPE'S
AWAITING BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
WHAT ADVICE TALKING ABOUT.
WITH ALL THE OTHER STUFF THE
TIME HOW LONG IT TAKES TO GET
THEIR BUSINESS DONE.
WHEN WE SPEAK GET TO SEE THE
REDUCTION IN IN IN AND INTO AND
WAIT TIME?
AND SO THAT WE CAN BEEN TALK
ABOUT HOLDING FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR WHATEVER'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY HOW WE
GOING TO SEE THE WAY WHEN WE GOT
TO SEE THAT DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
AT ALL SO WITH THE THINGS THAT I
HAD A DAY TALKED ABOUT SO WITH
THE INTEGRATION OF THE
APPLICATION INTO DRIVE LIKE
SYSTEM THAT'LL.
OCCUR MILTON THAT SEPTEMBER SO
WE HOPE TO SEE THAT EFFECT AND
SEEN THE REDUCTION IN THE WAIT
TIMES WHERE --
OUR OUR TECHNICIANS CHECKING
THEM FOR NOT HAVING TO KEEP THAT
INFORMATION SO FROM --
MILLICENT WE ARE JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO REDUCE THE
TIME BETWEEN NOW AND MIL
SEPTEMBER.
FAMILAR SEPTEMBER ONTO THE END
OF THE YEAR OUT WE WE ARE GOAL
IS TO DO JUST THAT WAIT TIME AND
SO WE WANT TO GET BACK TO THE
LEVELS THAT WE WERE BEFORE WHICH
IS -- A
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR AN
APPOINTMENT CUSTOMER AND AROUND
UP FORTY FIVE MINUTES FOR A NON
APPOINTMENT CUSTOMERS THAT ALL
THAT IS OUR GOAL SO SO BEGINNING
FROM SEPTEMBER OF TO DECEMBER WE
SHOULD STOP SLEEVES BEGAN TO SEE
THE DECLINE.
IN THE WAITING TIME YES THAT
THAT IS OUR INTENT SO BETWEEN
NOW IN THE MIDDLE SEPTEMBER
YOU'RE GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTING
THESE THINGS THAT WILL HELP US
BEGIN TO SEE THE REDUCTION HOME
AFTER RENEW MY LICENSE ON THE
TWENTIETH OF SEPTEMBER SO THAT'S
FINE THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
AND I GOT THE NOTICE LIKE THE
OTHER DAY AND I REALIZE OKAY I
GOT TO DEAL WITH THIS MADNESS
AND GET AN APPOINTMENT TO DO
SOMETHING SO I DON'T WANT TO BE.
I DON'T BE THE FACE OF THE M. V.
BOB SO YOU'RE SAYING BY THE
MIDDLE SEPTEMBER MOVING FORWARD.
WE SHOULD BE SEEING A REDUCTION
AND WAIT TIME YES BECAUSE WE ARE
IN OUR GOAL IS TO GET DOWN TO
THE FIFTEEN MINUTES AND THE
FORTY FIVE MINUTES BY DECEMBER.
THAT THAT IS OUR OUR GOAL AND WE
ALL WORK HARD TO GET TO THAT NOT
BUT AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO BALANCE BETWEEN YOUR
CUSTOMERS YOU KNOW IF WE SEE.
A MORE CUSTOMERS COMING AND THEN
YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE THEY NEED
IN ORDER WE HAVE TO REDIRECT
RESOURCES THE AND SO A WE ARE
WORKING VERY HIGH.
AND TO TO ACHIEVE THAT HAVE YOU
EMPLOYED OR ARE YOU GOING TO
EMPLOY SOME OF YOUR RETIRED
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THE SYSTEM.
YES WE HAVE MADE THAT CALL OUT
AND WE ALREADY HAVE SOME OF
RETIRED IN NEWTON AND PLAYS WE
TRY AND NOTICED THEM AND SAID
THEY WOULD COME BACK AND WORK
FOR US.
OKAY BECAUSE I MEAN THAT WOULD
BE ALSO EQUALLY IMPORTANT IF
THEY IF YOU HAVE A CUT SCHOOLS
DO THIS ALL THE TIME NOW.
UP MAY BE BECAUSE THE KNOWLEDGE
IS THE AT THE SKILL IS THE AND
YOU NOT ALWAYS EVEN IF YOU
TRAINING FOLKS YOU STILL NEED
EXPERIENCED PEOPLE TO BE TO STEP
IN YOU BET. TO THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT YOU NEED TO TRAIN IN
YOU STILL NEED SOME EXPERIENCE
PEOPLE BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING
WORSE IN BETWEEN IN LIFE EIGHT
HOURS AND THEN GET SOMEBODY
BRAND NEW LESLIE BEHEST OF TO
IDENTIFY AS TOM EVERYTHING THE
DO YOU KNOW YOU DON'T WANNA DO
THAT.
WE HAVE ASKS OF PEOPLE EVERY
TYPE THEIR INTEREST IN COMING
BACK SO WE'VE ALREADY MADE THAT
CALL OUT OKAY WE ONLY HAVE HAVE
DONE SOME INTEREST OKAY GREAT
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
HAPPENS THANK YOU.
THICKNESS SCORE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU YOURSELF AND CHEN FRAZIER
FOR HOSTING THIS ARM.
AFTER BEING HOME FOR A MONTH.
I GOT A VERY CLEAR OF PICTURE
FOR MY CONSTITUENTS THAT THIS IS
A GOOD TOPIC OF THEM ON TOP OF
MY CONCERN.
ADDS ONE OF WHICH MY COLLEAGUE
LACK WHEN SHE GOT HOME IN LATE
DECEMBER MY SUSPICION.
BUT A BIG OF A CREW CAMERAS
FOLLOWING.
HIM HE CAN STRAIGHT BECAUSE I I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE DR WEBER
YOU KNOW WE HAVE LONG UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE HILLCREST DMV AND MY
SIMPLY DISTRICT IS GOING TO HAVE
A LONG LINE.
YOU'RE GONNA BE THERE VERY LONG
TIME YOU GONNA STAND IN THE SUN
IT'S NOT GONNA BE A PLEASANT
EXPERIENCE AND SO I HAVE TO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE START
RAISING THIS ISSUE WITH ME.
I THOUGHT IT WAS MORE OF THE
SAME BUT OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING IS
EXTREMELY DIFFERENT AND THERE
ARE REAL EQUITY ISSUES THAT ARE
IN THERE THAT EVEN WHEN --
THAT WAIT TIMES COME DOWN I HOPE
WE DO TALK ABOUT OF THESE
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE LONG
EXPERIENCE THIS I DID NOT GET MY
DRIVER'S LICENSE IN MY OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD COMMUNITY BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT'S NOT WHERE YOU WENT
RIGHT YOU WENT SOMEWHERE OUTSIDE
SO SHE BRINGS UP SOMETHING THAT
IS.
ALMOST UNRELATED TO TODAY'S
CONVERSATION BUT VERY MUCH
RELATED AND I AND I HOPE YOU
TOOK THAT TO HEART --
AND DIRECTOR OF I WOULD SAY YOU
KNOW I LIKE TO TELL MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO DON'T KNOW WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE ARMED AND
THE CUSTOMER SERVICE DEPARTMENT
FOR THE STATE AND SO I'M GLAD
THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY.
ON BECAUSE I NEED TO VOCALIZE ON
THEIR BEHALF WHAT THEY HAVE
SHARED --
THESE ARE MILD MANNERED PEOPLE
ARE WHO I COME ACROSS IN MY DAY
WHO ARE NOT HAPPY CAMPERS --
AND THEY VERY MUCH EXPECT EXPECT
ME TO EXPRESS THAT TO TODAY I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES OF COVERED
THAT WELL.
ON BUT THEN HE BECOMES AFTER
THAT EXPRESSION IS THEY AREN'T
AYE FOR THINGS LIKE MISSOURI
HELL ON EARTH I'M ALL THE KINDS
OF DESCRIPTIONS WHICH AGAIN I
THINK ARE OFTEN TRITE STATEMENTS
ABOUT THE DMV IT'S IT'S YOU KNOW
PEOPLE COMMONLY TO SAY THAT
ABOUT THE M. BEAT ME NEVER.
GET CREDIT FOR COMING IN AND OUT
UNLESS A FEW MINUTES I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT A BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS DIFFERENT AND
I THINK THIS HEARING ILLUSTRATES
THAT POINT TO YOU --
BUT I THINK THE CONSTITUENTS
THAT IT ATTEMPT TO MEET IT STUCK
IN MY MIND THE MOST IS A HE SAT
--
WILL WEAKEN APPOINTMENT FOR OVER
FIVE HOURS IN THE HILLCREST DMV
ON IT IS OBSERVATION HAS A LONG
HISTORY IN BUSINESS IN THE BIT
PRIVATE SECTOR.
IF THIS WAS A BUSINESS IT WOULD
BE OUT OF BUSINESS WE HAVE
SERVICE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS --
SO I GUESS THE QUESTION THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT REAL IDEAS A
DRIVER BEHIND THIS.
AND I HEARD SOME DESCRIPTIONS
ABOUT WHY PROPS THE PLANNING DID
MIND OF EXACTLY WITH EXPERIENCE
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO ME.
ON IS THERE ANY STATE IS DOING
THIS CORRECTLY MEAN EVERYONE IS
UNDER THIS OBLIGATION HEAVY TALK
TO YOUR COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
STATES.
BY THE EXPERIENCE IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE HERE ARE THERE
OTHERS THAT ARE GETTING IT RIGHT
AND WHAT ARE THEY DOING SHOULD
WE DO THAT HERE I GO THERE ARE
SOME STATES ARE EXPERIENCE SOME
OF THIS --
SAME -- NEW
MEXICO IS ONE THAT IMPLEMENTED
AND NEW YORK IT'S IMPLEMENTED
AND SOME OF THE STATES AND WE
HAVE OUT TALK TO THOSE STATES IN
AND ASKED FOR THEIR IN SHARING
THEIR THE BEST PRACTICES IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY'RE
IMPLEMENTING SO WE DO.
I HAVE THAT BUT DATA AND THE
STATE OF THE STATES ARE NOT AS
BIG AS CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
LARGEST POPULATION AND SO WE
HAVE THE MOST CHALLENGE IN TERMS
OF SERVING.
UP OUR CITIZENS A LOT OF STATES
HAVE A LOT SMALLER POPULATION
AND IT WOULD NOT GET THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
UNDERSTOOD.
ARM AT THE SAME TIME IF THEY
WEREN'T HAVING IF THERE WERE NO
OTHER STATE TO THIS PROBLEM
YOU'D UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE OF
A BAD DAY FOR YOU GOT A LOT
WORSE RIGHT.
NOW BUT YOU'RE SAYING THAT OTHER
STATES ARE EXPERIENCING THIS IS
WHAT SOME OF THE STATES ARE SOME
STATES HAVE NOT IMPLEMENTED YET.
AND IN SO AND YOU KNOW WE DEFTLY
HAVE CONTACT OTHER STATES IN
TERMS OF BEST PRACTICES THAT
THEY'RE USING IF WE CAN.
COPY THOSE OUT WE WILL AND
ADDITIONAL.
WORK MAY I SEE THE MONEY THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN EXPENDED UNDER THE
BUDGET THE ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION
MORE POSITIONS THAT YOU MENTION
TODAY THAT COULD BE HELPFUL IN
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM.
THAT'S REAL MONEY.
A WE GET ANYTHING FROM THE FEDS
TO THOSE AND KNOW WHERE NOT DIED
THEY HAD SOME GRANTS AVAILABLE
--
YEARS BACK WE DID I'D.
MAKE YOURSELF AVAILABLE OF THOSE
GRANTS AND WE HAD DONE SOME
THINGS TO IMPROVE OUR PROCESSES
IN ANTICIPATION OF GETTING READY
FOR ID AND THAT WAS PRIOR TO
THAT -- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE THE
REGULATIONS IN PLACE IN SO
STATES HAD APPLIED FOR A WEEK
AND I CAN'T GO BACK AND GET FOR
YOU HOW MUCH WAY THAT GRANT
MONEY WE DID RECEIVE.
BUT GUESS IT'S NOT THE NEARLY
HUNDRED MILLION OR SO THAT I
THINK NOW IS IN THIS MEMO IN
FRONT OF ME NO --
OKAY -- WITH
REGARD TO THE POSITIONS THAT ARE
BEING FILLED --
YOU'VE GOTTEN YOU GOT
AUTHORIZATION WITH THIS BUDGET
FOR FIVE FIFTEEN ANY VERY HARD
FOUR HUNDRED IS THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING THIS MEMO QUICKLY.
ALMOST ALL OF OUR POSITIONS WE
HAVE HIRED THE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY I THINK AND THEN THAT OF
THE FIVE FIFTY WERE REALLY I'M
I'M HAVE A SMALL WRAPPED UP.
OR DOWN TO ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE OF THOSE ARE OUR
I'M HAVE HIGHER HAVE NOT STARTED
DATES IN THE OTHER FIFTEEN WILL
HAVE START DATES BY THE END OF
THIS MONTH.
HIM FOR THE THOSE POSITIONS IN
THE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THAT
ARE BEING DISCUSSED BY THOSE
PERMANENT HIRES [inaudible]
NO.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT'S THEIR TERM
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW GO AHEAD.
SO THAT I'M THE ONE THAT ARE IN
THE BUDGET ASK THOSE A BIT OF A
MULTI YEAR TERM AND THE ONES FOR
THE TWO THIRTY WE WOULD PROBABLY
LOOK SINCE WE KNOW THAT IN THE
OUT YEARS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
STILL RAMP UP YOU KNOW AS WE
CLOSE.
TO TWENTY TWENTY ORIGINAL BOMB
PROJECTION WAS THAT THERE'S ANY
MORE PEOPLE COMING IN TO GET THE
REAL ID BECAUSE YOU ARE YOU
HITTING THAT DEADLINE AND SO OUR
REGION LAST HAD A HIGHER RAMP
UP.
SO THE TWO THIRTY WE WOULD
PROBABLY KEEP.
EACH YEAR AND THAT WE BE ASKING
FOR MORE BUT ALL THE POSITIONS
ARE ON WHAT THEY'RE CALLED THAT
I'M PERMANENT OR MITTENS.
AND SO.
DIRECTORS AND WIND UP HAVING TO
TO GO DOWN ONCE THE WORKLOAD.
THESIS RIGHT NOW AND OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE.
GOING TO TREAT THEM IT IS THAT
RIGHT IN MY IT WAS DOES THIS
BOOKLET FALL OFF.
TWENTY TWENTY OR DOES THIS
CONTINUE I MEAN THE REAL IDEA
LAWSUIT CORRECT SO --
ONCE YOU COME IN AND GET THE
REAL ID AND YOU GO BACK TO THE
NORMAL CYCLE OVERDOING BY MAIL
GOING ONLINE AND SUCH THAT THE
INITIAL EMPLOY I'M.
MINOR GRAYSON YES THEY HAVE
THERE IS A BILL RAMP UP.
IN TERMS OF HOW MANY PHYSICIANS
STATE PERMITTED IS UNCLEAR IN
PART BECAUSE YOU.
PROJECTIONS BEING ABOUT THIS IS
NOT YOUR FAULT THAT YOU WOULD
WANT TO MENTION IS I LOOK AT YOU
--
IN THE YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PROJECTIONS MAY BE.
EMPLOYEES ARE RETIRING SO ON SO
FORTH SO THE REMAINS WE SEE HOW
MANY OF THE FIVE FIFTY GET GET
KEPT OVER TIME THAT IS CORRECT
OBVIOUSLY AS WE HIRE EMPLOYEES
THERE IS A HIGH ATTRITION RATE
WITH A DEPARTMENT THAT HAS.
NO RATE THOUSAND PLAY IN TOTAL
OVER.
FOR THERE'S A CONSTANT TURNOVER
ANYWAYS QUICKLY THAT YOU HIRE
SOMEONE AS A TEMPORARY POSITION
OR PERMANENT ADMIN AS WHAT THEY
WOULD CALL.
AND IF YOU HAD A FULL TIME
POSITION OPENED UP OBVIOUSLY YOU
WANT TO BRING THAT YES YOU'RE
RIGHT ON IT.
BY IRAQ I GUESS THAT'S ONE
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE RECOUP
THE PROBLEM WHICH CHALLENGE AT
THIS IS YOU HAVE A CRISIS ON
YOUR HANDS YOU'RE TRYING TO
HIGHER UP BUT SOMETIMES IT MAY
NOT BE.
ATTRACTIVE POSITIONS IF THEY'RE
NOT LONGER TERM FOR AND SUCH
TRYING TO GET MY HEAD AROUND
WHAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH AN AYE
WE SETTING UP FOR SUCCESS
FAILURE WHERE THE CHALLENGES YOU
DOING.
I'M I KNOW THE HOURS LATENESS
CHEN I WANT TO BE RELATIVELY
QUICK THE LAST THING I WOULD
JUST SAY THIS WAS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE MEMO BUT I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE AVERAGE TIMES ARE ABOUT
PUTTING THIS IN PRINT RIGHT NOW
I DON'T THINK.
ANYONE DOES ANYONE ANY FAVORS I
MEAN I DON'T KNOW ANYONE WHO
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED A TWENTY THREE
MINUTE EXPERIENCE THE DMV I JUST
NEVER HEARD THAT.
THAT MAYBE AGAIN A PART OF
DOCTOR WEAPONIZE EXPERIENCE.
BUT I I JUST IT IT SEEMS LIKE
INSULT TO INJURY TO CONSTITUENTS
ARE CALLING MY OFFICE AND
REQUESTING ASSISTANCE A WITNESS
SO I MEAN.
IT IT IT IT SOUNDS OUT OF IT
TONE DEAF TO PUT THAT IN WRITING
THAT MAY BE THE STATEWIDE METRIC
BUT I JUST.
I WOULD SAY UNTIL YOU GET BACK
TO YOUR THE OBJECTIVE AT THE END
OF THE YEAR REPEATING THAT IS
THE THAT'S IS NOT DOING ANYONE
ANY GOOD --
THE LAST THING I GUESS I WOULD
ASK HURT MALIK COLLEAGUES ABOUT
WHAT YOU NEED YOU'VE BEEN VERY
EXPLICIT AND THANK YOU AYE I
SERVED ON THE LOCAL CITY COUNCIL
WERE STAFF WASN'T OFTEN POWERED
SAY WHICH NEEDED. TO HEARING
FROM YOU WHAT YOU NEED NOW IT'S
ON US TO KIND DELIVER RIGHT TO
GET THAT --
THAT SAID WHAT WOULD BE YOUR
ADVICE TO DATE TO CONSTITUENT I
SPEAKING WITH A CONSTITUENT JUST
THIS MORNING SHE HAS APPOINTMENT
TOMORROW AYE SHE THOUGHT I'D
APPOINTMENT I'M GOOD TO GO.
HIGH WAS WARNING HER NO YOU'RE
GONNA WANNA PIE CANCEL YOUR
AFTERNOON --
HERE.
AND WHAT BUT THAT SEEMS LIKE
TERRIBLE AND FOR THE STATE SO
WHAT ADVICE DO I GIVE BECAUSE IT
IS OUT OF TOWN HALL MEETING I
THINK IN A WEEK WHAT WHAT OUT IF
YOU HAVE AN APPOINTMENT I WOULD
NOT CANCEL THAT APPOINTMENT I
WOULD SHOW UP FOR THE
APPOINTMENT.
LOW NO FOR THE REST OF HER
AFTERNOON HE'S GOT A POINT YEAH
BUT SHE CUT IN OUT.
OUR TO MAYBE WHATEVER BUT I'M
TELLING HER.
AND I THINK WHAT LIKELY WHEN SHE
COULD NO THEY'RE NOT ALONE WHILE
THE TRIAGE AND IN THE OFFICE WE
HAVE AN APPOINTMENT AND NON
APPOINTMENT LYING IN SO WE HAVE
START YOUR WINDOWS TECHNICIANS.
AND SHE WILL BE AIRED A DIRECTED
TO THE APPOINTMENT LYING WHEN
SHE WOULD BE SERVED UP AS SOON
AS WE CAN GET UP THERE SO IT BE
HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE IN FAVOR
HAD APPOINTMENT WE SCHEDULED
STAGGER THOSE APPOINTMENTS SO.
THAT SHE WOULD GO TO THE
APPOINTMENT LINE. TO GET IN OF
ITSELF IN TERMS OF ADVICE FOR
SHE HAS ALL THE RIGHT DOCUMENT
NOON BETWEEN A WHAT HER
TRANSACTION IS WITH THE DMV.
OF IF HE'S GOING TO GET A ROLE
LIKE THE SHE SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT DOCUMENTS AND THEN WE HAVE
THAT INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE.
LOOK FOR TREE AT THE LOOK FOR
THE TRIAGE LINE AT THE PERSON
SHOULD BE CHALLENGING THE LINE
DIRECT INERTIA THE RIGHT LINE
SHE SHE THESE --
BE DIRECTED TO WHICH IS THE
APPOINTMENT LINE TO GET AND THEN
SHE WOULD GET ISSUED A TICKET AT
THE START HERE WINDOW.
IN THIS TRIAGE THAT SITUATION
THAT EVERY LOCATION IT'S OUT OF
YOUR TV.
SET EVERY LOCATION ANY OTHER
HELPFUL TIPS FOR FOLKS I THINK
THE ONE OF THE BIGGEST ONES THAT
THAT THE DIRECTORS ALSO
MENTIONED IS A VERY GOING TO GET
A REAL ID ACT ON OUR WEBSITE WE
HAVE A CHECKLIST.
THAT ACTED INTERACTIVE CHECKLIST
AS EARLY AS YOU GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS TO SAY OKAY HAVE THIS
DOCUMENT FOR A REAL ID THE HAVE
THE STOCK IN THE STOCK AND THEN
ACTUALLY HAS A PRINT OUT OF THE
AND I THINK THAT'S CRITICAL.
WE HAVE ANYTHING.
THEY COME IN IN THAT THEY'RE
MISSING AND DOCUMENTS SO THAT
THE MATTER OF YOU KNOW THE NAY
THAT THE GO BACK HOME AT THE
THOUGHT OF ANOTHER APPOINTMENT.
SO THEN THEY'VE LOST THAT TIME
I'M AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
OBVIOUSLY IT'S A HUGE
FRUSTRATION I'M FROM A CONCERT
REBEKAH BUT THAT'S THAT WHEN
SOMETHING THAT THE DIRECTOR
DOESN'T WANT EITHER.
AND SO ONE OF BIG THINGS ON THE
TRIAGE IS THE TRY CATS AT THE
FRONT RIGHT IF WE CAN HAVE THAT
PROCESS OF THEY'RE NOT WAITING
IN THAT THAT.
THAT PREACH YOU LINE FOR THE OUR
WHATEVER THEY SAY DO YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT NOT BECAUSE IF NOT
THEN HERE'S WHAT YOU NEED TO
DEAL.
BY THINK THE BIGGEST THING IS
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO REITERATE.
IS THAT EDUCATION OF IF YOU'RE
GOING TO GET REALLY DO WHAT OF
THE DOCUMENTATION THAT YOU NEED
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS.
ON THAT THAT WE TRIED TO
ADVOCATE OUT OKAY JUST TRY TO
GET SOME HELPFUL TIPS REPORT
RESISTING RIGHT.
UP BE PART OF SOLUTION ALSO I'VE
HEARD WHAT YOU NEED AVERAGE
ADVICE ON WHAT NEEDS TO BEAT
WHAT SOMEONE CAN DO TO HELP
THEMSELVES I'VE HEARD THE
OBJECTIVE STANDARDTHAT YOU
WANNA BE JUDGED AGAINST.
SOME IMPROVEMENT STARTING MID
SEPTEMBER BACK TO NORMAL
HOPEFULLY BY THE END OF THE YEAR
AND WE AS A LEGISLATURE
OBVIOUSLY ARE CAPABLE AND WILL
HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE TO HEAT IT
THOSE MARKS --
THE LAST OBSERVATION THAT MAKE
ONE IS THAT I WANTED I THINK
AUDITS ARE GOOD THING AND I
THINK IT'S GOOD ORGANIZATIONAL
CULTURE TO HAVE THAT HIDING HERE
YOU SAY ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THAT.
I DO WANT KNOWLEDGE NOTHING IS
FREE NOTHING THAT YOU DON'T GET
SOMETHING FOR NOTHING --
AND IT JUST WOULD BE COGNIZANT
OF THAT I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TIME BEING HERE TODAY TO ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS IN PUBLIC AND
THAT'S AN EXPENDITURE OF YOUR
RESOURCE I MATCHING THAT'S
PREVENTING YOU FROM ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE
YOU'RE HERE.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S ONLY
ONE OF THESE PARTS I KNOW YOU
HAVE BEEN CLONED AND SO I'M AYE
KNOWLEDGE THAT NOTHING IS FREE.
RIGHT INTO REPRESENT OTHERWISE
IS NOT ACCURATE NUMBER THAT SAID
NOT IT AT SOME POINT PROBABLY
OUGHT TO BE DONE LET'S CHAPTER
THAT FOR AFTER THE END OF THE
YEAR LET'S FIX THIS BURST.
AND THEN COME BACK AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT YOU SHOULD DO I GO.
FOR RELATED BECAUSE THAT TO LONG
LINES AT SHIRLEY KNIGHT TO DEAL
WITH FOR A LONG TIME.
WHY THERE IS NO FREE WIFI IN THE
NB AS I HAVE NO IDEA PLEASE DO
THAT I AM SURE YOU CAN GET A
CORPORATE SPONSORSHIP TO HELP
SOMEBODY?
IT DOESN'T MAKE A FIVE OR EIGHT
HOUR WAIT ANY BETTER BUT IT DOES
MEAN THAT YOU'RE NOT BELONG TO
YOUR DAY AT IT HAVE INSULT TO
INJURY.
I DON'T KNOW IF SOME OF THEM
HAVE THEM BUT I DON'T MIND
DOESN'T I'M AND I THINK THAT
THAT CAN GO A LONG WAY TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE SOMEHOW TECH SAVVY
SOMEWHAT WITH IT SOMEWHAT IN THE
REALM OF THE REAL LIFE PEOPLE
THAT PEOPLE ARE LIVING.
ON LIFE SHOT BUT MY DMV'S ON
SATURDAY MORNING TELEVISION I'M
GETTING READY TO GO TO TOWN HALL
MEETING I'M WATCHING MY
CONSTITUENTS LINED UP THERE ALL
ON THEIR PHONES YEAH --
AND IT JUST SEEMS TO ME TO BE
LIKE ONE WAY TO SHOW SOME SORT
OF FATE THAT WE GET IT AND THAT
SHOULD BE THERE REGARDLESS OF
THERE'S AN EIGHT HOUR WAIT AND
ONE HOUR WAIT OR TWENTY THREE
MINUTE WAIT.
JUST A FREE OPPOSITE YET SO WE
DON'T WE I DO OFFER THERE IS
FREE WIFI IN SOME OFFICE SOME OF
THEM IT'S BEEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
GET THAT CAN ACTIVITY SIDE
VENDOR THAT HAS THE MESSAGE MORE
IT.
DOES GET THAT FREE WIFI AND
THERE ARE SOME AREAS WHERE
THEY'RE HAVING SOME CHALLENGES
IN GETTING THE WIFI BUT WILL GO
BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT IT THIS
IS THE TIME FOR THAT VENDOR
BECOME A HERO YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK THAT
BEING A THANK YOU THIS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND TAKING THE TIME.
TO UPDATE US ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
--
I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
OBSERVATIONS AND ON SOME OF THIS
MIGHT BE A LITTLE REPETITIVE BUT
I JUST WANT TO REALLY DROVE HOME
WHAT HAVE I WHAT STOOD OUT TO ME
IN THIS FIRST OF ALL YOU
CERTAINLY HAVE SOME GOOD IDEAS
IN TERMS OF THE TRIAGE BANG IN.
THE TEXTING --
YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS IS REALLY
--
CONCERNING ON WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING AT THE MPS I REPRESENT
GLENDALE AND I'VE SEEN THE LINES
GROW.
AND GO DOWN THE BLOCK A FEW
WEEKS AGO THE TEMPERATURES IN MY
CITY HAD A HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
DEGREES.
SO I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS FOR
YOU THE FIRST IS DURING THAT
HUNDRED DEGREE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
DEGREE.
DAY AND THEN THE HUNDRED AND TEN
DAY OUR DEGREE DAY AFTER AND ALL
OF THE HOT DAYS WE'VE BEEN
HAVING.
HAS ANYBODY IN YOUR OFFICE GIVEN
YOU KNOW I I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE
HAVE THEIR THEIR JOBS THAT THEY
DO BUT IS ANYBODY EVER JUST SAID
HEY WERE THE D. M. V. WE HAVE.
A BIG BUDGET.
I'M GONNA GO TO COSTCO AND SPEND
FORTY DOLLARS --
A PER UMBRELLA TO BUY TWENTY
UMBRELLAS TO PUT DOWN THE STREET
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
I MEAN HAS ANYONE.
EVER BROUGHT YOU A SUGGESTION
JUST LIKE THAT IN OUR THE
EMPLOYEES EMPOWERED TO EVEN
THINK ABOUT THOSE SORTS OF OF
SOLUTIONS WHEN PEOPLE ARE
LITERALLY IN PHYSICAL DANGER BY
GOING TO YOUR ESTABLISHMENT.
AND IF NOT.
I THINK THAT YOU REALLY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT EMPOWERING PEOPLE
AND REALLY HAVING THEM THINK
ABOUT CUSTOMER SERVICE YOU KNOW
FACT THAT PEOPLE WOULD BE EVEN
ALLOWED. TO BE IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT. TO DO UNNECESSARY.
SOMETHING THAT IS NECESSARY FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO DRIVE TO
WORK.
TO ME IS IS REALLY OUTRAGEOUS SO
HAS ANY HAVE ANY OF YOUR
EMPLOYEES CALL TWO ADJUSTMENT
THAT'S JUST AS ANYBODY DONE
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
SET YET YET SO AND TERMS OF YES
WE ASK IF WE COULD DEVELOP GET
CANOPIES OUTSIDE THE OFFICE
BECAUSE IT DOWN IN SOUTHERN CAL
NO I DIDN'T ASK IF YOU CAN DO
THAT NO I SAID WHEN I WAS A
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN DEGREES
OUT.
WHO DID YOUR EMPLOYEE JUST GO
AND DO THAT ON THEIR OWN OR DO
THEY JUST THANK HATE IT'S NOT MY
JOB TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE
PEOPLE?
THAT'S GONNA TAKE EIGHT MONTHS
YOU KNOW SOMEONE THINKING ABOUT
THIS AND SOMEWHERE DOWN THE LINE
OR DID THEY JUST THINK.
THAT PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE IT'S
UNDER THE CHIN WRISTS NOT MY
PROBLEM.
NO I DON'T BELIEVE OUR PLACE
THINK THAT IS NOT THEIR PROBLEM
I KNOW THEY ARE THEY THEY YOU
KNOW ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE THE
CUSTOMERS AND I KNOW WE CAN GET
A PHONE CALL CAN WE GO OUT AND
GET.
SOME UMBRELLAS OR THAT WE WILL
LOOK.
BE A SHOULD BE EMPOWERED TO GO
AHEAD AND GETS THE ROLE IS AND
TAKE PEOPLE OUT FROM THE HEAT OR
IF THERE'S INCOME THAT WAY.
BUT I MEAN I'M NOT JUST THINKING
ABOUT THAT ONE INSTANCE BUT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
MINDSET THAT WHEN THERE'S A
CLEAR PROBLEM THAT SHOULD BE
OBVIOUS TO ANYBODY.
BUT YOUR EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO
TIM EITHER MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
ON THEIR OWN OR THAT SOMEONE IS
EMPOWERED IN THAT OFFICE. TO BE
ABLE. TO GO TO JUST THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT I THINK
THAT ANY BUSINESS PERSON WOULD
THINK OF OR YOU KNOW ANYBODY WHO
WAS COMPASSIONATE WOULD JUST
MAKE THAT CHOICE AND I THINK
THAT UNTIL YOU HAVE A A A
WORKFORCE.
THAT HAS THAT IN THEIR MIND IN
THAT WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE IF
THEY DON'T DO THAT.
YOU'RE GONNA END UP IN THE SAME
SITUATION OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND YOU KNOW AND I HAVE YOU KNOW
I I THINK THAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHY EVERYONE KEEPS
GOING BACK TO THIS LETTER.
AND HARPING ON THE WAIT TIME.
WE PUT THIS ONLINE TODAY AND
TALK AND MENTIONED THAT I WAS
GOING TO BE AT THIS HEARING AND
INVITED PEOPLE TO WATCH IT.
AND ALTHOUGH WE'VE HAD IS A
HUGE.
STRING OF COMMENTS ABOUT.
THAT WAY TIME PEOPLE PICKED UP
ON THAT IMMEDIATELY.
AND THAT MEANS THAT THE THAT YOU
HAVE BY DOING THIS PERPETUATED.
OF THE FEELING THAT PEOPLE CAN'T
TRUST YOUR AGENCY WHEN MISTER
PATTERSON HAS TO ASK YOU OVER
AND OVER AGAIN ABOUT WHETHER.
COMPUTER OUTAGES AND GLITCHES
ARE COMMON AND YOU REFUSE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION IT DOESN'T
MAKE ME FEEL VERY TRUSING THAT
ANY OF THE COMMENTS THAT WE MAKE
AND THAT THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE HERE
WITH ALL THE BEST INTENTIONS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO BE HONEST.
AND THIS IS NOT AN HONEST TIME
AND I I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THE GOAL OF PUTTING BENEFITS WAS
TO MAKE US FEEL BETTER.
ON IT CERTAINLY MAKES PEOPLE
MORE ANXIOUS ABOUT.
THE ATTEMPTS YOU KNOW IN THE
COMMUNICATION AND THE
TRANSPARENCY SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
WHY SO MANY OF US BROUGHT UP I
CAN TELL YOU MY CONSTITUENTS SAW
THAT IMMEDIATELY.
I'VE BEEN REALLY SURPRISED AT
THE AMOUNT OF ANGER PEOPLE HAVE
HAD.
IN MY COMMUNITY WHEN THEY SAW
THAT WHEN I POSTED THAT LETTER
--
I ALSO WANT TO PIGGYBACK ON
SOMETHING THAT MS BAKER HAD SAID
THAT I HAD WRITTEN DOWN AS WELL
WHICH WAS ABOUT YOUR COMMENT
SEVERAL TIMES ABOUT WORKING WITH
YOUR PARTNERS WITH YOUR PARTNERS
LIKE TRIPLE A AND I THINK THAT'S
GREAT BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT REDUCES.
THE DEMAND ON THE FACILITIES
WHEN YOU WORK WITH YOUR PARTNERS
BUT I AM CONCERNED ABOUT SETTING
UP A SORT OF A DUAL TRACK OF THE
HAVES AND HAVE NOTS WITH THE
HAVES.
BEING ENCOURAGE HEY.
YOU GOT THE MONEY.
EVEN IF IT'S A HUNDRED DOLLARS
OR TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A TRIPLE
A PEOPLE ARE GOING TO PAY THAT
IF THEY CAN DO IT TO NOT HAVE
GOOD YOUR FACILITY.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW AT SOME POINT
WITH THE AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL
RESOURCES YOU'RE PUTTING INTO
THOSE PARTNER PROGRAMS TO KIND
OF GIVE A FAST TRACK BECAUSE
THAT'S A FAST TRACK FOR PEOPLE
WHO CAN AFFORD IT.
I AND MY CONCERN IS THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING RESOURCES THERE INSTEAD
OF IN YOUR FACILITIES SIPHONING
OFF PEOPLE. FOR A GREAT
EXPERIENCE WHO CAN PAY AND USING
TAXPAYER MONEY BUT THEN PENALIZE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE PAYING
THAT.
WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO DO THAT
EXTRA AND END UP GOING TO THE
DMV AYE I'M CONCERNED IT'S ONE
THING IF IT DOESN'T COST A LOT
YOU HAVE TO DO IT ANYWAY?
BUT IF YOU'RE PUTTING RESOURCES
THERE FOR AND AND YOU KNOW
HOPING THAT APPEAL PEOPLE OFF
YOU HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THOSE
PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE PEELING OFF.
ARE THE ONES WHO CAN AFFORD IT I
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT PUTTING
RESOURCES INTO A FAST TRACK.
YOU KNOW FOR WEALTHIER PEOPLE
AND LEAVING EVERYONE ELSE KIND
OF TO GET THE LAST OF THE
RESOURCES TO IMPROVE THEIR
EXPERIENCE SO WE IT DAVEY DOES
NOT WE DON'T NOT.
PUT RESOURCES IN THE AUTO CLUB
CELLS ARE --
AND PLACE OF THE OUT OF CLIPS
OVER NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
YOU WOULD SAID EARLIER YOU HAD
SAID SOMETHING ABOUT WORKING ON
YOUR COMPUTER SYSTEM WITH YOUR
PARTNER AGENCIES WITH THEIR PART
WITH THOSE PARTNERS FIRST.
MAY I MAY HAVE MISUNDERSTOOD
WHAT YOU SAID WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU ARE
WORKING WITH THEM. TO TO KIND OF
BRING THAT UP IDEA I MAY HAVE
MISUNDERSTOOD SO I JUST WANT.
TO BE CLEAR THEN SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PUT ANY EXTRA RESOURCES
INTO THAT THEY JUST.
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE TAPPING INTO
YOUR COMPUTER SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T THERE'S NO COST TO DMB
FOR ANY OF THAT.
NO WE DON'T DOES WE DON'T TO PAY
IT'S JUST A PARTNERHIP WHERE
THEY ARE OF ALLOW WE ALLOW THEM
TO PROCESS OUR TRANSACTIONS
VEHICLE REGISTRATION
TRANSACTIONS AND THEY ARE OF THE
EMPLOYEES OF THE AUTO CLUB.
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO PROCESSES
SPECIFIC TRANSACTIONS ON BEHALF
OF THE DMV I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE THEIR EMPLOYEES SO THAT
FOR FOR THEM TO ACCESS YOUR
SYSTEM THERE'S NO FINANCIAL COST
TO DMB FOR THAT.
NO IT'S JUST A WE MAINTAIN OUR
SYSTEM NO THERE'S NO --
COST DATA WE ARE THEY JUST HAVE
ACCESS TO OUR SYSTEM OKAY THAT'S
GREAT SO I GUESS I MUST HAVE
MISUNDERSTOOD SOMETHING YOU SAID
EARLIER.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUR
COMPUTERS IN THE TIME TABLE AND
YOU YOU HAD MENTIONED SOMETHING
ABOUT THE INVESTMENT SO WE ARE
MORE IN TERMS OF MODERNIZING OUR
SYSTEM SO WE HAVE OF?
GOD TREND VEHICLE TRIPS OF
TRANSIT TRANSACTIONS IN THERE IS
A A LOT THAT A FIELD OFFICE DOES
--
OUR PARTNERS SHOWS SUCH AS
THERE'S AND ALL BECAUSE CAN ONLY
DO A SUB SAID AT THAT.
SO WE HAVE TO MODERNIZE ALL
ACTION IS SO WE'RE STARTING WITH
THE PLANS THAT --
THESE PARTNERS DO AND THEN
EXPAND THE ALSO THESE THAT WAS
WHAT YOU SAID SO YOU'RE
MODERNIZING THOSE SYSTEMS FIRST
THAT THEY'RE WORKING ON BUT
THAT'S STILL BENEFITS THIS DMV
YES SERVICES SO IT WOULD LESSEN
THE IMPACT OF THE MODERNIZATION
OF THE FIELD US WE START WITH
THE FIELD OFFICE.
FIRST WE HAVE TO MODERNIZE AND
ALL THE TRANSACTIONS THAT ONE
TIME WHERE MODERNIZING THE
TRANSACTION IN DIFFERENT SUBSETS
AND THEN GOING AND ADDING THAT
--
THAT A MORE DIFFICULT
TRANSACTIONS THAT TAKE A BIT
LONGER SO THAT WE CAN GET THESE
DONE THE SUPPLY TRANSACTION
STUNT FAST AUDIT.
THAT ABSOLUTELY CLARIFIES THAN
WHAT YOU SAID SO I I
MISUNDERSTOOD THAT SO THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING THAT THAT MAKES
TOTAL SENSE --
AND THEN LASTLY I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT -- I IN
AND AND THIS IS PROBABLY BEEN
DONE AND I APOLOGIZE IF I'M THAT
I DIDN'T.
I IF IT HAS BUT GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE BASICALLY AN UNFUNDED
FEDERAL MANDATE --
AND THAT WE ARE PUTTING QUITE A
LOT OF RESOURCES INTO FOR
FILLING HAVE WE ASK OUR FEDERAL
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS. TO HELP WITH
FEDERAL RESOURCES FOR THIS
UNFUNDED MANDATE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THAT THE DIRECTOR I THINK ANSWER
THAT QUESTION I BELIEVE EARLY ON
IN THE PROCESS JUST MANDATE WAS.
SENATE AND BELIEVE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE THERE WERE
GRANTS THAT WERE AVAIL ARE
AVAILABLE TO DIFFERENT STATES TO
DO THAT AND I BELIEVE THAT WAS
THE FUNDING THAT WAS OFFERED.
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT FUNDING
IS NOT COMPENSATING US FOR THE
THE FULL COST OF WHAT THIS IS.
SO I'M SUGGESTING THAT WE TRY TO
CALCULATE WHAT THAT IS FOR THE
REAL ID AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
OTHER ISSUES HERE BUT AT LEAST
FOR THE REAL ID PART AND THAT WE
DO.
AS THIS COMMITTEE ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS ASK OUR ENTIRE
FEDERAL DELEGATION.
TO HELP US FULFILL THAT UNFUNDED
MANDATE FINANCIALLY SO IT
DOESN'T OFF.
THIS HUGE AMOUNT DOESN'T FALL
JUST ON CALIFORNIA.
LET'S HOPE THANK YOU RAPPER
FOLLOW YOUR LEAD ON THAT THIS
BAKER.
I THINK A AND I JUST WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE LINE A QUESTION
ABOUT PARTNERS THAT YOU EITHER
WORK AND AND I SHOULD ASK THIS
EARLIER IN IT IS WELL CAN YOU
DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL WHAT.
OUTSIDE NON D. M. V. ENTITIES
ARE ABLE TO DO I THINK YOU
MENTIONED VEHICLE LICENSE
RENEWAL --
WHO WHO ARE THERE'S PARTNERS AND
WHAT ELSE CURRENTLY ARE THEY
ABLE TO DO?
SO WE HAVE --
THOUGHT CLOTHES ARE PARTNERS AND
THEY CAN DO AND VEHICLE
REGISTRATION YOU WANT SOME
TRANSFERS THERE'S A SUBSET OF I
CAN GET THOSE SPECIFIC IS A
TRANSFER LIKE IF I HAVE A
VEHICLE IN TEXAS AND I MOVED
HERE THEY CAN HANDLE THAT.
OKAY.
FLAT ON THE PARTY TRANSFERRED BY
THAT POINT YET.
CAN'T.
HOW WE HAVE REGISTRATION
SERVICES THAT DO TRANSACTIONS --
IN THAT WHICH YOU PAY A FEE FOR
THAT I WE HAVE --
OUR SELF SERVICE TERMINALS WHERE
WE HAVE A VENDOR THAT DOES THAT
WHERE THEY PUT THESE TERMINALS
THAT WE CAN DO A VEHICLE
REGISTRATION RENEWAL ALL CAME
OUR PLANT OPERATION IF THE PLAN
NOT TO OPERATE YOUR CAR.
OKAY.
FROM WHAT I AM BEEN SEEKING A
BIT MORE ABOUT THE SCENARIO THAT
I MENTION WHICH WAS YOU KNOW IT
USED TO BE YOU COULD ONLY GO TO
THE POST OFFICE. TO MAIL
SOMETHING AND I'M JOB SOMETIME
THERE'S NO BETTER WAY TO THINK
OF SOVIET STYLE [inaudible]
SERVICE.
AT AT A GOVERNMENT SERVICE AND
SOME TO GOING TO THE POST OFFICE
IN THOSE DAYS THAT WAS IT THAT'S
ALL YOU CAN DO.
YOU CAN GO ANYWHERE ELSE AND NOW
YOU CAN GO TO MANY.
ENTITIES MAY BECOME PRIVATE
FAMILY BUSINESSES FOR THE MOST
PART TO GET A LOT OF THE WORK
THAT YOU COULD HAVE GONE TO THE
POST OFFICE FOR DONE.
THERE THAT WE CAN'T DO THAT
BECAUSE THE DMV'S GOT TOO
IMPORTANT A JOB YOU KNOW IT'S IT
IT'S AN IDEA THAT IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT FOR EVERYTHING ELSE TO
DEVELOP A PACKAGE THAT WE SEND
SECURELY IS A PRETTY IMPORTANT
JOB.
WHAT IS YOUR PURSE NEW YOUR
THOUGHT YOUR EXPERTISE ON WHAT
MORE WE COULD PUT INTO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR?
THERE WOULD CLEARLY HELP WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BECAUSE LONG
BEFORE THAT REAL ID ISSUE AND
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW THIS IS
THE ONLY PROBLEM YOU'RE
EXPERIENCING [inaudible]
THERE.
THERE BEEN PROBLEMS WITH THE
DMV.
WHAT WOULD YOU THINK ARE SOME?
POSSIBILITIES FOR WHAT MORE WE
CAN.
ALLOW A PRIVATE ENTITY TO DO TO
COMPLEMENT YOUR WORK.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
MANY DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
SO AND STATEMENT BEFORE WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME THINGS THAT --
WE WOULD LIKE TO DO WE FILL
STAFF TO HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THOSE I
DON'T WANT TO JEOPARDIZE THOSE
PROPOSAL IF YOU HAVE TO DO THAT
THE FORMAL REQUEST FOR POLO
PROCESS.
AND BECAUSE THEN SOME VENDORS
MIKE GIPSON INSIDE TIPS IN TERMS
OF OUR LOOKING AT BUT WE ARE
LOOKING AT SOME THINGS TO AND
NOT DO IT IN THE DMV AND AND DO
IT WITH A PARTNER SO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WE
HAVE.
SOME THINGS WERE LOOKING AT A
JUST NOT ABLE TO DISCUSS THOSE
UP PUBLICLY.
TIED AND AND I I HOPE THAT THAT
WILL LOOK AS MUCH TO THE MODEL
WILL HAVE TO STUDY IT MORE OF OF
IN TERMS OF THE POST OFFICE AND
SEE HOW MUCH MORE YOU ALMOST
NEVER HAVE TO WALK IN THERE YOU
CAN ALMOST PRINT SOME OF THE
THINGS.
A LADY A DIFFERENT ERA ALLOW
THAT YOU KNOW WE YOU CAN PRINT
ALLOW THE FORMS ONLINE RIGHT
OFFER ONLINE TRANSACTIONS WE'D
WE ARE WORKING TO OFFER MORE
ONLINE TRANSACTIONS ONLINE.
AND WITH THAT WE CAN PUT MORE ON
THOSE SELF SERVICE TERMINALS
THEY'RE LOOKING AT SOME THINGS
THAT WERE WEAKENED DEFTLY --
YOU KNOW DO SOME DO AND THERE TO
TAKE THAT WORK OUTSIDE OF THE
DVD WHERE YOU DO NOT HAVE TO
COME TO THE DMV AND CARE WHICH I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THANK YOU AND WHAT YOUR TIME
FRAME FOR HAVING. FOR US TO
START TO SEE THE POSSIBILITY AT
LEAST KNOWING HERE'S WHAT ELSE
SHE HERE'S WHERE ELSE YOU CAN GO
TO GET SOME DMV SERVICES OR WHEN
THIS RFP IS YOUR WENT WHAT'S THE
TIME FRAME WE COULD START TO SEE
THAT SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
RIGHT NOW I CAN'T.
GIVE YOU EXACT TIMEFRAME WE NEED
SOMETIME TO BE ABLE TO FLESH
THOSE OUT MEDICINES WERE AYE
ABLE.
TO AT W. WILL LET YOU KNOW THAT
CAN AYE WE STILL HAVE TO HAVE
SOME TIME TO BUILD THE FLESH
THOSE OUT.
AND WHAT THAT COST WOULD BE
CALLING THEM WORKING ON THAT.
I KNOW WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THAT -- FOR
PROBABLY THERE SOME IDEAS THAT
WE WERE THINKING ABOUT SO WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT IT FROM FOUNDED
LAST SIXTY DAYS IN TERMS OF
BRAINSTORMING.
WHAT ELSE WHAT CAN WE TAKE OUT
OF THE DEAN V. AND INFLUENCE AND
A PARTNERSHIP THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
THAT?
THINKING I WAS GONNA FOLLOW UP
SO.
DO YOU THINK BY.
THE END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR
WILL SEE SOMETHING YOU THINK IN
THE NEXT THIRTY DAYS MEAN FOR
ANY OUTSIDE PROPOSALS OUT GET
GET WHERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT RIGHT NOW I I'D I DID
SQUEEZE IN.
A VISIT WITH A CALL WITH THE
VENDOR --
THIS AFTERNOON THIS MORNING TO
FURTHER FLESH OUT SOME OF THESE
THINGS SO WE ARE.
ACTIVELY TALKING AND TWO OTHER
--
A ENTITIES IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
COULD DO.
TELL ENTITLED TO KNOW YOU GOT MY
TO MY QUESTION IS.
HOPEFULLY WITHIN THE NURSES NEXT
THIRTY SIXTY DAYS WE WERE WAS
NOT HARD.
SO WE JUST NEED SOMETIME BILL A
FLESH THOSE OUT --
WONDERFUL SO THAT SOMEONE ARE
KIND OF GO BACK AND TERM --
RECAP A FEW OF THE THINGS BUT
JUST SO I CAN.
CLARIFY BECAUSE AYE I DO WANT TO
GUARANTEE I KNOW MISS FRIEDMAN
LAUGHED BUT I'M GONNA.
GUARANTEE EVERYBODY WHO SPENT
ABOUT TWO PLUS HOURS HERE THAT
ALL OF THESE COMMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY.
I AND IT'S UP TO MYSELF AND MR
FRAZIER NO MISTER BLOOM WOULD
HAVE BEEN HERE HE UNFORTUNATELY
IS DOING A TOUR OF OUR FIRES
RIGHT NOW AS I'M SURE HE'D MUCH
RATHER BE WITH US THAN ON HIS
TOUR.
AND URGE THEM TO LEFT ARE THREE
COMMITTEES TO CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THAT -- ALL
OF THESE ISSUES IS THAT WERE
REYES BIRD DUH WHO RESOLUTIONS
WILL BE DONE.
ON SO WE TALKED ABOUT HOPEFULLY
TOWARD THE END OF DECEMBER --
SEEN -- SOME
RESOLUTION AND GOING BACK TO A
PRE REAL ID --
WAIT TIMES IS THAT.
THERE IS OUR GOAL THAT'S OUR
GOAL WONDERFUL.
BECAUSE YOU DID MENTION I
BELIEVE JULY SIXTEENTH STARTING
THE E. DRIVER SLIDE THE
ELECTRONIC DRIVER'S LICENSE
APPLICATIONS AYE.
I MISS I MUST HAVE MISUNDERSTOOD
SOMETHING BECAUSE AND YOU ALSO
MENTIONED A MID SEPTEMBER
IMPLEMENTATION SO SO IT JULY
SIXTEENTH WE OFFERED OF THAT IS
BEING A PUBLIC THROUGH OUR
WEBSITE YOU CAN.
COMPLETE THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
APPLICATIONS FOR THE COMFORT OF
YOUR HOME OF YOUR SMART DEVICE
AND THEN IN THE MIDDLE OF
SEPTEMBER WE WILL INTEGRATE.
THAT ELECTRONIC --
INFORMATION THE FILLED UGLY
TIGHTLY INTEGRATE THAT INTO A
DRIVERS LICENSE SYSTEM SO I
TECHNICIANS WON'T HAVE TO KEEP
THAT INFORMATION.
GOT A RIGHT SO RIGHT NOW.
I CAN GO AND ENTER THAT
INFORMATION.
BUT IF I HAVE AN APPOINTMENT
TOMORROW.
THAT INFORMATION CAN BE
DOWNLOADED IS THAT WHERE YOUR
INSIGHT YOU CAN.
DO THAT FOR ALL THE ELECT
ILLUSION THAT TANAKA APPLICATION
IN OUR FIELD OFFICE TO A TOUCH
SCREEN TERMINAL AND THEN WHEN
YOU CAN YOU DO THAT FIRST.
AND THEN WHEN YOU GET CALLED TO
THE TECHNICIAN WINDOW THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO BRING THAT UP PREFER
AS WHAT BUT WE HAVE TO STILL KEY
THAT AND SO THE INTEGRATION
WALCHER IN SEPTEMBER WE DON'T
HAVE TO KEEP IT TIMOTHY SYSTEMS
DON'T TALK JUST YET TALK TO EACH
OTHER.
AND SO THE TECHNICIAN TO BRING
UP THE INFORMATION YOU KEY DAM
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO THEM TO
GET INTO.
THE ACTUAL SYSTEM IN IT WHAT A
WISE TECHNICIANS INPUTTING DATA
INTO.
AS A AS A WORKSTATION FOR PEOPLE
TO AND PUT THAT INFORMATION
RIGHT NOW.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON
RIGHT NOW WHERE WE DID THIS IN
PHASES AND OFFER ELECTRONIC
APPLICATION THAT BECAUSE OF THE
CUSTOMERS CAN --
COMPLETE THAT AND AND AND WE
FIND THAT IT'S MORE INTUITIVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS INFORMATION IN TERMS
OF VETERANS PREFERENCES POINTS
IN -- AND
ORGAN DONOR SO THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION THAT AS YOUR
COMPLAINT APPLICATION.
BEFORE THE PATRIOT THE FLIP BACK
AND FORTH THAT YOU CAN GO AND
YOU CAN CLICK AND YOU CAN GET
MORE INFORMATION RIGHT THERE IS
A MORE INTUITIVE APPLICATION.
OF FOR THE CUSTOMER TO
UNDERSTAND --
WHAT WERE THE QUESTIONS WE'RE
ASKING IT'S VERY INTUITIVE AND
THEN WE'RE GETTING MORE UP
ACCURATE INFORMATION IN TERMS OF
SPELLING?
OF NAMES AND ADDRESSES SO SINCE
THE JULY SIXTEENTH
IMPLEMENTATION ARE YOU SEEING A
REDUCTION IN TIME --
WHICH SAYS WE JUST LAUNCHED THAT
WE OR STILL --
TRITE SEEM TO SEE IF THAT IS A
REDUCTION IN TIME AND SO WE JUST
ONCE THAT STEP.
JULY SIXTEENTH AND WE ARE STILL
SEEING AND SEE THAT.
AND WHAT PEOPLE COMPLETED ONLINE
AND SEE THAT --
AN AFFECT ON THE REDUCTION OF
THE TIME.
BUT THAT ALSO PEOPLE COMING IN
AND GOING TO KEY AUSTIN FILLING
THAT INFORMATION OUT RIGHT.
THERE WE ARE AND AND HAVE YOU
NOT SEEN ANY IMPACT.
AT THIS POINT [inaudible]
OF LOVE SO THEY ARE KEEN IF
THEY'RE GOING INTO OFFICE AND IN
FILLING IT OUT QUIRK AND WE ARE
--
IN SO THAT SAVES WERE WERE THERE
NOT COMPETE ON PAPER SO WE WILL
SEE THE IMPACT WHEN WE DO THE
FULL INTEGRATION WERE IT IS KEY
THAT CAR CALLED UP INTO OUR
DRIVER'S LICENSES.
THAT'S WHAT WE JUST SAID SO WHAT
YOU JUST SAID WAS FAT RIGHT NOW
IF I AM GOING TO A KIOSK WITHIN
THE DMV OFFICE.
IT'S MORE INTUITIVE I FILL IN
ALL THE INFORMATION I GIVE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE CLERK YOU ARE
SAYING BASED ON YOU JUST SAID
BASED ON THAT THAT THERE.
IT SHOULD BE EASIER FOR
EVERYBODY SO ARE.
ARE ARE YOU IN FACT SEEING A
REDUCTION TIME TO USE BODIES
BECAUSE WHAT'S THE POINT OF
GOING WHAT'S THE POINT OF ME.
GOING TO A KIOSK TYPING ALL THIS
INFORMATION AND GIVING IT TO A
CLERK AND NOT HAVING ANY
REDUCTION TIME ONE I JUST GIVE
THE CLERK A WRITTEN APPLICATION.
EITHER WAY YOU WOULD FILL OUT
THE ELECTRONIC APPLICATION
ORIGINALLY BEFORE THE JULY
SIXTEENTH DATE WHEN WE HAVE
INDIVISIBLE OF THE FIELD OFFICE
YOU HAD TO GO TO ADD A TOUCH
SCREEN TERMINAL.
AND YOU FILL OUT THE ELECTRONIC
APPLICATION AT THAT POINT INSULT
COME JULY SIXTEENTH WE HAVE THE
ABILITIES TO FILL OUT THE
APPLICATION ARM ELECTRONICALLY
IN THE FIELD OFFICE.
OR AT HOME THE REDUCTION OF TIME
WOULD WOULD REALLY BE WITH
APPOINTMENT CUSTOMERS BECAUSE IF
YOU HAD AN APPOINTMENT.
ARM YOU'RE GOING TO THE FIELD
OFFICE APPOINTMENTS ARM A MUCH
SHORTER WAIT TIME IN SOME OF YOU
HAD TO GO FILL OUT THE
APPLICATION I'M AFTER YOU GOT
YOUR TO TAKE IT.
HOME LIBYA A SLOWER PROCESS SO
THE PRE FILLED IT OUT YOU GOTTA
Q. TICKET NEVER OPPORTUNITY GET
CALLED A LOT FASTER.
I'M INDIVIDUALS THAT DON'T HAVE
AN APPOINTMENT WHAT'S
TRANSPIRING IS MOST ON THEIR GET
THEIR QUEUE TO GET IN THE WAY
TIME IS IS LONG ENOUGH TO WHERE
THEY THEN GO AND FILL OUT THE
APPLICATION AFTER THEY HAVE THAT
YOU TAKE IT.
SO WHAT WISER NO CORRESPONDING
REDUCTION IN TIME THE FUN
FILLING IT OUT AT HOME.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE AT HOME OR
YOU FILL OUT AFTER YOU GET THE
Q. TICKET THAT THEY'RE STILL
HAVE THE THE WAY TIME OF THE OF
THE SAY THE COUPLE OF HOURS.
THEY GET THE DON'T WANT SO Y.
WITH US IMPLEMENTED PRIOR TO THE
MID SEPTEMBER WHY EVEN.
LAUNCH IT BEFORE THEN.
SO WE WE WANNA MISSILES LIKE
YOU'RE JUST WASTING MY TIME.
WHERE OR ANY MORE ACCURATE
INFORMATION FROM THE CUSTOMER IN
TERMS OF THAT OKAY INFORMATION
BEING COLLECTED?
YOU HAVE TO FILL OUT EITHER WAY
AND DO SO YOURS.
YOU KNOW AGAIN I MEAN
[inaudible]
ARM.
SO ARE YOU SAVING TIME IN US
INTO.
BUT IT'S WHAT WHERE NOT SEEN
TIME RIGHT NOW WHAT DID FULL
INTEGRATION WE WILL SAVE TIME
AND WHY DID YOU IMPLEMENT THIS
NOW WEST PURSES WAITING FROM ITS
TIMBER.
THEY'RE THE REASON WHY WE WENT
TO ALLOW THAT THE CUSTOMERS THE
FULLER HOME IS BECAUSE I'M IF WE
DIDN'T OFFER THAT OPPORTUNITIES
THEN THERE WAS A BACKLOG AT THE
TOUCH SCREEN TERMINALS TO FILL
OUT THE APPLICATION IN THE FIELD
OFFICES SO THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT WOULD.
THEN BE WAITING FOR THE I SCREEN
TO POP UP FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
NAM FILL OUT THE APPLICATION.
SO IS EVERYBODY WAS SAYING THAT
OFFERING IT --
OF PUBLIC KEY DO YOU CAN FILL
OUT FROM YOUR COMPUTER SCREEN AT
HOME A WE WERE SEEING SOME
CONGESTION IN TERMS OF IT FREES
UP THE OFFICE SPACE CENTER OF
THE TOUCH SCREEN TERMINAL THE
CUSTOMERS.
DON'T HAVE TO GO THERE IN SO
REDUCE IN THE WORK OF THE OFFICE
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO OVER
TO THAT TOUCH CREE.
TERMINAL TO COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION YOU COMPLETED FROM
YOUR WHOLE SO WE ARE SEEING SOME
EFFICIENCIES IN TERMS OF THE
WORK FLOW.
OUT WE WILL SEE THE EFFICIENCIES
IN TERMS OF TIME SAVINGS WHEN WE
DO THE FOREIGN AGGRESSION.
I YOU'D MENTION FROM --
COULD YOU MENTION THAT YOU'RE
SENDING OUT NOTIFICATIONS FOR
DRIVER'S LICENSE RENEWALS FROM
SIXTY TO NINETY DAYS.
A WORSENING THEN --
STARTING ON I THINK AND APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTH THOSE NOTICES THE
MONTH OF AUGUST IS THE AUGUST
TWENTY EIGHTH.
I WILL BEGIN SEEING THOSE OUT OF
NINETY TWO HUNDRED DAYS EARLIER
BECAUSE IT WAS SIXTY TO NINETY
NOW CAN BE NINETY TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS EARLIER SO THEN --
AT WE MAKE APPOINTMENTS
AVAILABLE NINETY DAYS OUT IT
SHOULD START TO MATCH UPLAND PUT
MISTER AVAILABLE SERVES UP SOME
SIDE SO THAT THAT'S WHY I WAS
CONFUSED TOO WHICH WHICH WHICH
NOTICES ARE GOING OUT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS VERSUS NINETY TO
SUCH A PRETTY LARGE DRIVERS
LICENSE IDENTIFICATION.
RENEWALS DETECTIVES CUT
CARDINALS WILL BE GOING OUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS IN
ADVANCE AND THEN NINETY DAYS IN
ADVANCE WILL BE.
NO IT'S NOT SO THE MAILING THE
PROCESS WE START THE PROCESS OF
WRITING THE WE KNOW NOTICES AND
GAINED IN THE MAIL.
THAT IS STARTING AT A HIGH JUNE
TWENTY DAYS OUT IN SO BY THE
TIME WE DO ALL THAT PROCESS IT
SHOULD BE PROBABLY ABOUT NIGHT
HUNDRED DAYS THAT IT ACTUALLY.
ARRIVES AT A CUSTOMER'S MAILBOX
WHICH WOULD MATCH IT WITH AN
APPOINTMENTS BE AVAILABLE NIGHT
AUDIT SO I AYE SO I SHOULD BE.
RECEIVING MY NOTICE LET'S SAY.
HUNDRED TO NINETY DAYS IN MY
MAILBOX.
OKAY.
SO WHILE WE WERE HERE BECAUSE I
TWENTY OF TIME TO GET ON MY
TABLET.
I I TRIED TO GET AN APPOINTMENT
AT MY LOOK [inaudible]
THE IT WAS ON THE FOR OCTOBER
SEVENTEENTH WHICH I I CAN'T DO
BECAUSE THE FOOTBALL I'M I CAN
DUKE SENATE RECESS BUT I CAN'T
DO.
I IT FROM NOT DIE AT HOME ON A
THURSDAY.
ON BUT AGAIN THAT'S SIXTY EIGHT
DAYS IN ADVANCE AND THAT'S
ASSUMING THAT THE SECOND I GOT
MY NOTIFICATION.
THAT I RAN TO MY COMPUTER TO GET
AN APPOINTMENT [inaudible]
WHICH IS.
NOT TRADITIONALLY NORMAL HUMAN
BEHAVIOR.
SO ON A GIVEN THAT I REPRESENT
REGULAR PEOPLE --
WHAT I MEAN WHAT WATER AGAIN WE
GIVE YOU AND I HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION?
I'LL Y. Y. PICK A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS ONE ECHO SIX MONTHS ONE DOG
[inaudible]
A YEAR.
WHY ARE YOU STRESSING NOW
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE GETTING
THESE NOTIFICATIONS AND THEN
PANICKING AND THEN OF COURSE?
ON YOU KNOW WHY I LOVE HIM FOR
MY CONSTITUENTS --
THAN THEY CAN YOU KNOW MISS
PALACES CONSTITUENTS ARE CALLING
HIM HIS BIGGEST CONSTITUENTS ARE
CALL HIM MISTER FREEZE.
I MEAN BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET AN
APPOINTMENT --
WE YOU KNOW WITHIN THE TIME
FRAME TO GET A LICENSE
[inaudible]
RENEW.
SO DURING THIS TIME HI I
IMAGINED THAT ON YOU KNOW YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
UPDATING SOME SISTERS BUT REALLY
IF THIS IS A COMPUTER --
SOFTWARE ISSUE WHY NOT EXTEND
OUT THE PERIOD FAR IN ADVANCE I
KNOW WHEN I GET MY VEHICLE
REGISTRATION.
IT FEELS LIKE I'M GETTING AT YOU
KNOW. SIX MONTHS IN ADVANCE OR
FIVE MONTHS IN ADVANCE OR
SOMETHING WELL I FEEL LIKE I
HAVE TO REMIND MYSELF TO PAY IT
ARE -- LOOK
MUCH LATER ON WHY NOT SEND IT
MUCH FURTHER.
ARE IN ADVANCE SO PEOPLE HAVE.
PLENTY OF TIME SO THAT WE DON'T
GET CALLS AGAIN THE POINT THAT.
GILL WELL INTO THE FUTURE AND
NOT FEEL STRESSED ABOUT RENEWING
THAT LICENSE BEFORE OR AFTER IT
EXPIRES.
SO THERE IS THERE IS A CONCERN
TO PEOPLE FORGET AND THEN THEY
FEEL THAT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
GET IN AND THEY ARE NOT RENEWING
THEIR LICENSE THERE WOULD BE
DRIVING WITH AN EXPIRED LICENSE
AND IF THEY GET STOP ALONG FOR
THERE IS A CONCERN THAT THEY
WOULD NOT.
BE DRY WITH A VALID LICENSE IF
THEY FORGOT THAT THAT'S A THAT'S
A REAL CONCERN.
WILL BEGIN YOU KNOW --
AND MADE MAYBE IN THIS BAKER STE
TWO HUNDRED NOTE PILE THERE'S
PEOPLE WHO HAVE FORGOTTEN BUT IT
SEEMS TO BE.
THE BIGGER ISSUE IS PEOPLE
WORRIED ABOUT HAVING TO GO IN
RIGHT AWAY --
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY IN
THAT LIST OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
FORGOTTEN TO GO GET THEIR
LICENSE ONE THERE'S ONE PERSON
WHO FRIGHTENED PERSON TO ENSURE
TO GO BACK FOUR TIMES.
SO THERE SO THERE IS ONE BUT I
AGAIN I THINK THIS IS AFFECTING
THE LIKE THAT YEAH I THINK YOU
KNOW WE ARMED.
I KNOW FOR A FACT WE HAVE GOT A
NUMBER BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THAT
THE DATA RIGHT HERE FOR MY A
DATABASE.
BUT THAT WE HAVE GOT A NUMBER OF
CALLS FROM PEOPLE WHO --
WERE PANICKING BECAUSE THEY
COULD NOT GET AN APPOINTMENT --
PRIOR -- TO
THE EXPIRATION OF A DRIVER'S
LICENSE I THINK THAT --
IT IS IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
[inaudible]
I'M.
IT IN TERMS OF WAITING OUTSIDE I
DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE POINT
BUT IF I YOU KNOW WHEN I GO BY
DRIVE BY MY DMV ON THURSDAY ON
MY WAY HOME WHAT AM I GOING TO
SEE.
AT LIKE THREE O'CLOCK IN THE
AFTERNOON FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
DMP.
MOTHER TO SEE PEOPLE OUTSIDE WE
ARE WORKING TO BRING THOSE
PEOPLE INSIDE --
WE ARE GOAL IS FOR THOSE IF YOU
DRIVE BY THAT THEY ARE NOT STAND
OUTSIDE WERE WORKING AT TO GET
THOSE PEOPLE TRIAGE AND INSIDE
THE OFFICE IT IN IN ONE
SITUATION WITH THE P. OUTSIDE IS
A IS A BECAUSE EVERY SEATS
ALREADY BEEN.
TAKEN.
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE THAT THAT OF
WE ARE FULL BUT WE ARE WORKING
TO GET THOSE CUSTOMERS SERVE
FASTER IT WOULD BE WHERE.
OF WE ARE WORKING THAT LINE IT'S
BE WORRIED THAT EVERY SEAT IS
TAKEN ARE NOT ABLE TO GET
INSIDE.
WELL POP PART OF THE ISSUE NOW
IS AS I MENTIONED WHEN I STARTED
MY COMMENTS IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
WAITING.
AT HOURS IN ADVANCE OF THE DMV
OPENING.
SO EVEN BEFORE THAT DOORS OPEN
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LINING UP AT SIX
AM IN THE MORNING.
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT AND
UNDERSTAND HOW HOW'RE YOU.
SORT OF ACCOMMODATING ADAPT
DURATION ARE YOU JUST WAIT EDU
DOT NOT OPEN THE GATES ARE JUST
LETTING PEOPLE LINED UP.
MAY BECAUSE HAVING EVEN PEOPLE
WAY FOR TWO HOURS --
BEFORE THE DEPARTMENT OPENS IS
IS CONCERNING.
SO WE AND IT WAS SO WE ARE --
MAKE IT SHARING THAT WE'RE TO
GUN LYING IN IF WE CAN GET YOU
IN EARLY BECAUSE WE GET START
APPLICATION AND DOING THE
ELECTRONIC FORTY FOUR WE GET
INSIDE --
FOURTEEN OFFICES DO OPEN OUR
EARLY AT SEVEN O'CLOCK WIENER
STAND PEOPLE LINE UP SO WE ARE
--
ALLOWING CUSTOMERS WE DO OPEN
HOURLY BECAUSE IF WE CAN GET A
BIG JUMPS ON THE DAY.
OUT BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING
CUSTOMERS LINED UP AND SO WE
HAVE DONE THAT OPEN FOURTEEN
HOURS HOW WE ARE LOW AFFLICTING
OFFICES ARE LOOKING TO SEE.
THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO OPEN
ADDITIONAL OFFICES EARLIER.
AND SO WE CAN GET THOSE
CUSTOMERS INSIGHTS INTO WHOSE IS
LIFTED UP THE LINE OF PEOPLE
GOING AROUND THE BLOCK OR OF A
HUNDRED OR SO PEOPLE.
ON IT IS A REASON WHY EVEN IF
THEY CAN'T BE HAPPEN SEATED
INSIDE THAT THEY CAN'T GET.
THEIR TICKET AND THEN.
LIKE YOU SAID.
SO I AT IN A COUPLE IS IS IS --
RIGHT NOW IF YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WAITING OUTSIDE --
AND IN THE WAITING TO GET INSIDE
OR TO GET EIGHT A TICKET IS IS
THERE A REASON WHY WE'RE FORCING
THEM TO WAIT INSIDE VERSUS CAN
THEY JUST GO GET A TICKET AND
SUPERSTAR GO GET COFFEE NEXT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
OR KUWAIT SOMEWHERE ELSE OR GO
WAIT IN THE CAR FRANKLY.
AND SO SO THAT IS HOW WE ARE
ABLE TO SEND CUSTOMERS TO THE
RIGHT WINDOW FOR IT TO TRAINED
TECHNICIANS DO THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE VEHICLE REGISTRATION SO
WHAT IF THINGS IS YOU NEED TO
GET THAT TICKET --
WE ARE FIRST THING IN THE
MORNING IDENTIFYING HOW MANY
TECHNICIAN HAVE WORK IN THE
WINDOWS AND THAT THOSE ARE NOT
CUSTOMERS ARE GIVEN A TICKET
IMMEDIATELY AT FORCING THE
VOICES THE DOORS OPEN THEIR
HEADED THERE.
PRACTICE STRAIGHT TO THOSE
WINDOWS WE CAN GET PEOPLE AND A
LOT SOONER IN THE MORNING OUT
JUMPSTART SO WHERE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
GETTING CUSTOMERS AND SOONER
BECAUSE YOU SAID THERE ARE
WORKING AND SO WE ARE TREATING
EYEING THE LINE.
IN THE MORNING TO SEE.
WHO HAS WHAT TYPE OF TRANSACTION
DO YOU HAVE THE RIGHT DOCUMENTS
AND SO THEN IF YOU NEED TO GO
HOME AND GET YOUR DOCUMENT READY
TO COME BACK OR GIVING AN
APPOINTMENT SO WE ARE WORKING --
TO MAKE IT A BETTER CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE TO NOT HAVE TO WAIT
IN THAT LINE BUT THE WHAT COULD
YOU JUST GIVE IT TO BE A NUMBER.
AND THEN.
YOU KNOW WHY WHY WHY DO I HAVE
TO WAIT IN LINE OUTSIDE FOR
THREE HOURS BEFORE I CAN TALK TO
THE TECHNICIAN.
SO WILL IT WILL GO BACK AND TAKE
A LOOK THAT YOU'RE SAYING GIVE
SOMEBODY AT A NUMBER THEY CAN GO
IT AMELIE SIT DOWN THEY WILL
CALL THAT NUMBER AND GET READY
TO START YOUR WINDOW I MEAN YOU
HAD YOU HAVE I MEAN IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU'RE FIVE PEOPLE.
IN LINE YOU HAVE SOMETIMES A
HUNDRED OR TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
GOING ON THE BLOCK IS FRIEDMAN
TALKED ABOUT THE HEAT.
ARM ADDITION.
I DID IT IT'S IT SEEMS WE ARE TO
MAKE PEOPLE WAIT IN LINE TO GET
A TICKET.
SO WILL GO BACK AND WILL EXPLORE
THAT FURTHER --
GOING GOING BACK TO THE FIVE
HUNDRED AND AND FIFTY ARM --
POSITIONS THAT YOU'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF HIRING WHERE IF
THEY'D BEEN DEPLOYED.
SO THEY HAVE JAY COULD YOU SHARE
THIS WITH US AND I DO HAVE THAT
LIST DONE.
AND COULD YOU GIVE SOME EXAMPLES
OF WHERE --
BUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
SO AND THE UP WITH THE HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THAT WE'VE GOT.
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
THEY'RE BEING DEPLOYED TO AND
QUITE A MADERA DALY CITY AND A
PETALUMA.
SAN FRANCISCO IS GETTING.
THREE AND WE HAVE --
FREMONT WE HAVE SAN JOSE WE HAVE
SEE SIGH JUST TO GIVE YOU A
FLAVOR.
NOT ONLY HAVE BACK AVAIL WE HAVE
CONQUERED CARMICHAEL DAVIS WE
HAVE --
FRESNO IN IN THE JUST TO MAYBE
IF YOU COULD JUST PICK.
PARTICULAR I'M I'M NOT GONNA YOU
NOT TALK BY SAN FRANCISCO BE YOU
COULD TALK ABOUT A WHATEVER YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU AND JUST
MAYBE TALK US THROUGH SOME OF
THE POSITIONS HOW YOUR TO POINT
THEM TO SO WE GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE.
THAT POSITIONS ARE BEING
DEPLOYED TO THE OFFICES WITH THE
HIGHEST WEEK TIME COURSE AND SO
HIGHEST UP VOLUME OF DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND HIGHEST QUALITY TO
RELY DE.
REQUESTED CARD SO THAT'S WHERE
THE PLACE IT WOULD OF BEING
WHERE THEY WERE THE BAGASSE
DIRECT FOUR FOUR ZERO I THINK
IT'S MISTER CARMICHAEL WITH
COMICAL PASTOR.
IN TERMS OF THEM PLATE ARE GOING
TO BE PLACED THERE THEY'RE GOING
TO BE --
FIRST ARE GOING --
TO WORK IN TRIAGE LINE GET
FILLED WITH THE CUSTOMERS EITHER
BECAUSE MY EXPERIENCE AND THEN
THEY WILL GO TO TRAINING IN
TERMS OF LEARNING OTHER DRIVERS
LICENSE VEHICLE REGISTRATION
PROCESS.
AND THEN THEY'LL BE ON A WINDOW
PROCESSING CUSTOMERS.
GOT IT ARE AND IN STATE --
FOR CARMICHAEL HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES WERE HIRED
[inaudible]
FULLER.
THE DISC COMMUNITY ZAMBONI JUST
MISSED EXAMPLES OF WHAT HAS
BECAUSE I I KNOW FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY POSITION SOUNDS LIKE A LOT
MISTER FRAZIER MATTER HOW
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY OFFICERS.
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO OFFICE HER
SUBJECT OFFICES WHICH IS LIKE
YOU KNOW LEFT LESS THAN. FOUR
FIVE PEOPLE PER OFFICE.
SO AND POSITIONS ARE BEING
ALLOCATED I WANTED TO OFFICES
THAT HAVE THE HIGHER WAIT TIME
OF COURSE.
SO THAT'S WHERE THE PLACE MS
CARMICHAEL'S GETTIN WHEN WITH
ADDITIONAL REQUEST --
FOR THE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY CHI
MAK CARMICHAEL WE GET.
TO A WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
TO MONITOR THE PLACEMENT OF OF
WHAT THE EMPLOYEE SHOULD GO OKAY
SO WHAT WHAT I NOTICE IN THE
WHEN THE ONE TIME THAT I WAS IN
LINE IT'S A FRANCISCO.
WAS THAT AGAIN GOING BACK TO THE
SIDE A VERY VERY FROM THE TRIAGE
STAFF PERSON VERY INCREDIBLY --
NICE PERSON BUT SHE WAS AT THE
FRONT OF THE LINE.
AND SO IT WOULD PROBABLY BY MY
ESTIMATION TAKE AN HOUR OR TWO
OR THREE TO EVEN GET TO HER
[inaudible]
SO TOM.
YOU KNOW MY CONCERN IS MAKING
EVERYBODY WAIT BEFORE THEY EVEN
GET TRIAGE.
SO HOW HOW MUCH TIME OUR PEOPLE
HAVING TO WAIT BEFORE THE EVEN
THE TRIAGE.
SO AND SO THAT THE TRIAGE PERSON
WITH SOME AT SOME OFFICES WE
HAVE ONE OR TWO PEOPLE OUT THEIR
TREE I SEEN SO THAT WE CAN GET
THROUGH THE LINE FASTER.
IN SO AYE WE WANT TO DEFTLY GET
THROUGH EVERYBODY.
SO WE HAVE YOU KNOW IT TRAINED
ON THE BIG OFFICES SHOULD BE TO
PEOPLE OUTSIDE TREE AYE FUTURE
SOLVE REPEAT MY QUESTION BECAUSE
IT CLEARLY DIDN'T --
WAS AN ANSWER ARE HOW LONG DOES
IT TAKE BEFORE THE PERSON GETS.
TO THE TRIAGE PERSON.
HOLLOW SO SO YOU SO YOU SO I I
GET THERE MET MISS MISTER
FRAZIER GET SIR I GET THE RIGHT
BEHIND.
YOU SAID YOU GIVE EVERYBODY A
TICKET WITH.
YOU KNOW IT IS NOW 630- SO
THIRTY MISTER FREEZE ABOUT
TICKET I GOTTA TAKE A THING.
SIX THIRTY ONE WHAT TIME DOES A
TRIAGE PERSON TAKE THE TICKET.
THAT HURT THE TRASH PORTION --
GIVES A CUSTOMER'S A TICKET YET
I'D YOUR TALK ABOUT THE SERVICE
TICKET AYE WHY YOU MADE YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE SECOND I GET
TO THE PROMISES YOU'RE STARTING
TO GIVE PEOPLE.
ARE THE TIME THAT THEY GOT THERE
SO SO THAT YOU KNOW WHEN I GET
TO THE NEXT.
CHECK POINT BUT WHATEVER
CHECKPOINT THAT IS THAT YOU KNOW
HOW LONG IT TOOK.
OKAY SO MY EXPERIENCE WAS THE
TRIAGE PERSON WASN'T IN THE BACK
OF THE LINE THE TRIAGE PERSON
WAS IN THE FRONT OF THE OUTSIDE
LINE THIS IS THE OUT.
WERE JUST TALKING US ON THE
RIGHT TO TALK TO THE INSIDE.
SO.
GET THE LINE GOING AROUND THE
BLOCK.
SURE I GOT.
I ASSUME SOMETHING THAT SAID HEY
I GOT HERE AT SIX THIRTY PM
[inaudible]
SO.
SO WE HOW TO TAKE YOUR MODELS
AND TAKING ME TO GET TO THE
TRIAGE PERSON SO WE ARE MARCHING
ON OUR THE FEELS PERSON GIVES IT
A A CAR TO THE LAST PERSON IN
LINE SO WE CAN MONITOR.
YOU KNOW HOW LONG IT'S TAKING
THAT PERSON TO GET TO THE FRONT
OF THE LINE.
IN SO THAT IS WHERE WE ARE --
ON OUR JOINT MONITORING HOW LONG
IT TAKES BEFORE BECAUSE WE GET
TO THAT TO GET TO THE START HERE
WITH ELEVENTH SO IN THE TRIAGE
PERSON.
GIVES ME THE SIX THIRTY PM CARD.
THEY'RE ASKING ME DO I YOU KNOW
MY HERE TO PICK BUT LICENSE MY
HERE BECOME A PLACARD IS OUT.
YET SO THEY SHOULD BE TRIAGE IN
THE LINE AND THEN ON OUR AT THE
LAST PERSON LIKE GIVING THEM A
CARD TO WE CAN IDENTIFY HOA IT'S
TAKING THEM TO GET TO THE FRONT
OF THE FINAL LINES.
SO I THINK YOU YOU HAVE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
OCCURRING BECAUSE AGAIN IF YOU
HAVE ONE TRAILS PERSON IN THEIR
JOB IS TO MANAGE THE EXTERIOR
LINE.
AS WELL AS TRIAGE PERSON.
WHAT I NOTICE IS THERE THEY'RE
MANAGING THE LINE?
BAD THEY'RE NOT IN THE BACK OF
THE LINE DURING THE FINAL.
THEY SHE SAID THEY SHOULD BE
WORKING THE WHOLE LINE.
AND IT MAY TAKE THEM AWHILE TO
GET THROUGH EVERYBODY AND AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ENOUGH.
PEOPLE OUTSIDE TRIAGE IN LINE
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY HAS A DEBT
TALK TO AND DISCUSSED IN TERMS
OF WHAT ARE YOUR VISIT WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO.
WHAT WE THINK IT GOES BACK TO I
THINK ALL ALL MY COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY REASON FOR ANYBODY?
TO YOU KNOW QUOTABLE WAIT IN A
LINE RIGHT WHAT THEY HAVE A
TICKET OR THEY HAVE THEY'VE KIND
OF CORTICAL CHECKED IN.
THEY THEY THEY SHOULD BE.
HANG OUT SOMEONE THE PREMISES OR
SOMEWHERE NEARBY BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE.
YOU KNOW.
STANDING UP AGAIN THE YOU'RE THE
THIRD THESE ARE LEGAL
ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES YOU CAN'T
[inaudible]
FORCE PEOPLE.
TO SAID HOW ARE BEING A
SITUATION WHERE THEY HAVE TO
STAND IN A LINE --
FOR HOURS NOT OFFERED THEM SOME
LEVEL OF ACCOMMODATION.
SO THAT THAT'S IT THAT'S COULD
VERY CONCERNING FROM JUST A
LEGAL LIABILITY STANDPOINT.
SO THAT I MEAN THAT WILL GO BACK
AND TAKE A LOOK AT THAT IN TERMS
OF OF WHAT I'VE HEARD IS THAT.
I CAN'T WE FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET THE CUSTOMERS INSIDE THE
LINE AND NOT HAVE INSIDE OFFICE
AND I HAVE TO WAIT OUT ALSO I OR
AT LEAST DISPERSE RIGHT I CAN'T
BECAUSE BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO PASS
ISSUES OF EVERY SEAT IN THE
OFFICE BEEN TAKEN.
THEN THEY HAVE TO BE DISPERSED
YOU KNOW AGAIN DIED IN GENERAL
PEOPLE ARE THERE WITH THEIR
VEHICLES I CAN GO SIT IN THE
CAR.
ME HOPEFULLY THERE'S NO COFFEE
SHOP OR SOMETHING YOU KNOW CLOSE
BY WHERE THEY COULD THEY COULD
WAIT ARM.
BUT MAKING YOU KNOW MAKING THEM
STAND FOR THREE HOURS DOESN'T
REALLY SEEM LIKE A GOOD USE OF
FRANKLY ANYBODY START.
ARMED.
SO YOU SO YOU DEPLOYED THERE --
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY OR SO OP
POSITIONS HOW ARE.
HOW HAS IT BEEN GOING IN TERMS
OF SEEING COME INTERMEDIATE
REDUCTION OF WAIT TIMES AND HOW
HOW LONG BEFORE WE START TO SEE
THE IMPACT OF THAT?
APPOINTMENT OF NEW STAFF.
SO AS I SIT SO WE ARE MEASURING
THE WAIT TIMES AND SO WE ARE
WATCHING OUT WHERE THOSE --
EMPLOYEES ARE BEING DEPLOYED AND
WATCHING THE WAIT TIMES IN THOSE
OFFICES WHERE WE WANT TO SEE THE
IMPACT OF THE COST OF THE TWO
TECHNICIANS BEING TRAINED BILL
TO SERVE THE CUSTOMERS AND OUT
WATCHING TO SEE THAT THE WAIT
TIMES TO GO DOWN.
THERE ARE TRACKING THAT OKAY AS
SIZE AS YOU'VE DEPLOYED PEOPLE
HAVE WHAT WHAT'S BEEN DONE OF
PROGRESS.
SO AND SO WE HAVE.
JUST I PLAYED THOSE WITHIN THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS SO WE ARE
AYE IT WOULD GET W. I'VE A BILL
TO GIVE TO REPORT IN TERMS OF OF
PROGRESS THAT WE SING.
AND THE ADDITIONAL TO EDITOR
THERE ASKING FOR YOU KNOW THOSE
ARE WE'RE STILL WAITING TO SEE
IF WE CAN GET PERMISSION TO HIRE
THOSE TO SEE WHETHER WE HAVE HAD
THAT PROGRESS IS SO SO JUST GOT
CALLED BACK TO THE CARMICHAEL
SIMPLY YOU BROUGHT IN ONE
POSITION.
MEET REAL REALISTICALLY HOW MUCH
IMPROVEMENT COULD YOU REALLY
EXPECT WITH ONE POSITION.
AND SO WE WILL.
BE ABLE TO OF PUT THAT PERSON A
TRAINING AND THEN.
A COUPLE I KNOW A TRAINED PERSON
CAN SERVICE ABOUT FIFTY PEOPLE A
DAY SO WE WOULD HOPE TO SEE THAT
WITH THAT WE ABILITY REDUCTION.
I IN THE WAIT TIMES BECAUSE A
TECHNICIAN CAN PROCESS MORE
CUSTOMERS SO WILL MEASURE THAT.
IT IN IN THIS SO THEY COULD
SERVE FIFTY MORE PEOPLE DAVE HOW
MANY HOW GROUP ROUGHLY HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE BEING.
ARM SERVED AT VERB YOU KNOW
ROUGHLY THAT THAT LOCATION.
THAT DEPENDS ON THE ON THAT THE
DIFFERENT RATES OF OFFICE IS THE
NUMBER EMPLOYEES DON'T HAVE
WORKING SO AND IF COULD BE AND I
DON'T HAVE THAT TRANSACTION
NUMBER HAVE SOME OF OUR LARGER
OFFICES ARE SEEN EIGHT HUNDRED
NINE HUNDRED CUSTOMERS A DAY.
AS AS YOU WOULD KNOW AND AND
EVEN IN YOUR DISTRICT.
BUT BUT BUT AGAIN THAT'S AND
THAT'S WHY I'M CONCERNED RICE
WITH SO IN SAY IN THAT
PARTICULAR OFFICE YOU ONLY
ADDING. ONE PERSON TO DEMAND
WHIMS AND WHAT TO DO FIFTY MORE
FIFTY MORE TRANSACTIONS RIGHT IT
SEEMS LIKE EIGHT EIGHT HOUR WAIT
TIME NOW BECOMES A SEVEN AND A
HALF HOUR WE TALK [inaudible]
CORRECT.
I MEAN IN THEORY THERE'S ARM. TO
BE HONEST AND THAT THAT'S THOUGH
THE WHOLE POINT OF THAT
ADDITIONAL JAIL BC ASK
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY I'M POSITIONS.
THAT EVEN TURN TO THIRTIES JUST
ONE PERSON PROFITS.
SO WHAT DO WHEN HE'S THAT WE ARE
WE ARE MARCHING THE THE NUMBER
OF CUSTOMERS TO HAVE.
ISSUED TICKETS FROM ARGUING
SYSTEM [inaudible]
WAITING AND THERE MAY BE S. IS
WHERE OF OFFICE GETS BUSY AND
THEY FOR ME FORGET TO CALL THAT
CUSTOMER FROM THAT Q. TICKET AND
WE'RE SEEING THAT AND SO THIS IS
WHERE WE WILL ON REAL TIME SAY.
I HAVE THERE'S A CUSTOMER THAT'S
WHEN A LONG TIME YOU NEED TO
CALL THAT TICKET CONSERVE THEIR
THEIR BEEN IT'S IS WHERE I THINK
THE OFFICES MAYOR FOR GONE TO
COLLEGE TICKET. TO WEAR IRAQ'S
ASKINGWHY IS A BECAUSE WE'RE
WAITING SIX HOURS SEVEN HOURS SO
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THAT AND SO MARK
IN THE THE KISSES IN RURAL TIME.
BILL TO SEE THAT HAPPENING AND
CALL THAT CUSTOMER THAT CUTE
TICKETS SO BUT I'M GOING BACK TO
THIS HUNDRED THIS FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY POSITIONS AND PROSTITUTED
THIRTY POSITIONS WHICH IS SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY POSITIONS.
MEAN ON TO YOU EVEN HAVE ENOUGH.
COMPUTERS --
TO STAFF ALL THOSE PEOPLE.
AND AND AND WINDOWS SO YES WE DO
SO WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO TO
STAFF THE ADDITIONAL HIGHER IS
THAT WE'RE ASKING.
FOR OKAY SO AS AS PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN DEPLOYED WHAT HAS BEEN.
THE PRODUCTION TIME.
SO YOU SAID YOU'VE NOW.
STARTED TO DEPLOY A FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY OP DESCEND NO IT'S PHASED
BUT AS YOU'RE DEPLOYING.
THESE INDIVIDUALS HOPEFULLY YOU
WILL SHOULD BE IMMEDIATELY BEING
ABLE TO SEE SOME.
SO GRAYSON BASED ON THE OFFICE
--
YOU KNOW WE BEAT THAT SIZE OF
THE OFFICE BUT YOU KNOW AGAIN WE
WE SAY ESTATE RIGHT THERE ARE
OUTLINES WERE --
WAIT TIMES ARE A LOT HIGHER BUT
STATEWIDE AVERAGE WE ARE SEEING
A REDUCTION A WITHIN THREE TO
FIVE MINUTES IN THE WAIT TIMES
STATEWIDE SOME OFFICES ENEMY PER
TRANSACTION --
YEAH YEAH.
PER PERSON RIGHT SO.
SO WE ARE WE ARE MARCHING TO SEE
STATE WHY THE WAIT TIME IS IS
GOING DOWN BUT WE KNOW AND WE
UNDERSTAND WE HEAR FROM FROM
EVERYBODY THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS THERE WAYNE AT SOARING
AMOUNT TYPE.
Y. WORK ON REDUCING THAT WE ARE
SEEN WHERE WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WE ARE WORKING TO
REDUCE THAT TIME WE GO BACK AND
GIVE YOU INFORMATION BY OFFICE
WHERE RESPECT YOUR TRACKING THAT
TO SEE.
A REASON THAT REDUCTION IN THE
WAIT TIMES SO SO I GUESS I MEAN
FOR FOR FOR ME I YOU KNOW I
DROPPED BY MY MY LOCAL OFFICE HE
HERE'S HERE'S WHAT I'M I'M
HEARING I SHOULD BE.
EXPECTING TO HEAR HOPE HOPEFULLY
NOBODY OUTSIDE.
BUT IF THERE ARE PEOPLE OUTSIDE
THE SHOULD ALL HAVE A TICKET AS
TO WHEN THEY ARRIVED --
ON ON PREMISES SERVICE OUTSIDE
RESIDES RIGHT AND SO YOU KNOW
HOW LONG IT'S GONNA TAKE THEM
FROM THERE TO GET TO THEIR
TICKET.
AND THEN NOW YOU AND THEN YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE THE TIME THAT IT
GETS FROM THE TICKET TO THE
FRONT.
WINDOW OVER RIGHT YEAH SO WHERE
WE'RE WORKING ON OF THE LINE
OUTSIDE THIS IS WHERE YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS
IT THAT'S WAIT OUTSIDE HAS A
TICKET TO BE ABLE TO GET INSIDE
IN GETS SEATED AND GET SIR.
SO I THINK WHAT WHAT WHAT WE
WHAT I'D WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
FOR THE CONTRA THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS SOME.
ON SOME LEVEL OF RIP OF THE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY OR SO
OFFICERS.
AND WHAT THE BAND OF WAIT TIME
IS NOT THE AVERAGE WEIGHT IN
EARLY BUT IT IS AND WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE BAND WITH THE THINK
EVERYBODY HERE.
IS VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE I
THINK THE CONCERN IS THAT.
THAT THE DATA IS NOT REALLY
REFLECTING THE REALITY OF
AIRPORT OF WHAT SEEMED AND OR
FEELING I MEAN --
I KNOW AUGUST IS A VERY VERY
BUSY TIME THE FACT THAT SO MANY
LEGISLATORS ALL CAME HERE AT
FOUR O'CLOCK IN THE AFTERNOON
WAS A REFLECTION THEIR LACK OF
WORK BUT BILLY.
OF THE ARMY AT THE FACT THAT OUR
PHONES ARE REALLY BLOWN UP IN
OUR DISTRICT OFFICES THAT THIS
IS A MAJOR MAJOR CONCERN.
AND THAT HIGH I DON'T KNOW THAT
HOME.
YET WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CONTINUE ARE FOR THE NEXT YEAR
FOR MONTHS SINCE JUST IF IT'S
REALLY GOING TO BE A PROBLEM --
THEN IT ASSUMING THAT WE CAN GET
APPROVAL FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY POSITIONS HOW HOW LONG
WOULD IT TAKE YOU TO DEPLOY
THEM.
IT'S OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE THEM --
HIRED BY THE END OF SEPTEMBER WE
ALREADY HAVE BULLETINS ALREADY
POSTED ANTICIPATION GAIN THE
APPROVAL.
AND ONCE WE GET APPLICANTS --
OF APPLYING WE HAVE HIRING
INTERVIEW TEAMS OF HIRING TEAMS
READY TO GO --
TO START GETTING THOSE --
EMPLOYEES OF WORKING AT THE
GREAT.
SO I'M YOU KNOW AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU YOUR WHOLE TEAM
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SPECIAL THE FEW
COLLEGE A STUCK OUT THE WHOLE
TIME -- BUT
MIGHT MY COLLEAGUES FOR FOR FOR
BEING HERE HOPE IT REALLY
UNDERSCORES THE SIGNIFICANT
LEVEL OF I INTEREST BUT WE WILL
BE -- YOU
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT
WILL BE HOLDING ADDITIONAL
HEARINGS OVER THE RECESS TO
REALLY CONTINUE TO UNDERSTAND --
HOW THE RESOURCES ARE DEPLOYED
--
WHETHER THEY'RE BEING EFFECTIVE
ON THEM YOU KNOW MY HOPE IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
HOPEFULLY SEE THAT --
DE SORT RESOURCES WERE ADVOCATE
TO REALLY DRASTICALLY BRING DOWN
THOSE LINES AND WE WON'T HAVE --
TO REVISIT THAT WE CAN JUST YOU
KNOW.
GET UPDATES FROM YOU WILL FROM
THE DEPARTMENT ARE I KNOW THAT.
THE THE LAST PART OF THE VERY
LONG AGENDA IS PUBLIC COMMENT I
SEE A FEW PEOPLE AND THE PUBLIC
WHO HAVE BEEN EAGERLY WAITING
VERY.
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
FOR WAITING TWO HOURS AND ALMOST
FORTY FIVE MINUTES SO NOT QUITE
A DMV WAIT BUT DONE YOU KNOW.
ARMS YOU KNOW WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE.
ON THE SET UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA MUSEUM I
WORK AT THE DMV FOR TWENTY
YEARS.
AND THAT I AM AN IMMIGRANT FROM
EGYPT AND I THOUGHT I WAS SO
HAPPY TO GIVE PRIMITIVE KHYBER
DMV BUT WHEN I CAME HERE I
CHANGE MY MIND.
AND THAT WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE IS
THAT THAT I WORKING THAT
LEGISLATION AND THEIR DOCUMENT
IMAGING DATABASE.
THIS IS WHAT OLDER RECORD OUR
STORE.
AND IT'S THAT IT AFFECTS
DIRECTLY THE COURSE OF
SERVICEAND THE LONG LINE.
AND THE AYE WITNESS USE OF
INEFFICIENCY PUTTING
PREMEDITATION MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WASTED.
AND AN ARROGANT ATTITUDE TOWARD
THE CUSTOMER I AND I WROTE THE
BOOK IS CALLED THE DAY VESTED
BUT THE REAL AND I HAVE A LIST
OF PERFECT FOR EACH ONE OF YOU
THAT THIS DO STORIES ARE 1100%
FULL. 1100% BACKED BY LETTERS
WHEN I WAS A DAVY.
I DO COMMITTED EVERYTHING WHEN I
WAS THERE.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT ONE IS
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF FOR A FOR
THE SCANNERS AT DMV --
IS TOO LONG TO EXPLAIN TO YOU
BUT IT'S OR EXPLAIN VERY WHEN IN
MY BOOK AND AT THE SAME TIME IS
VERY FUNNY YOU GO TO BE SO VERY
INTERESTING IT'S ONLY THE TRUTH
COULD BE.
SO FUNNY IT'S IT'S SAD BUT IT'S
TRUE.
AND THAT REALLY IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO AUDIT HOW THE MONEY SPENT BUT
HOW THE SYSTEM AND OPERATIONS
ARE IMPLEMENTED.
AND THE IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHAT'S WRONG THE DAY OF YOUR
PETITION JUST ASK ME ABOUT THE I
WROTE THE BOOK ABOUT IT.
AND I SAID EXPLICITLY CHAPTER
ELEVEN TWELVE THIRTEEN OR
FOURTEEN AND THEN MY LETTER TO
THE GOVERNOR IN CHAPTER TWENTY
WHERE WITH TWENTY ONE THAT WAS
NEVER ON TO WHICH IS THE
SOLUTION.
HOW TO CUT IN HALF HOUR BUDGET
OVER NINE BILLION BUDGET CUTS IN
HALF?
WITHOUT ADDING THE EDGING ONE
PENNY MORE OF THE BUDGET THAT
THEM HITTING NINETEEN MILLION
AND TEN MINUTE.
EVERYTHING CAN DO CAN BE DONE
WITHOUT ADDING A PENNY THAT OUR
BUDGET.
SO I HOPE YOU THINK THE TIME TO
DO THAT IT WOULD BE CUTE AND NOT
ON THE VOCAL DO IT'S FUNNY.
BUT CHAPTER ELEVEN TWELVE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND THE
LETTERS TO THE GOVERNOR'S
CHAPTER.
TWENTY ONE AND ONE LAST THING.
TO RAISE TO SOLVE ANY PROBLEM
SPECIAL DMV.
REALLY THE REAL PROBLEM AND IF
PEOPLE OF THE SOLUTION IS ASK
THE LIST OF CLERK IS NOT THE
MANAGER I MEAN DANE TEND WHETHER
THEY MEAN WELL.
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW HOW IT'S
WORKING AND WHAT YOU DID.
AND I WISH YOU GIVE SOME TO MORE
CLERK LIKE ME TO COME AND TALK
TO YOU.
AND REALLY SAID WAS A PROBLEM
YOU WOULD KNOW WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM I MEAN I COULD SEE THE
ANSWER OF MRS SHUICHI MORTAL.
SHE SHOULDN'T THEY THEN THAT'S
THE REAL PROBLEM BECAUSE SHE
DOESN'T KNOW SHE DOESN'T ALWAYS
APPEAR WITH APPLICATION WITH THE
DATES WHAT'S A PROCESS.
IT'S WE HAVE OUR DMV BOOKS LUCK.
THEY'VE PUT EXPECT BIG. TWENTY
ONE A SINGLE ON MET THAT YOU
KNOW IT'S HUGE THE PUT ITS OWN
IN THE IN THE IN AND INDIANA
ONLINE BUT I REALLY I REALLY
THINK YOU SHOULD TALK TO AUSTIN
IS FROM GUYS YOU WILL LEARN SO
MUCH MORE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THEY'VE.
FINAL COMMENTS MISTER FRAZIER.
SO YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT IT IN
THE ADDITIONAL.
ABILITY POLL MORE PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE.
FOR CUSTOMER SERVICE BUT I'M
AFRAID THAT WE CAN TO PUT MORE
OF A DEMAND ON ME.
OF SOFTWARE SYSTEMS IT'S BEEN
[inaudible]
A UNRELIABLE KIND OF ANTIQUATED
SYSTEM THAT WOULD CREATE MORE
PROBLEMS OF FOR PUTTING MORE OF
A BURDEN ON IT.
A I WOULD HOPE THAT IN THIS
PROCESS THAT YOU HAVE.
AND ABILITY TO START LOOKING AT
A BACKUP.
HOW THEY CAN GET CAN SWITCH OVER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
THAT WERE.
AT YOU KNOW YOU PUTTING THAT
MUCH MORE BURDEN ON THE SYSTEM.
OTHERS ARE NOT WORKING WELL.
A AYE DISARRAY THAT WE'RE GOING
TO CREATE ANOTHER PROBLEM.
HOW GOING FORWARD FEATHER IS?
PLEASE DON'T WAIT SO LONG.
I KNOW THE YOU GO OUT AND TRY TO
DO IT YOURSELF.
BUT IT TAKES A VILLAGE TO GET
THINGS DONE AND HAS COOL PART OF
OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
IS TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
THE PEOPLE THAT.
WE SERVE ALSO --
THESE PEOPLE PAY THEIR TAXES.
AND THEY FACT OF LEAD DESERVE.
BUT NOT A SIX HOUR WAIT.
AND THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE IN --
IN ANYBODY'S --
WINDHAM BUSINESS --
SO.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO YOUR
SOLUTION BASED [inaudible]
APPLICATION WORKING.
IF IT DOESN'T I NEED YOU OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT IS NOT AND AND
SHIFT GEARS AND GO TO SOMETHING
ELSE PLAN BE.
HAVE A PLAN B. --
AND AND BUT AGAIN NO WAITING SO
LONG TO OUR REACH OUT OR ASK.
HAVING US TO HAVE TO ASK YOU TO
COME IN TO TWO DEMANDS YOU KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON UP HIS.
WE DON'T FOLLOW YOU DAY TODAY.
AND US SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
--
TO MAKING SURE THAT THIS GOES
FORWARD AND IN US IN A PROCESS
THAT -- WE
DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS AGAIN AND
I KNOW THAT WE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WITH THEY SERVICE
CHIU.
WHEN I WAS ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW AND HE
KNEW THERE WAS SOME
IMPLEMENTATION PROBLEMS AND?
IT SEEMS LIKE IT TO THIS THE YOU
NEED TO LOOK AT OUTSOURCING
SOME OF YOUR COMPUTER STUFF THAT
THE PROFESSIONALS ACTUALLY DO A
BETTER JOB --
AND IF IT'S THIS ISN'T WORKING.
AND IT NAY KNOWLEDGE THAT AND
SAY WE GOT NOTED TO ANOTHER
SOURCE --
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE DOWN.
AND PEOPLE ARE TAKING TIME OFF
FROM WORK AND THEY HAVE TO COME
BACK ANOTHER DAY.
HAS ABSOLUTE NOT FAIR WE GO
THROUGH IT WITH THE COURTS.
TO AND SO LOOKING FORWARD.
TO BEING A RESOURCE FOR YOU.
pSO THIS ADJUSTER I THINK I
THINK
REITERATE --
MY COLLEAGUE WE WE ALL WORK FOR
THE STATE YOU WORK FOR THE STATE
I DON'T THINK.
OUR CONSTITUENTS CARE OR FRANKLY
DIFFERENTIATE THAT NONE OF US
WORK. FOR DMV.
OUR YOU KNOW OUR SUCCESS IS YOUR
SUCCESS --
AND YOURSELF AS OUR SUCCESS IN
AND VICE VERSA IF IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE FAILING.
THAT'S OUR FAILURE AS WELL AND
THAT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE
THE TWINS ARE YOU KNOW MY CAR
COLLEAGUES TO FRAZIER IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT --
WE DON'T GET PAID TO POINT
FINGERS RIGHT WE WE GET PAID
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
AND SO THAT THAT'S ABSOLUTELY --
I HOPE YOU GOT A LOT OF FEEDBACK
YOU GOT A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
GREATNESS BUT ONLY BECAUSE I YOU
HAVE A LOT OF IT WAS IT IS
EVERYBODY --
I'D LIKE TO SINGLE OUT ANY
PARTICULAR COLLEAGUE BUT BECAUSE
WE WE HAVE A LOT A GROUPIE
CONSTITUENTS HAVEN'T HAVEN'T
SAID THAT AND I THINK THAT --
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU TO FIX
THIS PROBLEM.
AND THERE'S THERE'S NO EXCUSE
FOR US THERE'S NO EXCUSE FOR
YOU.
AND AND THAT'S THE ONLY THING I
WOULD WANT TO JUST.
HAMMER HOME IS THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE WE WANT TO
FIX THIS NOT NOT BECAUSE YOU
WANT THIS THING TO CONTINUE SO.
WITH.
OF SEEING NO OTHER FINAL
COMMENTS VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE WE OUR
JOURNEY.
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING FROM
BUDGET SUB SIX IN SIMPLY
TRANSPORTATION